ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA BAKER.
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BROUGH [inaudible]
BURKE CABALLERO CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM DALLY [inaudible]
DALY EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER GRAY.
GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY LACKEY
LEVINE LIMON OWN [inaudible]
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
REYES REVISE RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO STEINORTH
STONE [inaudible]
THURMOND TING VOEPEL WALDRON
WEBER WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA REVEREND
OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
ALREADY THE SWELTERING HEAT OF
OUR SACRAMENTO SUMMER IS WINDING
DOWN.
AND IN FOUR WEEKS WHO ENTERED
THE FALL SEASON.
I FOUND AUTUMN TO BE UNNATURALLY
TAUGHT FULL TIME. ONE OF MY
FAVORITE JAPANESE HAIKU POINTS.
CAPTURES THE CONTEMPLATED NATURE
OF AUTUMN.
HAIKU AS MANY KNOW.
IS THE SHORTEST STRUCTURED FORM
OF POETRY AND HAS ONLY SEVENTEEN
SYLLABLES.
THIS HAIKU WAS WRITTEN OVER TWO
HUNDRED YEARS AGO.
BY THE FOOT NEOCON TAIKOO IN
NIIGATA JAPAN.
THE SEVENTEEN SYLLABLES READ.
WOULD ONLY SAY A MORE DETAILED
ME CITY SHE DO MOMIJI.
A TRANSLATION IS SHOWING FRONT
[inaudible]
SHOWING BACK MAPLE LEAFS FALL
SHOWING FRONT [inaudible]
SHOWING BACK.
MAPLE LEAVES FALL.
WITH THESE FEW WORDS.
WE KNOW WITHOUT BEING TOLD THAT
IT IS SADDAM.
THE POETIC IMAGE CREATED
CAPTURES THE NATURALNESS OF
IMPERMANENCE.
WE CAN ALMOST FEEL A SUDDEN GUST
OF WIND CAUSING THE LEAVES TO
FLOAT TO THE GROUND.
THIS HAIKU REFLECTS THE
NATURALNESS OF CONSTANT CHANGE.
ALL THINGS MUST PASS.
KNOWING THAT NOTHING IS FOREVER.
OPENS OUR WISDOM I AND WE ARE
REMINDED TO TRY TO LIVE.
NOT TAKING FOR GRANTED THE DAYS
WE ARE ABLE TO ENJOY.
OR THE MOMENTS WERE ABLE TO BE
WITH THE PEOPLE WE LOVE.
WITH WISDOM EYES OPEN.
WE BEGIN TO LIVE WITH EVER
DEEPENING APPRECIATION.
NO MORE NEED HELP WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW.
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER BIGELOW GOOD MORNING ONE
AND ALL PLEASE JOIN ME IN SAYING
OUR NATIONAL.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE HIGH
[inaudible]
IT'S A HILLARY RODHAM.
STANDS [inaudible]
MISSION [inaudible]
REALLY NICE.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY AUGUST EIGHTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN RECENTLY MET AT SEVEN
A. M. I'M A ROCKY CHAVEZ
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEVENTY SAYS
DISTRICT PROVIDING CHEAP QUICK.
<c.green> DAWSON ON THIS MATTER THAT</c>
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE
WE HAVE CHEL GAS
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF SPECIAL PRESENTATIONS.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING.
TO TAKE UP SOME MOTIONS PRIOR TO
THE PRESENTATIONS MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN AID TO ALLOW THE
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
O'DONNELL AND COOLEY TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST
IS GRANTED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ACOSTA MELENDEZ
COOPER.
MEDINA AND JONES SAWYER TO SPEAK
ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
ALSO ON MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
MEMBERS THERE ARE NO ABSENCES
FOR TODAY'S SESSION.
WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE TO OUR
SPECIAL PRESENTATIONS I WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE MISTER
O'DONNELL.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AT MY
DESK FOR HIS SPECIAL
PRESENTATION [inaudible]
MR.
O'DONNELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU ARE MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE.
THIS WEEK AS A BITTERSWEET WEEK
FOR THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
WE RECOGNIZED OUR COMMITTEE
TERRY ON MONDAY.
AND TODAY WE ARE RECOGNIZING OUR
CHIEF CONSULTANT RICK CRACK.
WHO IS ALSO RETIRING AT THE END
OF THE SESSION [inaudible]
IS INSULTING TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
WE WILL BE LOSING A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE FOR MOST IMPORTANT I
THINK A LOT OF WISDOM.
WHEN WE THIS RECORD?
RICK'S WHOLE CAREER HAS RESOLVED
AROUND REVOLVED AROUND --
RESULT TO AROUND EDUCATION WITH
THE LA SHOW CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
AND SAVING THE BEST FOR LAST.
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION.
SERVING AS CHIEF CONSOLE.
HE HAS SERVED AS CHIEF
CONSULTANT FOR THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS.
AND AS PROVIDED EXPERTISE TO OUR
HOUSE DURING DELIBERATIONS OVER
MAJOR EDUCATE REFORM.
SUCH AS LCF BATH AND MANY OTHER
MATTERS INCLUDES YOUR BILLS.
MAYBE SAVING YOU FROM YOURSELF
OFTENTIMES QUITE FRANKLY --
THOSE OF YOU KNOW REC KNOW THAT
HE IS EVEN KILLED AND NOT EASILY
TURN SO HE RATTLED AND I USE
THAT WORD WISDOM --
BECAUSE THAT REALLY PERSONIFIES
NOT ONLY REYES EXPERIENCE BUT
ALSO.
IT HELPS YOU THINK YOUR WAY OUT
OF A PROBLEM OR THROUGH.
AND I'VE ALWAYS APPRECIATE.
APPRECIATE THAT QUALITY ABOUT
HIM.
AND THESE ARE IMPORTANT
CHARACTERISTICS FOR ONE OF
RICK'S FAVORITE PASTIMES SAILING.
SO SOON YOU WILL BE SAILING OFF
INTO RETIREMENT.
AND WE RESTRICTED PASSED AS HE
SPENDS TIME SAILING TRAVELING
WITH HIS WIFE LESLIE NEWS HERE --
ALONG WITH HIS DAUGHTER ALLISON.
AND HIS GRANDCHILDREN CAROLINE
INVENTOR HERE AS WELL THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
AND I YOU KNOW RICK YOU KNOW
ABOUT A SPAM.
ABOUT THEM WHILE HE SPEAKS WELL
AMERICAN IF YOU'RE YOU'RE THAT --
SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN THANKING
RICK TRAVERS YEARS OF SERVICE.
PUBLIC EDUCATION THIS IS ONE OF
OUR HEROES LOSING.
AND WE'RE LOSING HIM THANK YOU
WRECK
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
SPECIAL GAS IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MISTER CROWLEY I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE YOU FOR YOUR SPECIAL
PRESENTATION IS.
MISTER COOLEY FROM MY GAS ON
FLOOR [inaudible]
OR PRESENTATION.
MISTER COOLEY.
YOU RECOGNIZE [inaudible]
MEMBERS MEMBERS.
PLEASE HAVE YOUR ATTENTION. FOR
MR COOLEY IN AMERICA CHAMBER.
COLLEAGUES IT'S MY HONOR TODAY.
TO BRING TO OUR FLOOR --
TELLING JONES WHO IS RETIRING
AFTER THIRTY SIX YEARS OF
SERVICE TO THE ASSEMBLY
[inaudible]
AND PRETTY APPRECIATE HIS
SERVICE BECAUSE HE'S
[inaudible]
BRIEF TIME.
SERVING THE SENATE.
AND THEN THEN CAME BACK TO THE
THE BETTER HOUSE [inaudible]
ARE.
NO WAS BORN IN EL DORADO
ARKANSAS.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WE
INVEST IN NINE STATES NEED.
HE SERVED AT THE ALAMEDA NAVAL
AIR STATION --
WORK IN A COMMUNICATIONS AND
ALSO [inaudible]
ON CREW.
U. S. S. CORAL SEA AIRCRAFT --
IN NINETY SEVEN NINE HE JOINED
THE NAVAL RESERVE.
WHERE HE SERVED EIGHTEEN YEARS?
SO GIVEN TWENTY TWO YEARS OF
SERVICE TO OUR NATION --
BEFORE RETURNING TO PAY OUT
[inaudible]
CLASS.
HE MARRIED IN [inaudible]
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE AND MOVED TO
SACRAMENTO.
I CAME TO WORK OF OUR BODY
SUPPORTING THE STUDENT WAREHOUSE
OPERATION.
WE GET ALONG REALLY SHOULD DO
SOME.
HE HISTORICALLY SINCE HE'S BEEN
HEARING THE SENATE OFFERING THE
ELEVATORS ARE.
MANY OVER IRAQ.
WHO WORKED IN THE BUILDING BUT
THAT WAS A CAREER --
WORK WAS SUPPORTED THE MEMBERS
AND SEE SUMA ABOUT THEIR WORK.
HE RETURNED THE ASSEMBLY IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE AND
REPROGRAPHICS S. OPERATOR.
SO HERE'S PLAYED A ROLE IN.
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT ACROSS A WHOLE
CAREER IS MEMBERS SEND MAIL OUT.
REACH OUT TO THEIR DISTRICTS --
AND HE WILL RETIRE --
IN DECEMBER AS A PRINTING TRADES
SPECIALIST.
THREE HE PLANS TO VOLUNTEER FOR
FOR SHRINERS.
WHICH DOESN'T I'D OUTSTANDING
WORK ALL OVER THE STATE NATION
THE GLOW.
AND HE'S JOINED TODAY BY HIS
COLLEAGUES IN REPROGRAPHICS.
AND CLOSE FRIENDS AS HE
CELEBRATES HIS ANTICIPATED
RETIREMENT.
PLEASE JOIN ME RECOGNIZE A
COMMANDING DEL AND FOR HIS MANY
YEARS OF SERVICE.
PRIMARILY THE ASSEMBLY BUT WE DO
GIVE YOU CREDIT FOR SERVING IN
THE SENATE AS WELL
.
MEMBERS I HAVE YOUR ATTENTION.
MEMBERS THE SPEAKER HAS A VERY
SPECIAL PRESENTATION FROM HIS
DESK IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS
FOLLOWING THE TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN ELECTIONS I ISSUED A
JOINT STATEMENT WITH THE SENATE
LEADER.
AND IN THAT STATEMENT THAT WE
SAID.
CALIFORNIA WAS NOT A PART OF
THIS NATION WITH ITS HISTORY
BEGAN.
WE WE BUT WE ARE CLEARLY NOW THE
KEEPER OF ITS FUTURE.
THAT MEMORABLE LINE WAS DREAMED
UP BY DAVE SEE BACK.
AND SO WERE MANY MANY OTHERS
DAVE HAS BEEN THE WORD GUY FOR
SIX ASSEMBLY SPEAKERS. TO SENATE
PRO TIMES AND ONE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR.
I'VE NEVER HAD THE PLEASURE OF
ACTUALLY WATCHING WATCHING HIM
RIGHT BUT I'VE MET WITH HIM A
COUPLE OF TIMES A WEEK FOR THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
AND I CAN'T BE --
CAN HELP WOULD BE IMPRESSED BY
HOW QUICKLY HIS MIND COMES UP
WITH THAT THE FUNNIEST THINGS.
MOSTLY ABOUT ALL OF YOU.
SO WE DON'T USES BEST MATERIAL --
AND I GUARANTEE YOU I DON'T
LAUGH AT THOSE --
BUT MOST OF HIS FUNNIEST
MATERIAL IS A IS IS LEFT THAT
LEFT IN MY OFFICE.
BUT DAVE'S PUBLIC WORDS OF
ALWAYS EMBODIED THE POLICIES
THAT I PUSHED AND MADE THEM
SHARPER.
HE EVEN MADE THINGS STICK DAVIS
ALWAYS BEEN GREAT TO HAVE AROUND
AS A ROLE MODEL AND I WISH I
COULD BE MORE LIKE HIM
PARTICULARLY HIS BEAUTIFUL WHITE
FLOWING HERE --
AND I ALSO WISH I COULD OH MY
GOD HE'S WEARING A TIE TODAY.
HE'S AND THIS IS THE FIRST I'VE
EVER WORN IN HIS LIFE HE MISSES
STOLEN THE FOR SOMEONE --
I I'M JUST SAD THAT IN THE YEARS
AHEAD THAT PEOPLE ARE NO LONGER
GONNA THINK I'M FUNNY.
BECAUSE HE'S NO LONGER GONNA
WRITE MY SPEECHES BUT EVERYONE
ON THIS FLOOR WHETHER OR NOT YOU
KNEW IT --
HAVE HEARD HIS REMARKS AND AND
I'M KIND OF RUNNING OUT OF
THINGS TO SAY BECAUSE HE DIDN'T
WRITE THIS SPEECH --
BUT THAT DAVIS STATE OUT OF THE
LIMELIGHT --
AND LET OTHERS LIKE MYSELF AND
OTHERS --
AND OTHERS --
TAKE A TAKE THE LEAD SO --
DAVE HAS BEEN --
CAPITAL FOR DECADES IMPORTANT
PART OF MY OFFICE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
INSTITUTION HE'S RETIRING HE'S
GOING TO BE MESSED.
AND WE ALL HOPE OWE HIM A GREAT
DEBT OF GRATITUDE THANK YOU
MISTER CALDERON YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEM FOR THIRTY THREE SB ELEVEN
NINETY ONE HUESO BY EDUARDO
GARCIA AND ITEM.
FOR THIRTY EIGHT S. B. THIRTEEN
OH FIVE GLAZER.
THE CLERK WILL NO I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY EIGHT THE
ONE DAY NOTICE TO REMOVE.
BILLS FROM THE NOT TO FILE IN
ORDER TO ALLOW AUTHORS TO TAKE
UP THE FOLLOWING BILLS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS ON
TOMORROW'S THIRD READING FILE
THOSE ARE ITEM A THIRD AT EIGHT
THREE SB ONE FIFTY TWO HERNANDEZ.
AND I AM A THIRTEEN SB SEVEN
FIFTEEN NEW MEANT BY
[inaudible]
CALDERON.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE RE REFER THE
FOLLOWING TRAILER BILLS TO THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE ITEM TO FORTY
FIVE AS BE A FORTY SIX ITEM TWO
FORTY SEVEN S. B..
EIGHT SIXTY TWO ITEM TO FIFTY S.
B. IT'S A BEFORE AN ITEM TO
FIFTY THREE SB.
EIGHT SEVENTY SEVEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE THE I'D
PLEASE MOVE ITEM NUMBER THREE
EIGHTEEN S. B.. THIRTY SIX THE
PORTANTINO TO ENACT A FILE.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR IS
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RETURN THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
THE SENATE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY
FIVE AB NINETEEN FORTY FIVE YOU
GARCIA AND ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN A.
B. THIRTEEN THIRTY REYES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR I AM GIVING A ONE DAY
NOTICE TO REMOVE ITEM ELEVEN S.
B.. FIFTY ONE ALLEN FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE.
THE CLERK WILL AGAIN NO.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO A
THE FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL DISASTER RESPONSE
RECOVERY AND REBUILDING TO HOLD
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
FRIDAY.
AUGUST TWENTY FOURTH UPON
ADJOURNMENT.
SESSION IN ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX
REGARDING THE VERIZON WILDFIRES
DATA FOR DATA THROTTLING OF
MENDOCINO COMPLEX FIREFIGHTERS
INTERNET ACCESS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MISTER CALDERON YOU AGAIN
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THERE IS A LIST OF BILLS
THAT THE DEATHS WERE FLOOR
AMENDMENTS PENDING.
I ASK THAT THAT READING CLERK
READ THE BILLS AND THAT WE ADOPT
A AMENDMENTS AND THAT THEY GO
OUT OF PRINT IN BE PLACED BACK
ON FILE.
HEARING NO OBJECTION THE CLERK
WILL READ THE BILLS WITH
AMENDMENTS.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO SENATE
BILL TEN THIRTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BOTTOM ONE SIXTY SIX SENATE BILL
TWO SEVENTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY FAMILY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
BOTTOM ONE SIXTY SEVEN SENATE
BILL EIGHT SIXTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
O'DONNELL.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY EIGHT SENATE
BILL NINE SEVENTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
COOLEY.
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY FIVE
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY FOUR IT
WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FIVE SENATE
BILL TWELVE SIXTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CABALLERO.
FILE ITEM TWO HUNDRED SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN TWELVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
THURMOND.
BOTTOM TO A EIGHT SAID ABOUT
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
OBERNOLTE.
FILE ITEM TO ELEVEN SENATE BILL
ELEVEN NINETY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
CHILD.
BUT I AM TO TWELVE SENATE BILL
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
CARILLO.
FILE ITEM TO THIRTEEN SENATE
BILL TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
FOLLOW AND TO TWENTY FIVE SENATE
BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME MEMBER JONES
SAWYER.
FILE AND TO THIRTY ONE SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD.
FILE ITEM TO THIRTY SIX SENATE
BILL ELEVEN TEN WITH AMENDMENTS
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALLY.
BY AND TWO THIRTY SEVEN SENATE
BILL PITINO FOURTH AMENDMENT'S
BY SOME A MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
BOTTOM TO FORTY FOUR SENATE BILL
TWELVE NINETY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
BOTTOM TWO FIFTY SEVEN SENATE
BILL NINE EIGHTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME MEMBER RUBIO.
BY AND TWO FIFTY NINE SET UP
ELEVEN FIFTY TO WITH AMENDMENTS
BY SOME A MEMBER WOULD.
BOTTOM TO SIXTY SIX SENATE BILL
THREE NINETY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
NAZARIAN.
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY SEVEN SENATE
BILL FIVE THOUGH TO WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
FRAZIER.
FILE INTO SEVENTY FOUR SENATE
BILL EIGHTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS
BY SOME THE MEMBER KANSEN CHU.
BOTTOM TO EIGHTY TWO SENATE BILL
TEN OH FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SOME REMEMBER WALDRON.
BOTTOM TO EIGHTY THREE SENATE
BILL TEN OH EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
WOULD.
BOB I AM TWO EIGHTY FIVE SENATE
BILL TEN NINETEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO.
BOTTOMTWO EIGHTY SIX SENATE
BILL TEND TO ANYONE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL.
BUT I AM TWO EIGHTY SEVEN SAID
ABOUT TEN TWENTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY.
FILE AND TO NINETY SENATE BILL
ELEVEN HUNDRED WITH AMENDMENTS
BY SOME A MEMBER BONTA.
BY AND TO NINETY FORCE AT ABOUT
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
CERVANTES.
BOTTOM TO NINETY NINE CENT ABOUT
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
ARAMBULA.
BY AM THREE OH NINE SIMPLE
TWELVE NINETY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA.
BY AND THREE TEN SAID ABOUT
TWELVE NINETY FOURTH AMENDMENT'S
BY SOME A MEMBER COOLEY.
FILE ITEM THREE NINETEEN SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
GLORIA.
FILE ITEM THREE TWENTY THREE
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN NO THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
REYES.
BOTTOM THREE TWENTY SEVEN SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
QUIRK.
BY AND THREE TWENTY NINE SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER LOW.
BY AND THREE THIRTY SAMPLE
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
DAVID CHIU.
FILE ITEM THREE THIRTY SEVEN
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS WISELY MEMBER
CERVANTES.
BOTTOM THREE THIRTY FORTY ONE
SET OF ELEVEN SIXTY FOURTH
AMENDMENT'S BY SOME A MEMBER
DALY.
BOTTOM THREE FIFTY EIGHT SIMPLE
FIVE SEMI SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
BY FAMILY MEMBER GALLAGHER.
BOTTOM THREE FIFTY NINE SYMBOL
SIX NINETY FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS
BY FAMILY MEMBER CARILLO.
BOTTOM THREE SIXTY EIGHT SENATE
BILL EIGHT THIRTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
LEVINE.
FILE AND THREE SIXTY NINE
CYNICAL EIGHT THIRTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE.
BOTTOM THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
SENATE BILL NINE OH FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
SANTIAGO.
BY AND THREE SEVENTY ONE SIMPLE
NINE TWENTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
LEVINE.
BY AND THREE SEMI FOR SENATE
BILL NINE SIXTY WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
BOB I AM THREE SEVENTY FIVE
SENATE BILL NINE SIXTY SIX WITH
THE MEMONS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY.
FILE ITEM THREE EIGHTY THREE
SAID ABOUT TEN FORTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SELLING MEMBER
REYES.
BY AND THREE NINETY CYNICAL TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SOME REMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
BOTTOM THREE NINETY ONE SAID
ABOUT TEN NINETY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES.
BY AND FOR A SIX AND A THIRTEEN
FORTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
FILE ITEM FOR ELEVEN CYNICAL
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING.
FILE ITEM FOR FOURTEEN SIMPLE
FORTY FORTY SO NUMBER BONTA.
BOTTOM FOR TWENTY SENATE BILL
FIVE THIRTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS
BY SOME A MAC THERE AGAR CURRY.
BOTTOM FOR TWENTY TWO SIMPLE TEN
FIFTY ONE BY WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SELENA BURGRAVE.
BOTTOM FOUR THIRTY EIGHT SIMPLE
THIRTEEN A FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAKER.
THANK YOU KATIE.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF THE
AMENDMENT SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
I OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YEAH HAVE THE BILLS ARE AMENDED
AND ARE OUT OF PRINT AND BACK
[inaudible]
ON FILE.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT WILL
SIX TO A THE FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS. TO ALLOW THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TO MEET
TODAY UPON ADJOURNMENT OF
SESSION REPORT THIRTY SEVEN TO
HEAR THE FOLLOWING BILLS ABA
SEVENTEEN AB FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
QUIRK SILVA.
AB FIVE OH TO PORTANTINO ACR TWO
SIXTY THREE REVERSE ACR TWO
SEVEN SIX SOLACE SCR ONE ELEVEN
LEYVA AND SJ OUR THIRTY MCGUIRE.
MISS WALDRON AYE WE OPPOSE THAT
MOTION THEN ASK FOR ALL CALL
MISS WALDRON IS WITHHOLDING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT IN THIS CASE
MISTER CALDERON.
MOVES AND MISTER GIPSON SECONDS.
THAT THE RULES BE SUSPENDED
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
SURE CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTES MISS WALDRON IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE MISTER CALDERON.
ISASKING FOR AN I. MISS WALDRON
A NO.
THIS TAKES FORTY ONE ON THE
RULES SUSPENSION THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE [inaudible]
MEMBERS [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE SHALLOW BUT I
FORTY FOUR KNOWS EIGHTEEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
AND MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I
AM RE REFER IN THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER.
FOURTEEN AB THREE FORTY NINE
MCCARTY TO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTEEN AB FIVE OH FIVE
CABALLERO TO THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE I DON'T
NUMBER SIXTEEN AB SEVEN HUNDRED
JONES SAWYER TO THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE.
ITEM SEVENTEEN AB TEN SIXTY FIVE
JONES SAWYER TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE.
ITEM NINETEEN AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX LEVINE TO THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER FORTY AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY THREE HAS AREA INTO
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY TWO AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
NINE RUBIO TO THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE.
ALSO MEMBERS PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVEN SEVEN POINT
TWO I AM REVISING.
THE REFERRAL OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR LEYVA TO INCLUDE RE REFER
IN THE BILL TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AFTER IT IS HEARD BY THE HIGHER
EDUCATION [inaudible]
COMMITTEE
.
OKAY MEMBERS WE HAVE LOTS OF
BUSINESS BEFORE THE BODY TODAY
WE ARE GOING TO START AT THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE.
THE SENATE THIRD READING.
FILE ITEMS.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN THROUGH.
ONE SIXTY PASS AND RETAIN
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING IT TAKE UP
FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY ONE THIS IS S. B..
FIVE NINETEEN NEVER CEASES FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS I GOT
IT.
THIS A FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENT CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
GIPSON.
MISTER GIBSON ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBER I RISE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDING S. B. FIVE
NINETEEN THESE AMENDMENTS WOULD
ALLOW CALTRANS TO ENTER.
TO LEASES WITH THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE IS THE LOS ANGELES SO THAT
UP TO TEN PARTIALS IN EACH CITY
CAN BE USED FOR EMERGENCY
SHELTERS HOMELESS SHELTERS AND
FEEDING PROGRAMS.
THESE AMENDMENTS GOES OUT TO
PRINCE AND BACK ON FILE.
MISS WALDRON.
WE OPPOSE THE AMENDMENT.
MEMBERS WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON THE AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TELL I ABOUT ICE
FORTY FOUR KNOWS EIGHTEEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED.
BILLS OUT TO PRINTED BACK ON
FILE.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS.
ONE SIXTY THREE THROUGH.
ONE SIXTY FIVE WE'VE DISPENSED
WITH ITEMS ONE SIXTY SIX THROUGH.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE
FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY NINE S. B.
[inaudible]
EIGHT TWENTY CORKERY.
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY INTO CIVIL PROCEDURE
[inaudible]
MS GONZALES.
FLETCHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
SORRY APPARENTLY WE SWITCHED
[inaudible]
BILLS --
GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY
WOULD BAN SECRET SETTLEMENTS AND
SEXUAL HARASSMENT SEXUAL ASSAULT
IN SEX DISCRIMINATION CASES.
THIS BILL WILL EMPOWER VICTIMS
BY ALLOWING THEM TO REQUEST
CONFIDENTIALITY CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA LAW DOES NOT ENFORCE
CONFIDENTIALITY AGREEMENTS IF
THEY INVOLVE A FELONY CHARGE OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT OR RAPE.
IN CASES OF ELDER INDEPENDENT
ADULT ABUSE SO EIGHT S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY TAKES THE NEXT LOGICAL
STEP BY COVERING ALL CASES OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ASSAULT AND
DISCRIMINATION.
IS WE'VE CLEARLY SEEN OVER THE
LAST YEARS ME TWO MOVEMENT HAS
GAINED MOMENTUM SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND OTHER TYPES OF
NON FELONY SEXUAL ASSAULT ARE
STILL ALLOWED TO BE HIDDEN FROM
PUBLIC AYE.
BE A SECRET SETTLEMENTS IN SHORT
SECRETS UNMANNED SETTLEMENTS
HELP.
PERPETRATORS EVADE JUSTICE.
WE ALL DESERVE TO LIVE AND WORK
FREE FROM SEXUAL HARASSMENT
ASSAULT DISCRIMINATION AND SP
EIGHT TWENTY ONE POWER VICTIMS
SO THAT THEY CAN NOT THOSE THAT
RASTER ATTACK THEM CAN DECIDE
WHAT IS BEST FOR THEM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE I'VE.
MS MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
AYE THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS WITH
THIS BILL I THINK WE ALL AGREE.
THAT SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE
WITH RESPECT TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WHETHER IT'S IN THIS
BUILDING OR WHETHER IT'S IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
BUT THERE'S ONE THING TO
CONSIDER WITH THIS BILL INDICTS --
SOMETIMES PEOPLE WANT
[inaudible]
THAT CONFIDENTIALITY.
SOMETIMES THEY DON'T WANT WHAT
HAS HAPPENED TO THEM TO BE
PUBLIC AND THEY WANT TO SETTLE.
WITH THEIR EMPLOYER --
YOU KNOW WHAT WITHOUT HAVING IT
PERHAPS MADE PUBLIC ARE SPLASHED
ACROSS THE PAPERS AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING WE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL.
ABOUT TAKING AWAY FROM THEM I'M
I AGREE THAT IT IS --
NOT APPROPRIATE WHEN SOMEONE IS
BULLIED INTO IT HOWEVER THERE
ARE TIMES WHEN THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT AN EMPLOYEE WANTS.
THE SECOND POINT THAT I WILL
BRING UP WITH THIS BILL IS THAT
IT.
DOES NOT AND APPLY TO GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES.
SO I'M NOT SURE WHY WE WOULD
APPLY THESE TYPES OF ROLES.
TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR BUT NOT TO
OURSELVES AND TO GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND I RECOGNIZE THAT WE
ARE.
TRYING TO WHAT KIND OF ATTACK
THIS PROBLEM AT ALL FRIENDS WE
CAN'T DO EVERYTHING ALL AT ONCE
[inaudible]
BUT IT'S HYPOCRITICAL FOR US TO
PASS A BILL LIKE THIS AND SAY
IT'S GOOD FOR YOU BUT NOT FOR US
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING I COULD
HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED VERY EASILY
IN THIS BILL BUT I WASN'T SO.
FOR THOSE REASONS --
I WOULD ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MS MELENDEZ SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU MAKE
LOVE THINK ILL AND THIS BILL IS
RECENTLY AMENDED WOULD ALLOW THE
VICTIM TO REQUEST TO KEEP
CONFIDENTIAL ANY PERSONAL
INFORMATION THAT COULD REVEAL
THE VICTIMS IDENTITIES.
SO I THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN --
FIRST OF ALL DO YOU DO ADDRESS
THE FIRST [inaudible]
PROBLEM THE SECOND PROVISION HAS
BEEN AMENDED TO ENSURE.
THAT EVEN THAT'S MORE LIMITED
CONFIDENTIALLY PROVISION WOULD
NOT APPLY WHERE ONE PARTY TO THE
AGREEMENT IS A PUBLIC OFFICIAL
OR GOVERNMENT ENTITY.
THIS AMENDMENT RESPONSE TO
CONCERNS FROM THE NEWSPAPER
INDUSTRY THAT GOVERNMENT RECORDS
MUST BE AVAILABLE FOR PUBLIC
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT WHICH IS EXISTING
LAW.
SO HOPEFULLY --
PEOPLE READ THE BILL AND THE
AMENDMENTS AND WILL VOTE
ACCORDINGLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
ABOUT.
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS OUT OF VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
EYES.
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS FOURTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS ONE SEVENTY
THREE ONE SEVENTY TWO WE'RE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM. ONE SEVENTY THREE
AND WE'RE GOING TO PASS A RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY FOUR WE DISPENSE
WITH FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY FIVE
HOUSE RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS.
ONE SEVENTY SIX THROUGH.
ONE EIGHTY TWO MEMBERS I
NEGLECTED SECOND READING.
COME BACK TO SECOND READING FOR
A MOMENT SECOND READING CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY TRY RESOLUTION FIFTY
WITH AMENDMENTS AND SENATE BILL
EIGHT TWENTY TWO WITH A MOMENT
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY THREE S. B.
[inaudible]
SIX OH SEVEN CORKERY.
SENATE BILL SIX OR SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY FAMILY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU MAKE AN
OPEN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
S. B. SIX OR SEVEN I'LL BUILD
UPON PREVIOUS LEGISLATION BY
LINNANE WILLFUL DEFIANT
SUSPENSIONS EXPULSIONS FOR
CERTAIN GRADE LEVELS ENSURING WE
KEEP OUR STUDENTS IN SCHOOL AND
REDUCE OUR LIKELIHOOD OF
DROPPING OUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS FLETCHER THESE ARE
AMENDMENTS BEFORE THE BODY WE
WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE.
MISS WALDRON IS WITHHOLDING WE
ON THE AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON
THE AMENDMENTS ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE THESE ARE
AMENDMENTS.
ON S. B..
SIX OH SEVEN MAJORITY PRESIDENTS
AND VOTING ON AMENDMENTS
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
THREE KNOWS SEVENTEEN THE
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL IS
OUT OF PRINT.
AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS.
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS. ONE
EIGHTY SIX AND ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
WE'VE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT THAT BRINGS US
TO FOLLOW HIM WHEN EIGHTY NINE
WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY NINE PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEMS.
ONE NINETY ONE NINETY ONE WE ARE
IT FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY TWO THIS IS S. B..
TEN EIGHTY FIVE THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS COURT AGREED WITH
AMENDMENTS.
SEND SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALLED AROUND.
CALDERON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS TO
S. B. TEN EIGHTY FIVE S. B.
TENNEY FIVE ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE STEWARDS. FOR
THEIR UNIONS ARE ABLE TO TAKE
TIME OFF FROM REGULAR JOBS
PERFORMED UNION RESPONSIBILITIES.
SENATOR HAS AGREED TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS WHICH REMOVE THE
MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF SERVICE CREDIT.
A STEWARD CAN EARN.
THANK YOU KNOW RESPECTFULLY ASK
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON MISS
WALDRON.
WE OPPOSE THE AMENDMENT.
MEMBERS THIS WILL BE A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
QUIRK OF NARAL.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
THESE ARE THE AMENDMENTS ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MAJORITY PRESIDENT VOTING.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
SEVEN NO SEVENTEEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED.
THE BILLS OUT OF PRINT.
AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM
.
ONE NINETY THREE MEMBERS THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY THREE SB
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY.
PASSING TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY THREE PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM ONE ANY.
FOR THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY SIX S. B.
[inaudible]
TWELVE THIRTY SIX CORKERY.
SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY SIX BY
SENATOR MINING AND ACTUALLY IN
THE COMMERCIAL VEHICLE DRIVERS
MISTER STONE YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND MEMBERS TO GET A COMMERCIAL
DRIVER'S LICENSE TO DRIVE BUSES
OR TRUCKS TAKES.
THE THIRD AMOUNT OF SKILL AND
TRAINING WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IT A LINES CALIFORNIA TRAINING
GUIDELINES WITH SOME RECENT
FEDERAL STANDARDS AND IT
INCLUDES A CERTAIN AMOUNT.
OF ADDITIONAL BEHIND THE WHEEL
TRAINING TO ENSURE THAT OUR
ROADS OUR TRUCK DRIVERS ARE
COMMERCIAL CLASS.
CARRIERS ARE SAFE THIS IS A BILL
THAT COMES OUT OF A TRAGIC
ACCIDENT THAT HANNAH THAT
HAPPENED IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
WHERE THERE WAS A DRIVER OF A
VERY VERY HEAVY TRUCK THAT WAS
NOT PROPERLY TRAINED DID NOT
APPROPRIATELY UNDERSTAND THE
LOAD HE WAS CARRYING AND
UNFORTUNATELY?
KILLED SOMEONE WHEN HE STRUCK A
VEHICLE FROM BEHIND SO ON BEHALF
IS THAT OUR MONEY I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IN YOUR AYE
VOTES.
MS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL --
AS WE KNOW THERE'S GOING TO BE A
SHORTAGE AND THERE IS A SHORTAGE
OF FOLKS WHO CAN DRIVE
COMMERCIAL VEHICLES.
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
THOSE WHO ARE TRAINED ARE
SUFFICIENTLY TRAINED OF FOR
SAFETY REASONS I URGE AND I'VE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SORRY MISSED FRAZIER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
OR TODAY OF S. B..
TWELVE THIRTY SIX WELL
CALIFORNIA REQUIRES THOSE UNDER
EIGHTEEN TO HAVE FIFTY HOURS OF
BEHIND THE WHEEL TRAINING BEFORE
THEY CAN GET A LICENSE.
THERE IS CURRENTLY NO BEHIND THE
WHEEL TRAINING REQUIREMENT FOR
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO DRIVE A BIG
RIG.
S. B. TWELVE THIRTY SIX IS A
COMMONSENSE MEASURE TO REQUIRE
BEHIND THE WHEEL TRAINING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE SEEKING A
COMMERCIAL LICENSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT
VOTE [inaudible]
THINGS FRAZIER.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THERE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIED ABOUT I. SIXTY
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
AND RETAIN.
HOW FILE ITEMS?
ONE NINETY SIX ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
THAT BRINGS US FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY EIGHT S. B..
TWELVE FIFTY TWO KERKORIAN.
SENATE BILL TWELVE FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR PAN AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT.
MR THURMAN HUMANE OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT S. B..
TWELVE FIFTY TWO OF THIS IS A
BILL THAT BILLS ON THE LAW THAT
SAYS THAT WORKERS HAVE THE RIGHT
TO SEE --
THEIR RECORDS AT WORK AT THIS
BILL SIMPLY SAYS THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO PAY TO PROVIDE
THEIR OWN COPIES IN THAT THEY
SHOULD BE PROVIDED THEM.
BY THEIR EMPLOYERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON S. B..
TWELVE FIFTY TWO THANK THIS
THURMOND.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WAS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE FOUND ONE NINETY
NINE S. B. FOURTEEN AWAY CORKERY.
SAMPLE FORTINO EIGHT BY SENATOR
PAN AND ACTUALLY TO CIGARETTES
DOCTOR WILL YOU MAY OPEN.
WHEN MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I'M PRESENTING SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN AWAY FROM BEHALF OF
SENATOR PAN?
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE PASSAGE
OF THE CALIFORNIA CIGARETTE FIRE
SAFETY AND FIREFIGHTER
PROTECTION ACT CIGARETTES SOLD
IN OUR STATE HAVE BEEN REQUIRED
TO MEET CERTAIN IGNITION
STANDARDS.
CIGARETTES MEETING THE STANDARDS
KNOWN AS REDUCED IGNITION
STRENGTH OR FIRE SAFE CIGARETTES
ARE DESIGNED WAS EXTINGUISHED
WHEN NOT BEEN ACTIVELY SMOKE.
DESPITE THE SUCCESS OF THE FIRE
SAFETY ACT IN REDUCING SMOKE
RELATED FIRE DEATHS TO THE POLLS
REMAIN WHICH HAVE HINDERED OUR
ABILITY TO KEEP NON FIRE.
SAFE CIGARETTES FROM THIS BEEN
DISTRIBUTING CALIFORNIA AS
BEFORE TINO EIGHT WILL MAKE A
TECHNICAL CHANGE BY DEEMING
NONCE NON FIRE SAFE CIGARETTES
AS CONTRABAND PER SE.
THIS WILL ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS TO ME PRODUCTS WHEN
THEY'RE BROUGHT TO OUR STATE.
WHO ALSO ELIMINATED EXEMPTION
THAT KURT CURRENTLY EXISTS IN
THE LAW WHICH ALLOWED NINE SAFE
BY A NON FIRE SAFE CIGARETTES IN
THE CALIFORNIA JUST SO LONG AS
THE MANUFACTURE CLAIMED THEY
WERE INTENDED FOR SALE IN
ANOTHER STATE?
NOW THESE PRODUCTS ARE BANNED
ACROSS THE COUNTRY MAIN
ELIMINATE THIS LOOPHOLE ALLOWED
MANUFACTURERS TO INTRODUCE HER
UNSAFE PRODUCTS INTO OUR STATE.
AS BEFORE TO NAY WILL HELP US
FURTHER PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
FROM THE DANGER FIRES CAUSED BY
CIGARETTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD.
SAYING NO.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AREN'T ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS SARAJEVO
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE THAT ICE.
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS FOR THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE BACK IN THE FILE THE FILE
ITEM.
ONE NINETY THREE I TAKE UP SB.
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO IS FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY THREE SB ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO CORPORAL READ.
SENATE ELEVEN SIXTY TWO BY
SENATOR PAN AND ACTUALLY THE
STATE GOVERNMENT.
MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS
A DISTRICT BILL FOR ME AND OF
COURSE FOR CENTER PAN RELATE TO
IT INFILL HOUSING.
OPPORTUNITY JUST A FEW BLOCKS
HERE FROM THE CAPITAL
UNFORTUNATELY THE NINETEEN
NINETY TWO CAPITAL OF YOU
PROTECTION ACT SET A HEIGHT
RESTRICTION.
ON THIS PARCEL INADVERTENTLY
THIS SIDE CLARIFY THIS ISSUE AND
ALLOWS THAT GREAT INFILL HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITY TAKE TO
TAKE PLACE JUST UP BLOCKS WITH A
CAPITAL THANK YOU.
FAMOUS MCCARTY SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ALL TIME BUT I SEE
SIXTY NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WERE FILE ITEM TO A ONE S. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
QUICK READ WITH AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHILD.
MISTER CHOW ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS FOR
SP.
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR THIS
MEASURE DIRECTS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ESTABLISH AN ADVISORY
GROUP TO STUDY THE SPREAD OF
FALSE INFORMATION.
THROUGH INTERNET BASED SOCIAL
MEDIA PIPE AND DRAFT A MOTTO
STRATEGIC PLAN TO MEDICAID THE
SPREAD OF FALSE INFORMATION
THROUGH PLATFORMS.
THE AMENDMENTS MAKE THE LAW
CONTINGENT ON THE RECEIPT OF
PRIVATE FUNDING TO ESTABLISH THE
ADVISORY GROUP I ASKED WHERE I
GO.
NAMES SHALL MISS WALDRON UP WE
OPPOSE THE AMENDMENTS AND THAT'S
FOR ALL CALL.
MS WALTERS REQUESTING A ROLL
CALL VOTE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON THE MEMO. TO ADD TO S. B..
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MAJORITY PRESENT IN VOTING
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE WRONG TIED ABOUT EYES
THIRTY NINE KNOWS TWENTY THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL'S OUT PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO PASS A
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS TO A TO
INTO A THREE WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM TOOL.
FOR WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM TWO OH FIVE S. C. ARE
[inaudible]
ONE FIFTY ONE CORPORATE.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR PAN
RELATIVE TO FIREARMS SAFETY.
MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ONCE
AGAIN WE ARE ASKED THIS YEAR AS
WE HAVE IN PRIOR YEARS TO
RECOGNIZE ASK DAY.
ASKED DAYS ABOUT ASKING SAVES
LIVES BASICALLY CAMPAIGN THAT
PARENTS ARE OUR* WHEN THEY
TAKE THEIR LOVED ONES TO A
FRIEND'S HOUSE THE NEIGHBOR'S
HOUSE TO ASK IF THERE UNLOCKED
GUNS.
IN THE HOME WE SEE THESE
INCIDENTS ALL THE TIME AND
FORCEFULLY WHERE.
YOUNGSTERS ARE PLAYING AROUND
WITH FIREARMS.
EFFORT BY THE BRADY CENTER TO
PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE AND THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INFORMATION IS PUT FORWARD.
TO UNDERSTAND ABOUT FIRE ANTS IN
THE HOUSE OF HOPEFULLY SAVE
LIVES AT THE ARRIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY MR MATHIS
YOUR RECOMMENDS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
I THINK WE OUGHT TO LOOK AT MORE
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT WE'RE
HAVING OUR KIDS ASK A WHEN
THEY'RE GOING OVER TO FRIENDS
HOUSES LIKE.
DO THEY HAVE A SWIMMING POOL DO
THEY HAVE CERTAIN TYPES OF DOGS.
THE THESE THINGS ARE ACTUALLY --
TAKING MORE CHILDREN'S LIVES
THAN.
FIREARMS SO I THINK WE OUGHT TO
GET OUR HEADS STRAIGHT ACTUALLY
APPROACH ISSUES.
ON ONE WHAT'S MORE RELEVANT THAN
JUST --
FIGHTING A WAR AGAINST PEOPLE
WHO ONE FIREARMS ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MR MATHIS.
MR MCCARTY WHICH I LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THE FIRST ROLE BE FOR CO
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE.
RESOURCES FOR COAUTHORS.
ON SCR ONE FIFTY ONE THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE THIRTY NINE CO AUTHORS
ADDED
.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON SCR ONE FIFTY
ONE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE ON
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FORTY
FIVE KNOWS THIRTEEN THAT
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE BACK
IN THE FILE TO FILE ITEM TOOL.
FOR THIS IS FILE ITEM.
TWO OH FOR S. C. ARE ONE THIRTY
NINE CORKERY.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR MINING
RELATIVE TO NO STRAW NOVEMBER.
MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER S. YEAR
WITH THIRTY NINE WILL PULL
PROCLAIM THE MONTH OF NOVEMBER
AS A STRONG OF AMBER CALIFORNIA
AND TO PROMOTE PUBLIC AWARENESS
OF PLASTIC POLLUTION.
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER IN TAKING
ACTION TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT DESPITE THIS FACT
PLASTIC POLLUTION CONTINUES TO
POSE A SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO OUR
OCEAN.
OUR WATERWAYS AND OUR LANDFILLS
EIGHT BILLION TONS OF PLASTIC
HAVE BEEN PRODUCED TO DATE.
OF THAT AMOUNT SIX POINT THREE
BILLION TONS AND OF THAT AMOUNT
ONLY 9% HAS BEEN RECYCLED THE
GENERATION OF PLASTIC WASTE PER
PERSON AND THE U. S. WEIGHING AT
TWO AND TWENTY POUNDS PER YEAR.
IS A AMONG THE HIGHEST IN THE
WORLD REDUCING CONSUMER.
DEMAND FOR PLASTIC STRAWS CAN
HELP DECREASE PLASTIC POLLUTION
AND A NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN RESTAURANTS HAVE
VOLUNTARY STOPPED PROVIDING
PLASTIC STRAWS.
OR ONLY PROVIDE THEM UPON
REQUEST SKIPPING THE STRAW IS AN
EASY STEP TO HELP REDUCE PLASTIC
POLLUTION THIS RESOLUTION ALONG
WITH MY OWN SOMEWHERE MEASURE
WILL HELP US MEET OUR SOLID
WASTE GOALS HERE IN REDUCE THE
NEGATIVE EFFECTS.
OF PROSECUTION THEY CAN RESPECT
WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DAVIS CALDERON MISTER GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS I
WOULD DISLIKE IS TO KEEP.
IN NOVEMBER THE FOCUS ON NO
SHADE MOVEMBER.
YEAH YOU KNOW IN NOVEMBER YOU
WILL SEE THAT BEARD COME BACK
HERE -- I
KNOW YOU GET A LOT OF YOU COME
UP TO ME AND SAID HEY WHAT
HAPPENED.
YOU KNOW WHY DO YOU SHAVE --
SO I WANT.
TO I WANT TO KEEP THE FOCUS ON
NO SHAVE NOVEMBER WHICH RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT MEN'S HEALTH.
AND PROSTATE HEALTH AND OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE THERE ARE
IMPORTANT --
AND AND ALSO YOU AS WE JUST
CELEBRATE LAST WEEK WE HAVE --
WE WANT TO KEEP THE FOCUS ON
IMPORTANT ISSUES LIKE.
SEEK APPRECIATION AND AWARENESS
WHICH IS ALSO.
AN IMPORTANT THING TO CELEBRATE
NOVEMBER AND I THINK YOU KNOW
STRAWS COME A BIG DISTRACTION
FROM.
I THINK MORE IMPORTANT ISSUES
THAT WE SHOULD FOCUS ON THE
NOVEMBER SIDE ASK FOR A NO VOTE
ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER OF
MISTER CALDERON.
YOU WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY IN
YOUR CLOSE TO ADDRESS THE BEARD
ISSUE.
SPEAKING OF BEARDS MR MATHIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER FEAR THE BEARD --
AYE AYE GONNA RISE WITH WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM NICHOLS YOU KNOW
NOT NOVEMBER IS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW NO SHAVE.
NOVEMBER OR YOU KNOW GROW YOUR
MOVEMBER MILE.
WHY WE GOT TO TAKE THIS AWAY
FROM?
MEN'S HEALTH AWARENESS THIS IS A
IN.
NOVEMBER'S TURNED INTO A MOTH
ABOUT.
AWARENESS FOR MEN FOR CANCER FOR
THINGS THAT.
ARE ISSUES WITH MEN [inaudible]
IN A PICK ANOTHER MONTH
[inaudible]
LET'S KEEP.
MOVEMBER FOR THE MEN ASK FOR NO
VOTE.
MR ARE HARPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THE PUBLIC PRESSURE TO AND THE
USE OF PLASTIC STRAWS HIS LEAD
TO ONE BIG PROBLEM [inaudible]
MORE PLASTIC.
AFTER A LIMITING PLASTIC STRAWS
FROM A STORE STARBUCKS NOW USES
STROLLERS LIZARDS THAT REQUIRE
MORE PLASTIC THAN THE STRAWS
ORIGINALLY DID.
ADDITIONALLY.
THEY SELL PAPER STRAWS IS AN
ALTERNATIVE.
BUT OF COURSE THOSE PAPER STRAWS
ARE.
COME WRAPPED IN PLASTIC.
THIS IS A FEEL GOOD MOVEMENT TO
BAN STRAWS THAT ACTUALLY DOES
LITTLE TO CLEAN UP THE
ENVIRONMENT. 90% OF THE PLASTIC
POLLUTION IN THE WORLD'S OCEANS
COME FROM JUST AND RIVERS.
AND NOT ONE OF THEM IS LOCATED
ON THIS CONTINENT LET ALONE THIS
COUNTRY.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO STOP BEING
THE NANNY STATE.
THAT THREATENS SERVER'S WITH
JAIL TIME.
AND TELLS RESTAURANTS HOW TO RUN
THEIR BUSINESSES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR A NO
VOTE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE RESOLUTION MISTER
CALDERON YOU MAY CLOSE I'M
RESPONSE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HUNTINGTON BEACH THE DIFFERENCE
IS THAT A STRAWS NOT EASILY
RECYCLABLE.
A LIT AS EASILY RECYCLABLE.
ARE FROM MY OTHER COLLEAGUE FROM
THE VALLEY I THINK REAL MEN
SHARE AND I DON'T MIND SHARING A
MONTH WITH ANYTHING ELSE.
AND WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM EAST.
NICHOLAS I DON'T KNOW WHO YOU'RE
KIDDING BUT YOU CAN GROW A BEARD
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE.
FORTUNATELY IN HERE THAT SO
LET'S.
LITERALLY AN INHERENT --
LET'S JUST GO TO A ROLL CALL
VOTE.
CLICK OPEN ALL I'M VOTERS THAT
AMOUNT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE ANTI VOTE.
I FORTY THREE NOS THIRTEEN THAT
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
PAST A FILE AND TO FOURTEEN WE
ARE AT FILE ITEM.
TO FIFTEEN WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM TO
SIXTEEN S. C. R..
ONE TEN CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
TEN BY SENATOR WIENER AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO SEX CHARACTERISTICS.
MR THURMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
THIS MEASURE SEEKS TO EMPHASIZE
THE NEED TO PREVENT.
UNNECESSARY SURGERIES THAT HAVE
NO MEDICAL BENEFIT IN ONLY SEEM
TO HARM.
YOUNG PEOPLE.
I THIS BILL --
FOCUSES ON THE NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WERE BORN.
WITH VARIATIONS IN THEIR%
PHYSICAL SEX CHARACTERISTICS OR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE INTERSEX.
THE MAJORITY OF BABIES WERE BORN
AIR SACS ARE HEALTHY AND MAY NOT
REQUIRE MEDICAL INTERVENTION.
WAITED TO THEIR PHYSICAL SEX
CHARACTERISTICS IMMEDIATELY OR
IF AT ALL.
I MEAN THE FIFTIES PHYSICIAN
STARTED DOING.
THESE IRREVERSIBLE SURGERIES ON
INTERSEX INFANTS WITHOUT
[inaudible]
MEDICAL JUSTIFICATION OUGHT TO
CONFORM AND TO FORCE THEM TO
CONFORM. TO WHAT THESE POSITIONS
PERCEIVED.
THE SURGERIES ARE OFTEN PERFORM
BEFORE CHAO CAN EVEN SPEAKER
STAND MEAN IN THE IN A SIX
INDIVIDUAL.
IS EXCLUDED FROM THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS.
AND THE SURGERIES CAN CAUSE
SEVERE PSYCHOLOGICAL AND
PHYSIOLOGICAL HARM WHEN
PERFORMED WITHOUT.
THE INFORMED CONSENT OF THE
INDIVIDUAL.
THE UNITED NATIONS THE
PHYSICIANS FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND
OTHERS.
HAVE INDICATED HOW THE SURGERIES
CAN BE.
DAMAGING AND HAVE A LIFELONG
CONSEQUENCES INCLUDING.
YOUR VERSATILE INFERTILITY.
AND CAUSING SEVERE MENTAL
SUFFERING.
IN A SIX YOUNG PEOPLE WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE.
IN LIFE ALTERING DECISIONS ARE
THRIVING SO WE SHOULD FOLLOW ON
THAT.
AND SAY THAT MEDICALLY
UNNECESSARY PROCEDURES BECAUSE
THEY CARRY BOTH RISK AND HARM.
AND CAN BE SAFELY TO BIRD.
SHOULD BE THE PRACTICE OF THE
DAY THIS RESOLUTION CALLS UPON
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
A MODEL.
OF COMPETENT AND ETHICAL MEDICAL
CARE.
WHERE THERE IS A COMPELLING
INTEREST IN PROTECTING THE
PHYSICAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL WELL
BEING OF MINORS?
INCLUDING INTERSEX YOUTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SCR.
ONE TEN THANK YOU MISTER THURMAN.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MISTER CHAIRMAN WOULD YOU LIKE
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THERE WILL BE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR HOW AUTHORS
ON AND SEE ARE ONE TEN THIS IS
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
THERE ARE.
MICHAEL CLOSER ALL THEIR THIRTY
FOUR CO AUTHORS ADDED AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE
FILE TO FILE ITEM.
TWO OH SEVEN FILE ITEM TO A
SEVEN S. B. [inaudible] FOUR
SEVENTY THREE FOR COREY.
SENATE BILL FOUR SEVENTY THREE
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG ACTUALLY
DEFICIENT WILDLIFE.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER
TODAY I AM PRESENTING S. B. FOUR
SEVEN THREE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
HERTZBERG.
THIS BILL CONTAINS SEVERAL
AMENDMENTS THE CALIFORNIA
ENDANGERED SPECIES DOT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE THAT ARE
BALLOTS REFLECT INPUT FROM
ACADEMIC BUSINESS AND
CONSERVATION INTERESTS.
S. B. FOUR SEVENTY THREE IS
FOCUSED ON EXPANDING LAND OWNER
PROTECTIONS.
PROVING TRANSPARENCY REQUIRING
DECISIONS TO BE BASED ON THE
BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE.
WITH THE AMENDED TAKEN THIS WEEK
THE FARM BUREAU AND THE COUNCIL
MEMBER MENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE HOW REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WAS AG AIR CURRENTS
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. TO DECIDE
ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS.
TWENTY ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM.
TO TEN WE'VE DISPENSED WITH FILE
ITEMS TO 11-3.
TWO THIRTEEN PASS RETAIN A
PROBLEM
.
TO FOURTEEN MEMBERS WE'RE AT
FILE AND TO FIFTEEN FILE ITEM TO
FIFTEEN AS CHAIR [inaudible]
FOURTEEN CORPORATE.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION FOURTEEN
BY SENATOR GLAZER AND OTHERS
RELATIVES CONFEDERATE NAMES AND
STATUES.
MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION FOURTEEN
CALLS ON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO TAKE A LONG OVERDUE STEP OF
RENAMING ALL FEDERAL PLACES
PARKS BUILDINGS AND ROADWAYS
THAT BEAR THE NAMES OF ELECTED
MILITARY LEADERS OF THE
CONFEDERACY.
AS CHAIR FOURTEEN ALSO URGES
CONGRESS TO REMOVE STATUES OF
CONFEDERATE LEADERS AND PLACE
THEM IN MUSEUMS WHERE THEY CAN
BE VIEWED IN A HISTORICAL
CONTEXT.
THIS RESOLUTION A SIMILAR TO S.
B. FIVE THIRTY NINE FROM TWENTY
SIXTEEN WHICH PASSED WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THAT SOUGHT
TO REPLACE THE NAMES OF
CONFEDERATE LEADERS ON ANY
PUBLIC PROPERTY IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS RESOLUTION OF THE STALLS
SMALL STEP TOWARDS RECONCILING
WITH ACKNOWLEDGING SOME THE
DARKEST CHAPTERS IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MISTER GIBSON YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS AS STRONG SUPPORT.
OF AS J. ARE FOURTEEN AND THANK
SENATOR GLAZER FOR BRINGING UP
THIS RESOLUTION BEFORE US TODAY.
IT IS NOTED THAT THE CONFEDERATE
GENERAL ROBERT E. LEE'S SAID
THAT.
HE WAS OPPOSED TO EXIT OUT OF
SEEING.
CONFEDERATE MONUMENTS BECAUSE IT
WOULD KEEP OPEN THE SOURCE OF
WAR [inaudible]
AND MAN WE WE LOOK.
YOUR ATTENTION MISTER GIBSON.
AND WHEN WE LOOK AT THE STATE.
OF THE COUNTRY TODAY.
IT IS LIKE A BATTLEGROUND.
CHILDREN ARE BEING STRIPPED AWAY
FROM THEIR PARENTS.
PEOPLE ARE BEING TARGETED
BECAUSE THEY'RE MUSLIMS
[inaudible]
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS LIVES.
LIVES ARE BEING TURNED AROUND
THE LAND AS STAGE POINT OF ORDER --
MISTER SPEAKER I THINK THAT.
AND THE MEMBER IS STRAYING FAR
FROM WHAT THIS RESOLUTION IS
ABOUT THIS IS ABOUT.
CONFEDERATE NAMES AND STATUES
BEING REMOVED FROM BUILDINGS IN
MEAN PLACED IN MUSEUMS THIS
ISN'T ABOUT IMMIGRATION OR
ANYTHING.
RELATED TO THAT'S I WOULD JUST
ASK THAT THE SPEAKER STICK TO
THE SUBJECT AT HAND.
MS MELENDEZ --
THE POINT OF ORDER IS NOT WELL
TAKEN I BELIEVE THE SPEAKER THE
OUT --
MISTER GIBSON IS PROVIDING SOME
GENERAL CONTEXT THAT IS RELEVANT --
TO THE RESOLUTION I'M GOING TO
SAY POINT OF ORDERS NOW TAKEN.
MISTER GIBSON YOU MAY PROCEED --
IN THE SPIRIT OF OF THE ITEM
THAT'S BEFORE.
THE BY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER.
CHILDREN ARE BEING STRIPPED AWAY
FROM THEIR PARENTS.
PEOPLE ARE BEING TARGETED
BECAUSE THEY'RE MUSLIMS.
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS LIVES
LIVES HAVE BEEN TURNED UPSIDE
DOWN AND THEY'VE BEEN PUSHED IN
THE SHADOWS.
TRADE WARS ARE TAKING PLACE WITH
OUR ALLIES.
THE SORES OF OF OUR HISTORIES.
ARE ONLY BEING RE OPEN BECAUSE
OF WHAT'S TAKING PLACE WITH
THESE MONUMENTS.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE%
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON S. J. ARE.
FOURTEEN THEY WAS GIPSON.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YEAH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS YOU KNOW THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF DISCUSSION OVER THIS SAID
WE HAD BILLS [inaudible]
LAST SESSION.
I'M I THINK THE IMPORTANT THING
IS THAT WE DON'T FORGET OUR
HISTORY.
WE DON'T FORGET.
THE NEGATIVE ASPECTS OF OUR
SYSTEM HISTORY AND WE NEED.
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED
THERE WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT IT --
BUT WHAT THIS DOES WHAT THESE
KIND OF MEASURES DO. TO ME IS A
SENSOR HISTORY.
AS I SAY HEY YOU KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO JUST REMOVE THIS AND
AND TO ME THAT MEANS THAT YOU
DON'T TALK ABOUT THOSE THINGS
YOU DON'T TALK ABOUT WHAT
OCCURRED.
YOU KNOW DURING --
THE CIVIL WAR.
AND TO ME THAT'S NOT THE RIGHT
THING TO DO AND IN FACT.
WE NO BECAUSE WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS THAT.
PEOPLE IN HISTORY ARE
COMPLICATED.
FIGURES IN HISTORY ARE VERY
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT ROBERT E.
LEE AND JUST TALK ABOUT THE
CIVIL WAR.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE HE WAS A VERY
COMPLEX PERSON WHO.
WHO DID A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS?
THEY CONTRIBUTED. TO THIS NATION
[inaudible]
AND SO. TO ME TO TO OVERSIMPLIFY
AND SIMPLY SAY HEY LOOK BECAUSE
SOMEONE'S.
PART OF THE CONFEDERACY THERE'S
THE STATUE SOMEWHERE THAT WE
SHOULD REMOVE THAT [inaudible]
TO ME.
TAKES AWAY THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK ABOUT OUR HISTORY.
AND TALK ABOUT AND TALK ABOUT
THESE FIGURES.
THINK ABOUT WHERE YOU'RE GOING
WITH THIS.
BECAUSE WE CAN GO WE CAN GO DOWN
OF WE CAN GO DOWN THE LINE HERE.
YOU WE COULD WE COULD TALK ABOUT --
NO FIGURES IN OUR OWN HISTORY
WHO HAVE NAMES THAT NAMES UP ON
SCHOOLS WHO HAVE NAMES UP ON
BUILDINGS.
WHO MADE SOME BIG MISTAKES?
WHO DID SOME VERY NEGATIVE
THINGS LET'S LET'S TALK ABOUT
JAPANESE INTERMENT AND WHO
PLAYED A VERY BIG ROLE IN THAT?
THE FORMER GOVERNOR OF THE STATE
OF A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE THAT
MANY PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE
CELEBRATE.
BUT WHO WAS VERY INSTRUMENTAL IN
PUTTING THE JAPANESE AMERICANS
IN INTERNMENT CAMPS.
SHOULD WE REMOVE HIS NAME.
HEY ASHBURY AND SAN FRANCISCO IS
NAMED AFTER GOVERNOR HATE.
LOT OF LOT OF RACIST.
COMMENTS COMING OUT OF HIM IF
YOU LOOK BACK ON THE HISTORY OF
THAT SHOULD WE CHANGE THE NAME
OF PAID ASH VERY.
I MEAN HOW FAR DO YOU WANT TO
TAKE THIS.
IT'S SOMETHING TO REALLY THINK
ABOUT DO YOU WANT TO CENSOR
HISTORY BECAUSE YOU KNOW.
BECAUSE ALL OF A SUDDEN THAT YOU
WANT TO DISAGREE WITH THAT --
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT.
ART ARE DANGEROUS TO FIRST
AMENDMENT [inaudible]
I THINK --
AND SO LOOK I THINK YOU SHOULD
LOOK AT FIGURES IN HISTORY
[inaudible] FOR THE FOR THE
COMPLICATED FIGURES THAT THEY
ARE.
RIGHT AND HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
AND TALK ABOUT.
YOU CAN'T PUT PEOPLE INTO A
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
VIEWPOINT WHEN THEY LIVED IN A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT TIME THEN
YOU AT ALL YOU AND I'LL DO IT.
RIGHT AND I THINK TROOP TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRUE TRULY --
INTERESTED IN HISTORY AN INSTANT
TALKING ABOUT HISTORY AND
TALKING ABOUT HOW WE GET BETTER.
AND HOW WE IMPROVE UPON OUR
DEMOCRACY.
WOULD AGREE WITH THAT.
SO I WOULD URGES BODY TO BE VERY
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THIS I WOULD
REJECT THIS THIS POLICY OF
CENSORSHIP.
AND LET'S HAVE THE RICH DIALOGUE
THAT I THINK A LOT OF US WANNA
HAVE ABOUT OUR HISTORY THANK YOU.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
I'M SORRY.
SHE'S THE AUTHOR.
I'M LOOKING FOR ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THANK YOU
MEMBERS DOCTOR WEBER.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED YES MADAM
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT.
WHEN ONE LOOKS AT HISTORY NOT
JUST U. S. ISSUE BUT HISTORY IN
GENERAL?
YOU GENERALLY DON'T CELEBRATE
THOSE WHO ARE CONSIDERED
TRAITORS.
AND IT'S NO POINT US PRETENDING
THAT THE CIVIL WAR WAS SOME
LITTLE INCIDENT THAT OCCURRED.
IT WAS A DIRECT ATTACK UPON THIS
NATION AND WHAT THE NATION STOOD
FOR WEATHER WAS PRO AGAINST
SLAVERY THIS WAS A DIVISION IN
THE NATION.
AN ATTEMPT TO OVERTHROW THE
GOVERNMENT SO LESS NOT PRETENDED
TO SOME WILL PARTY THAT TOOK
PLACE BUT THERE WERE A COUPLE OF
PEOPLE WITH A FEW IDEAS AND A
COUPLE OTHER THINGS THIS WAS A
MAJOR EVENT IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT CHALLENGE THE DEMOCRACY WE
DON'T HAVE STATUES THAT I KNOW
OF TO BENEDICT ARNOLD.
AND PROBABLY IF WE PUT ONE UP
FOLKS WOULD BE UPSET.
NOW THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THAT
I'M LOOKING OVER LOOKING ALL OF
THE RACISM IN THIS COUNTRY AND
ALL OF THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED IN
RACES ACTIVITIES AS WE TALK
ABOUT THE SIXTIES ALL WE TALK
ABOUT.
THE CIVIL WAR ITSELF WHAT WE
TALK ABOUT THE SLAVE TRADE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE WILL
ALWAYS SOME ISSUES AND SOME
CONFLICTS THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE PHILOSOPHIES AND IDEAS THAT
WOULD DIFFERENT THAN OURS.
BUT THIS IS A MAJOR EVENT IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AND WE SHOULD NOT THINK OF IT
ANY DIFFERENT THAN NORTH AND
SOUTH KOREA.
WHILE THE OTHER VIETNAM IN THE
DIVISION THAT WAS THEIR THIS WAS
THEY'D ATTACK UPON THE DEMOCRACY
IN WHICH IT EXISTED AT THAT TIME.
AND IT CREATED A WAR THAT WAS A
WAR BETWEEN THE STATES AND IT IS
NOT JUST A MINOR INCIDENT.
NOT SHOULD WE TEACH ABOUT THIS
MOST DEFINITELY.
WE SHOULD TEACH ABOUT IT IN OUR
MUSEUMS IN OUR HISTORY BOOKS AND
WE SHOULD NEVER TAKE THIS OUT OF
OUR HISTORY BOOKS.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT TO WASH
HISTORY AWAY SO THE PEOPLE NEVER
LEARN FROM THE PAST.
BUT WHEN I SEE A MONUMENT WHEN I
GET ON A HIGHWAY OR FREEWAY I
BELIEVE AT SOME POINT THAT I AM
CELEBRATING THAT INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE NAME IS ON AND THAT'S WHY
WE NAME THINGS AFTER PEOPLE.
AND SOMETIMES WE FIGHT ABOUT THE
NAMES IN SOME COMMUNITIES IS
WHOSE NAME SHOULD BE THERE THAT
SHOULD NOT BE THERE NOT BECAUSE
IT'S AN INSIGNIFICANT EVENT BUT
BECAUSE IT IS AN IMPORTANT
ELEMENT THAT WE WOULD WANT TO
TEACH OUR CHILDREN EVEN WITHOUT
A STILL LESSEN.
WOULD THEY SHOULD BECOME WHAT
THEY SHOULD ASPIRE TO BE AND
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A GREAT
AMERICAN.
AND SO AS WE TALK ABOUT THIS
LET'S NOT WASH IT DOWN THAT IS
JUST AN EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE.
QUESTION OF THE CONFEDERACY AND
THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF THE CIVIL
WAR IN THIS COUNTRY WAS A MAJOR
EVENT.
THAT NOT ONLY DETERMINE WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN TO THOSE WHO WERE
ENSLAVED BUT DETERMINE WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN TO THIS DEMOCRACY.
AND WE SHOULD FIGHT FOR THAT
EVERY DAY AND THOSE WHO ARE
OPPOSED TO IT WE SHOULD
BASICALLY DEAL WITH THEM
AGGRESSIVELY AND NOT.
SOMETIME OTHER MAKE IT SOUND SO
ROMANTIC OF WHAT HAPPENED AT
THAT PARTICULAR TIME I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION I
SUPPOSE I STRONGLY SUPPORT US
HAVING CONVERSATIONS ALWAYS
ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS NAME
SHOULD BE THERE IN TERMS OF
TOTAL CONTRIBUTION BUT THEIR
EFFORTS TO DESTROY THIS NATION
SHOULD NEVER BE FORGOTTEN AND
SHOULD NEVER BE WASHED AWAY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
FOR THIS RESOLUTION.
THE DECK WEBER MISTER MATHIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THEY WITH FEAR MEMBERS.
IN OTHER THERE'S A LOT OF SCENES
OUT THERE THERE'S A LOT OF
QUOTES OUT THERE ABOUT
REMEMBERING IN OUR HISTORY.
AND IN THE MILITARY WE SAY LET'S
NEVER FORGET.
LET'S NEVER FORGET THOSE WILL
PASSED Y. THEY PASSED IN WHAT IT
WAS ABOUT.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST
WE TALK ABOUT LET'S NEVER FORGET?
BUT WE DON'T TALK ABOUT REMOVING
ALL OF THEIR HISTORY AND THROWN
INTO A MUSEUM [inaudible]
IS IMPORTANT.
THAT WE REMEMBER.
THE IS A GENERATION THAT FORGETS
IT'S PAST.
GETS ITS HISTORY.
IS DOOMED TO REPEAT IT.
AND THAT'S A FACT OF HISTORY.
SO LET'S NOT TRY TO SHUFFLE AWAY
THE THINGS WE WANNA KICK UNDER
THE CARPET UNDER THE RUG AND
DON'T WANT TO LOOK AT SO WE CAN
FORGET ABOUT WHAT WAS DONE.
IT'S REMEMBER IT.
LET'S HAVE IT THERE THAT WE CAN
HAVE IT IN CONTEXT.
AND LET'S REMEMBER AND LEARN
FROM THESE LESSONS.
THURMOND YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARISES BOARD THAT SHE ARE.
FOURTEEN GROSS WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT THIS MEASURE.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO BE CAREFUL TO THE REFERENCES
THAT YOU CHOOSE TO MAKE
[inaudible]
IN DEFENDING.
YOUR INTERESTS IN VOTING THIS
DOWN. TO MAKE A REFERENCE TO THE
HOLOCAUST [inaudible]
IN COMPARISON.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT [inaudible]
INDIVIDUALS [inaudible]
CREATED.
MASS SLAUGHTER MILLIONS OF
INDIVIDUALS THERE KNOW SCHOOLS
NAMED AFTER THOSE INDIVIDUALS
NOR SHOULD THERE BE.
THOSE ARE CRIMINAL ACTS.
ALL THIS MEASURE IS SAYING.
IS THAT WE SHOULD BE THOUGHTFUL.
ABOUT THE BUILDINGS THAT WE NAME.
SCHOOLS THAT OUR CHILDREN GO.
TO AND THAT IT HAS AN IMPACT ON
THEM WHEN THEY GOING TO A SCHOOL
THAT IS NAMED AFTER SOMEONE.
WHO STOOD AGAINST THEIR VERY
BEING?
BUT THIS IS A DEMOCRACY AND YOU
MAY VOTE HOW YOU WANT.
BUT LET'S NOT USE THIS MEASURE
OR THIS FLOOR. TO MAKE
REFERENCES TO THOSE WHO LOST
THEIR LIVES [inaudible]
FROM CRIMINALS.
DO MAKE ARGUMENTS WHY THEY
SHOULD NOT BE SUPPORTED.
I STRONGLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE.
I SURE LEVINE YOUR READINESS.
YEAH VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION I WHEN I HEARD ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES ON THE FLOOR
TALKING ABOUT.
THE TRADERS --
THAT TO HE WANTED TO STAND UP
AND SUPPORT HAVING THE STATUES
FOR I KIND OF SHOUTED OUT A
COUPLE OF THE CONCERNS THAT I
HAD BUT I DIDN'T THINK I WANTED
TO GET UP AND SPEAK BUT I JUST
CANNOT BELIEVE THAT A TIME AND
AGAIN MORE OF YOU KEEP.
STANDING UP. TO STAND UP FOR
THESE PEOPLE WHO WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DEATHS OF
MORE AMERICANS IN WAR THAN
ANYWHERE ELSE ANY OTHER TIME.
EVER HAPPENED IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT THERE PEOPLE STANDING UP
FOR THESE CONFEDERATE LEADERS
THAT WERE TRAITORS TO OUR
COUNTRY.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS DIED FIGHTING FOR
COUNTRY IF YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT.
KNOWING OUR HISTORY.
AND PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY DO
CELEBRATE HISTORY IN EVEN THE
BAD HISTORY IF YOU GO TO PLACES
LIKE BERLIN YOU SEE WHERE THEY
BURNED THE BOOKS THEY DON'T HAVE
A STATUE OF HITLER.
YOU SEE WHERE THESE ATROCITIES
OCCURRED THEY DON'T CELEBRATE
THEIR NAMES.
SO IF WE WANT TO PUT THESE
CONFEDERATE LEADERS [inaudible]
I IT IN IN UNDERSTAND THEIR
HISTORY THEN WE SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT HISTORY RATHER
THAN CELEBRATING THEIR THEIR
MEMORY.
AND I I WOULD JUST YOU KNOW THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE STILL MIKES
UP THAT ONE TO STAND IN SUPPORT.
OF THESE NAMES OF THESE LEADERS
OF HAVING THE STATUES BE UP TO
HAVE SCHOOLS THAT STUDENTS WALK
IN TO BE NAMED AFTER PEOPLE WHO
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MURDER
OF AMERICANS.
AND TO KEEP THE ENSLAVEMENT OF
AMERICANS IS JUST BEYOND MY
BELIEF [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PATTERSON YOUR REGULAR.
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M MY
MICROPHONE IS NOT UP.
OF FOR THE COMPLAINT OF MY
COLLEAGUE HERE MY MIKE IS UP. TO
JUST ASK IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS
DISCUSSION NOT WITHSTANDING YOUR
VOTE ON THIS.
OUR I HAPPEN TO BE --
DEEPLY INVOLVED AND INTERESTED
AND AMERICAN HISTORY AND HAVE
FOR MY ENTIRE LIFE.
I KNOW THIS IS COMPLICATED I
KNOW THIS IS STRESSING
[inaudible]
MEMBERS HERE.
I JUST HAVE A SUGGESTION.
KEN BURNS HAS CREATED A
REMARKABLE FILM.
ON THE CIVIL WAR FOR PBS.
IT IS THOROUGH AND COMPLETE AND
VERY VERY FAIR.
AND IT DOES PRESENT THE
COMPLEXITIES.
OF ALL OF THIS ARE AND ALSO OF
THE AFTERMATH IN A LIKE.
SO I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT YOU
VOTE ONE WAY OR THE OTHER THIS
IS A DISCUSSION THAT.
PROBABLY ISN'T GOING TO AND THAT
IT IS GOING TO BE A POLITICAL
MATTER.
BUT JUST AS A POINT OF
INFORMATION AND IT IS A POINT OF
A FIRST CLASS BIT OF HISTORY --
GET A COPY OWN IT I VIEW IT MORE
THAN ONCE.
AND YOU WILL GET A SENSE.
I'LL BE COMPLEXITY THAT'S AT
STAKE IT MAY STRENGTHEN YOUR
RESOLVE IN THIS ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER IT MAY.
WE CAN IT BUT AT THE VERY LEAST.
YOU WILL HAVE ACCESS.
REALLY REALLY GOOD [inaudible]
IN A UNBIASED.
THOROUGH AND COMPLETE HISTORY.
THAT IS A REMARKABLE PIECE OF
WORK THAT HELPS US TO UNDERSTAND
[inaudible]
WHAT TRANSPIRED --
I THINK THE REMARKABLE THING IN
ALL OF BUT KEN BURNS DID WAS TO
ABLE TO MAKE THIS IS COMPLEXES.
THAT IT AND AND AND AND
UNDERSTANDABLE BUT THERE IS A OF
WELL KNOWN A HISTORIAN AND IT --
WHO SAYS BASICALLY THAT THE
CIVIL WAR TURNED THE UNITED
STATES?
FROM OUR TO INDIA'S.
THE PRIDE OF THE CIVIL WAR WAS
PERFECTLY [inaudible]
A GRAMMATICALLY CORRECT. TO CALL
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA ARE.
PLURAL TODAY WE SAY THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
IS AND ALL THROUGH THE PAINT OFF
TO THE BLOODSHED IN ALL THROUGH
THE CIVIL WAR THERE HAS BEEN AN
ARC IN THEIR OF HISTORY.
THAT I THINK WE NEED TO BE
CELEBRATING AN UNDERSTANDING.
DEEPLY --
FOR IT ALSO.
MISTER BURNS MAKES THEIR CAKE
CASE IN THE FILM.
THAT YOU CANNOT UNDERSTAND.
AMERICAN THE TWENTIETH AND
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY UNLESS YOU
UNDERSTOOD.
AMERICA IN THE MIDDLE A OF THE
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS.
AND I'M NOT MAKING A CASE ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER HERE.
WHAT I AM SUGGESTING IS THERE
ARE THERE IS A GREAT PIECE OF
HISTORY?
THAT WILL HELP UNDERSTAND YOU TO
UNDERSTAND.
A LOT OF THE COMPLEXITIES HERE
BOTH ON THE NORTHERN AND THE AND
THE SOUTHERN SIDE.
OUR ON I THINK IT WOULD BE VERY
VERY HELPFUL.
INSTEAD OF I THINK OF MAKING
PROCLAMATIONS ABOUT YOUR POINT
OF VIEW OVER.
OVER HISTORICAL SITUATIONS AND
EVENTS AT LEAST BIG AND DEEPLY
TO THAT KEN BURNS SERIES.
I OWN THE ACTUALLY THE I PRINTED
WORK AS A RESULT IT IS A GREAT
REFERENCE AND I THINK THAT IT
WOULD BE VERY VERY HELPFUL.
AND QUITE INSPIRATIONAL FRANKLY
EVEN IN THE MIDST OF DOCUMENTING
THE HORROR OF THAT ERA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON MS
MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I WAS A
LITTLE DISAPPOINTED WHEN OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN RAFAEL SAW
THREE REPUBLICAN MICROPHONES UP.
AND STOOD UP AND SAID THAT HE
WAS APPALLED THAT --
PEOPLE ARE STILL RAISING THEIR
MICROPHONES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF OR IN OPPOSITION. TO THIS
REVOLUTION IN SUPPORT OF THE
PEOPLE.
WHO ARE MEMORIALIZED IN STATE --
I'M NOT STANDING UP TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF MEMORIALIZING THESE
FOLKS IN FACT I'M I'M SUPPORTING
THIS RESOLUTION AND I THINK.
THE COMMENT FROM MY FRIEND FROM
SOUTH SAN RAFAEL ILLUSTRATES
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE.
MORE OF A CONVERSATION ABOUT --
OUR FEELINGS ABOUT THE ISSUE AND
I THINK IT'S I MEAN THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO ME THAT WE HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING IN THAT EVERYONE
IN HERE GETS THAT WE ARE UNITED
IN --
WANTING TO WORK FOR A BETTER
SOCIETY IN TREATING ONE ANOTHER
BETTER SO IT'S GOING TO
CERTAINLY GOING TO BE MY PLEDGE
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE FOR THAT CONVERSATION BUT
WITH RESPECT TO THE RESOLUTION.
I DON'T THINK IT'S SEEKS TO
ERASE HISTORY ON I THINK IF
SOMEONE WERE SAYING GET RID OF
EVERY STATUE EVERY MONUMENT
EVERY NAME EVERY PLAQUE.
AND PUT IT IN THE DUMPSTER THAT
CERTAINLY IS AN EFFORT TO ERASE
HISTORY I THINK PUTTING IN ANY
MUSEUM MAKES SENSE --
YOU CAN.
PUT IT IN A CONTEXT WHERE THERE
SOME EXPLANATION INTO BACKGROUND
BEHIND WHO THESE FIGURES REALLY
WERE WHAT THEY DID WHAT THEY
STOOD FOR THEIR RIGHTFUL PLACE
IN HISTORY FOR THAT --
THAT'S DIFFICULT TO DO WHEN IT'S
A STATUE THAT JUST HAS A PLAQUE
ON IT PROBABLY DOESN'T EXPLAIN.
EVERYTHING IN THAT PERSON'S
HISTORY AND AND WHAT THEIR
RESPONSIBLE FOREST I SUPPORT.
THE MOVE TO PUT THEM IN MUSEUMS
THAT HAVE A ALLOW PEOPLE HAVE A
DEEPER CONVERSATION RELEASED
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT WHAT THEY
DID IN CERTAINLY THE KEN BURNS
DOCUMENTARIES WONDERFUL.
NAM AS WELL AND HOPEFULLY WILL
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION.
IN OUR SCHOOLS TO THAT OUR KIDS
GET THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
COMPLICATED AND THAT WAS A
DIFFERENT TIME IN OUR HISTORY
THAT DOESN'T MAKE WHAT HAPPENED
RIGHT -- BUT
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND IT IF
NOTHING ELSE SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE RESOLUTION THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAVEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THINK I'D LIKE TO TAKE THIS
BACK TO THE SDA ARE ACTUALLY
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO BE VOTING ON
HERE.
AND WHAT IT SAYS IS WE'RE GOING
TO READING.
RECOMMENDED RENAME ANY FEDERAL
BUILDING PARKS ROADWAYS.
AND HIGHWAY MARKERS AND IT GOES
ON SO WE'RE ACTUALLY QUESTION TO
RENAME THE ADULT CONTEXT TO IT
SOMEBODY MADE THE COMMENT.
Y. WE RECOGNIZE PEOPLE THAT
MURDERED AMERICANS.
THAT COMMENT MADE ON THE FLOOR
[inaudible]
SHOWS.
AND THAT THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT WAS GOING ON AT THE TIME.
THESE WEREN'T MURDERED AMERICANS
THESE ARE FATHERS FIGHTING SON.
BROTHERS FIGHTING OTHER BROTHERS.
A CIVIL WAR TOWARD THIS COUNTRY
APART.
YOU KNOW MAYBE BECAUSE I'VE
LIVED IN VIRGINIA AND BEEN BACK
THERE FACT THOSE ARE JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO.
AND BOX SOME BATTLEFIELDS
MANASSAS BECAUSE MY DAUGHTER
LIVES THERE.
AND I TOOK THE TIME TO GO TO
ARLINGTON CEMETERY.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT AS I WAS
WALKING AROUND.
WHAT I WAS SEEN?
HARLEY DID CEMETERY PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MOST HOLLOWED GROUNDS IN
OUR COUNTRY RECOGNIZING THOSE
WHO HAVE SERVED.
RIGHT IN THE CENTER OF IT.
IS LEE HOUSE.
ROBERT E. LEE [inaudible]
HOUSE.
IT'S WHERE HE WAS WHEN HE
DECIDED TO GIVE UP HIS
COMMISSION.
AS A UNION AS A FEDERAL SO
GENERAL. TO LEAD VIRGINIA.
AND TODAY IF YOU GO THERE HAS
HOUSE OF STILL THERE.
YOU CAN WALK AND SEE HIS BEDROOM
AND THE FURNITURE AND PICTURES
OF HIS FAMILY.
ARE WE SAYING THAT WE WANT TO
RENAME LEE HOUSE. TO PUT IT IN
THE MUSEUM.
YOU WALK THE BATTLEFIELDS OF
MANASSAS AROUND THE AREA.
THERE'S ONE BATTLEFIELD THAT I
WAS WALKING THROUGH ITS GOES TO
A FORCED.
I AM NOT TO THE SIDE OF THE
FORCE.
THEY SAY THERE'S SCIENCES
LARGEST CEMETERY.
AND WHEN YOU GO INTO THE
CEMETERY.
YOU SEE THESE DEPICTION OF HOW
THE CONFEDERATE SOLDIERS WHO
LIVE IN THESE THINGS THEY CALLED
THE DOG HOUSES WHICH WERE MUCH
BIGGER IN THESE.
TWO DESPERATE TOGETHER AND SIX
MEN WERE LIVING THERE.
AND THAT'S WHERE THEY WERE IN
THE WINTERTIME AND THEY ALL GOT
SICK AND MANY OF THEM DIED THERE.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT IT.
THE DOT OF THE CONFEDERACY FROM
SOUTH CAROLINA.
HAD MARK DID AS A GRAVE SITE
BECAUSE THIS IS WHERE. ONE OF
THEIR BATTALIONS WERE SET.
AND THE YOUNG MAN DIED THERE.
THAT'S IN VIRGINIA.
I WE SAYING THAT WE SHOULD TAKE
THAT MARKER CEMETERY TO SOUTH
CAROLINA PUT IN THERE. FOR THEIR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND MOVE THAT OUT.
YOU KNOW WHERE IN CALIFORNIA WE
DIDN'T YOU KNOW.
WE CAN GET SEE THE* FACE ARE
IN VIRGINIA NORTH CAROLINA SOUTH
CAROLINA.
I FIND IT INTERESTING THAT THE
PEOPLE IN VIRGINIA AND SOUTH
CAROLINA HAVE LEARNED HOW.
TO DEAL WITH THIS.
IN THE VARIOUS RESPECTFUL WAY
[inaudible] TO RECOGNIZE.
THAT THESE ARE TERRIBLE TIMES
I'M NOT SUPPORTED SLAVERY
SLAVERY WOULD IN MY OPINION WAS
A SENATE THE BIRTH OF PRICE.
IT WAS A SEN IN THE UNITED
STATES.
AND NOW AS WE KNOW TODAY.
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE IN
SLAVERY TODAY.
I'M NOT SUPPORTING SLAVERY.
WHAT I AM SAYING IS?
I'M SUPPORTING WHAT MADE THIS
COUNTRY GREAT.
AND WE MAY NOT LIKE IT.
BUT THE CIVIL WAR ALLOWED US TO
UNDERSTAND THE FIND THE ISSUE OF
STATE'S RIGHTS.
THAT WE ACTUALLY ARE A COUNTRY.
THERE WE CAN COME TOGETHER ON
THE BELIEF THAT WE ARE ONE
PEOPLE.
AND THAT THAT WAS MORE
[inaudible]
IMPORTANT AND THE DIVISION OF
THE STATE'S THANK BACK OF A PART
OF THIS HAPPEN.
WE WEREN'T EVEN A COUNTRY A
HUNDRED YEARS THE IDEA THAT STE
STATES COULD COME TOGETHER AND
BE A UNION.
THAT'S WHAT WAS GOING ON HERE.
AND PEOPLE DIED ON BOTH SIDES
FOR THIS. FOR US TO PUT AN SJR
TO SAY THAT THOSE SOUTH CAROLINA
[inaudible]
MEN.
WHO DIED IN THIS WAR SHOULD BE
REMOVED BECAUSE WE IN CALIFORNIA
THINK IT SHOULDN'T BE THERE?
OR THAT GENERAL LEE'S HOUSE
SHOULD BE REMOVED BECAUSE SHE
WAS A LEADER OF THE CONFEDERATE
FORCES THIRTY SECONDS MR DENIES
RESPONSIBILITY OF WHAT MADE THIS
COUNTRY GREAT.
AND WHAT'S GOING ON THAT DAY AND
HOW COUNTRIES AND OF SOUTH.
TO OUT EAST COAST ACTUALLY DEALT
WITH THIS.
THIS IS A IS A WRONG HEADED
MOVEMENT WITH THIS [inaudible]
BUT TAKES HISTORY.
M. MINIMIZES IT [inaudible]
ARGENEAU.
GABRIEL HERE RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION
FRANKLY I I HAVE TO ADMIT I'M A
LITTLE BIT SURPRISED THAT
THERE'S DEBATE ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
AND I WAS REMINDED US FOLKS WERE
SPEAKING ABOUT AN EXCELLENT
SPEECH THAT --
MITCHELL ENTER THE FORMER MAYOR
OF NEW ORLEANS GAVE.
ON THE OCCASION OF THE DECISION
BY HIS CD TO REMOVE FOR
CONFEDERATE MONUMENTS AND I
THINK IT PROVIDES AN IMPORTANT
CONTEXT OF THIS DEBATE AND
MISTER SPEAKER WITH YOUR
PERMISSION.
I'D LIKE TO READ SOME VERY SHORT
ACT SEARCH IN THAT SPEECH
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SO LET'S START WITH THE FACTS
THE HISTORIC RECORD IS CLEAR.
THE ROBERT E. LEE JEFFERSON
DAVIS AND P. G. T. BEAUREGARD
STATUTES WE'RE NOT ATTRACTED
JUST TO HONOR THESE MEN.
BUT AS PART OF THE MOVEMENT
WHICH BECAME KNOWN AS THE CULT
OF THE LOST CAUSE.
THIS COLT HAD ONE GOAL.
THROUGH MONUMENTS IN THROUGH
OTHER MEANS TO REWRITE HISTORY
TO HIDE THE TRUTH.
IS THAT THE CONFEDERACY WAS ON
THE WRONG SIDE OF HUMANITY.
THE STATUTES ARE NOT JUST STONE
AND METAL.
THEY ARE NOT JUST INNOCENT
REMEMBRANCES OF A BENIGN HISTORY.
THESE MONUMENTS PURPOSEFULLY
CELEBRATE A FICTIONAL SANITIZE
CONSIDERED CITY.
IGNORING THE DEATH IGNORING THE
ENSLAVEMENT AND THE TERROR THAT
IT ACTUALLY STOOD.
FOR AFTER THE CIVIL WAR THE
STATUTES WERE PART OF IT THAT
TERRORISM AS MUCH AS BURNING A
CROSS ON SOMEONE'S LAWN.
THEY WERE ERECTED PURPOSELY TO
SEND A STRONG MESSAGE TO ALL WHO
WALKED IN THEIR SHADOW.
ABOUT WHO IS STILL IN CHARGE OF
THE CITY.
SHOULD YOU HAVE FURTHER DOUBT
ABOUT THE TRUE GOALS OF THE
CONFEDERACY IN THE VERY WEEKS
BEFORE THE WAR BROKE OUT.
THE VICE PRESIDENT THE
CONFEDERACY ALEXANDER STEPHENS
MADE IT CLEAR THAT THE
CONFEDERATE CAUSE WAS ABOUT
MAINTAINING SLAVERY AND WHITE
SUPREMACY.
HE SAID IN HIS NOW FAMOUS
CORNERSTONE SPEECH THAT THE
CONFEDERACY CORNERSTONE RESTS
UPON THE GREAT TRUTH.
THAT THE NEGRO IS NOT EQUAL TO
THE WHITE MAN.
THAT SLAVERY SUBORDINATION TO
THE SUPERIOR RACE IS HIS NATURAL
AND NORMAL CONDITION.
THIS OUR NEW GOVERNMENT IS THE
FIRST IN THE HISTORY OF THE
WORLD.
BASED UPON THIS GREAT PHYSICAL
PHILOSOPHICAL AND MORAL TRUTH.
IT'S I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
CONTACT THAT WE UNDERSTAND THE
CULT OF THE LOST CAUSE AND THE
REASON THAT FOLKS MADE AN EFFORT.
TO NAME OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
BRIDGES AND OUR ROADS AFTER
FOLKS FROM THE CONFEDERACY INTO
A WRECK THESE MONUMENTS IT'S I
HOPE FOLKS WILL KEEP IN MIND
THATCONTEXT.
WHEN THEY THINK ABOUT HOW TO
VOTE ON THIS RED DELUDE
RESOLUTION?
AND I'D REALLY RESPECTFULLY URGE
MY COLLEAGUES WHO'VE WHO'VE
EXPRESSED OPPOSITION TO THIS
RESOLUTION.
THINK ABOUT THE SYMBOLIC POWER
HERE.
AND THE POWER OF THIS RESOLUTION
IN THE MESSAGE THAT IT SENDS TO
FOLKS.
WHO ARE HISTORIC VICTIMS OF THE
CONFEDERACY AND OF THE OUR
COUNTRY'S LEGACY OF RACIAL
OPPRESSION AND ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW?
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
HERE'S GABRIEL SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
YOU KNOW A FEW OF YOU ON THE
FLOOR OF COUNTRY CAN IN SAID CAN
YOU BELIEVE WE'RE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION BUT UNFORTUNATELY I
CAN'T BECAUSE THE REASON I'M SO
PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
IS IT WAS AN ISSUE WE TOOK UP IN
MY DISTRICT.
RIGHT AFTER I GOT ELECTED WITH
ME REALIZE THAT WHAT WE ALWAYS
CALLED THE ELEMENTARY WAS
ACTUALLY ROBERT E. LEE
ELEMENTARY.
A SCHOOL THAT HAD BEEN
ESTABLISHED IN THE LATE FIFTIES
A SCHOOL THAT NOW HAS 97% PEOPLE
OF COLOR.
AND WHEN WE WORKED TO CHANGE THE
NAME OF THAT SCHOOL.
A LOT OF WHAT WAS BEING SAID
HERE ON THE FLOOR.
WAS SAID TO ME.
BY FOLKS WHO DON'T EVEN LIVE IN
THE COMMUNITY [inaudible]
COMPLEX.
THERE'S A LONG HISTORY LET'S NOT
GET RID OF OUR HISTORY BUT LET'S
TALK ABOUT THIS.
MOST SCHOOLS IN A NUMBER OF
THESE THESE ARE TRIBUTES.
WE'RE PLEASED UP IN THE FIFTIES
AND SIXTIES AS A WAY TO THREATEN
AFRICAN AMERICAN [inaudible]
FOLKS [inaudible]
A REMINDER.
A REMINDER OF WHO WAS IN CHARGE
A REWRITING OF HISTORY.
SANITIZING OF THE CONFEDERACY
[inaudible]
THAT'S NOT.
GIVING OURSELVES SOME HISTORICAL
CONTEXT.
THAT'S TRYING TO REESTABLISH.
WHAT SOME PEOPLE STILL ARE
TRYING TO JUSTIFY?
I ALMOST WALKED AWAY FROM THE
FIGHT OF RENAMING THE SCHOOL MY
DISTRICT BECAUSE IT WAS TAKING
UP SO MUCH TIME AND ENERGY.
IT WAS BECAUSE MY DAUGHTER.
WHO IMPLORED ME EMPLOYED WITH
[inaudible]
GOING.
MY DAUGHTER IS HALF BLACK.
PER FAMILY COMES FROM ALABAMA.
AND SHE REMINDED ME THAT S..
DON'T EVER LET SOMEBODY SAY.
OUR HISTORY IS COMPLEX.
PEOPLE WHO FOUGHT FOR THE
CONFEDERACY.
THE PEOPLE WHO ENSLAVED MY
DAUGHTERS ANCESTORS WHO RAPED
THEM AND KILLED THEM.
WHO SOLD THEM AND OWNS ABOUT?
IT'S NOT COMPLEX.
THERE WERE NO BUT NOT MINE
SLAVEOWNERS.
IF WE WANT TO BE SERIOUS ABOUT
OUR HISTORY.
AND WATCHING KEN BURNS
DOCUMENTARIES WE HAVE TO BE
SERIOUS ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE ALL UNFORTUNATELY.
BEEN PRODUCTS OF AN EDUCATION
SYSTEM THAT TELLS US THIS
HISTORY IS JUST.
OKAY THERE WERE GOOD PEOPLE
ROBERT REALLY WASN'T THAT BAD.
HE WAS COMPLEX NO HE WAS
FIGHTING TO HAVE A WHOLE.
BUNCH OF FOLKS CONTINUE TO BE IN
AN INSTITUTION.
WHERE THEY WERE ABLE TO BE RAPED
SOLD MURDERED?
AND OWNED.
I'M SORRY I FIND NOTHING COMPLEX
ABOUT SAYING THAT'S WRONG.
IN THAT WE SHOULD NEVER HONOR
FOLKS.
WHO ALLOW THAT TO GO FOR IT?
IN THAT OUR HISTORY SHOULD BE
HONEST IN OUR HISTORY BOOKS.
THERE WERE NO BUT NINE
SLAVEHOLDERS THERE WERE NO BUT
NINE CONFEDERATE SOLDIERS.
IN THERE SURE AS HELL WERE NO
HEROES IN THE CONFEDERACY.
FIGHTING IS TRADERS AGAINST OUR
COUNTRY.
IN FIGHTING TO CONTINUE TO OWN
MIGHT DAUGHTERS ANCESTOR.
I'M SORRY THIS WHOLE DISCUSSION
ALTHOUGH IT MIGHT MEAN.
IT'S KIND OF SICKENING.
AND I THINK IT IS TIME.
THAT WE DON'T TALK ABOUT THIS
KNOW WHAT WHAT ABOUT IS A WAY.
WHAT WHAT ARE WE GOING DOWN WHAT
ROAD ARE WE GOING DOWN BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WHAT WE SHOULD GO DOWN
THAT ROAD?
WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT OUR
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE NAMED
AFTER SLAVEHOLDERS NATIVE
AMERICANS AND WE SHOULD TALK
ABOUT OUR INSTITUTIONS AND OUR
FORMER PRESIDENTS THAT DID
THINGS THAT WERE REALLY BAD IN
ATROCIOUS.
AND QUIT ACTING.
LIKE THEY'RE HEROIC BECAUSE THEY
WERE IN A DIFFERENT TIME PERIOD
[inaudible]
WELL HUMAN.
IN THE WERE PLENTY OF PEOPLE IN
THAT TIME PERIOD WHO KNEW
SLAVERY WAS FROM.
IN THE WHERE PLENTY OF PEOPLE
WHO KNEW WE ARE ALL HUMAN BEINGS
AND SHOULD BE TREATED THAT WAY.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT HISTORY SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
M. AS GONZALEZ FLETCHER WOULD
YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THE FIRST ROLE WILL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE SJ OUR COURT
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
IS FOR COOPER.
ON SJ ARE FOURTEEN THIS IS CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
S. CO AUTHORS [inaudible]
QUIRK.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE
FIFTY SIX CO AUTHORS ADDED AS AN
SJ ARE WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VETERANS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THIS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ON THE RESOLUTION [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
FIFTY EIGHT NOSE TO THE
RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
MR GARCIA I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
SOME GAS THAT ARRIVED IN THE
CHAMBER MISTER GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED I DO MISTER SPEAKER
AND THINK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR
YOUR ATTENTION I CAN'T IMAGINE A
BETTER OPPORTUNITY FOR YOUNG MAN.
WHO WILL BE STARTING?
HIGH SCHOOL OR I'M SORRY GOING
BACK TO SCHOOL --
TOMORROW AND HAD JUST WITNESSED
A VERY IMPORTANT DISCUSSION.
ON AMERICAN HISTORY BUT TO OUR
TWO MY INTRODUCTION I'D LIKE UP
MISTER.
I STEAL A BOTH AYE XANDER'S
FATHER EAST MY HEAD TO STAND UP
THEY ARE VISITING FROM BRAWLEY
CALIFORNIA.
A HE IS A STUDENT THERE ARE
PROBABLY UNION HIGH SCHOOL OUR
COMMUNITY IS EXTREMELY PROUD.
OF THIS TALENTED YOUNG BOXER
FROM IMPERIAL COUNTY WHO WAS
ABLE TO BRING HOME A BRONZE
JUNIOR OLYMPIC MEDAL RECENTLY.
GIVE HIM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
[inaudible]
I REPRESENTS.
I DIDN'T REPRESENTS BAD WALKING
WHICH STANDS FOR BOXING AGAINST
DRUGS UNDER THE USA BOXING
ASSOCIATION.
AFTER MANY VICTORIES IN THE RING
HE WAS ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR THE
NATIONALS WHICH WAS HELD THIS
YEAR IN CHARLESTON WEST VIRGINIA.
REPRESENTING REGION FOURTEEN
CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA ISAAC
COMPETED IN THE FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
YEAR OLD. NINETY FIVE POUND
DIVISION.
WHERE HE FACED OFF WITH THE BEST
IN THE NATION?
AFTER WINNING THE QUARTERFINALS
HE ADVANCE TO THE SEMIFINALS
WHERE HE WON HIS BRONZE MEDAL.
HE'S PRETTY RANK NUMBER NINE IN
THE NATION FOR THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN JUNIOR OLYMPICS AND
HE'S ALSO RIGHT NUMBER TWO IN
THE NATION FOR THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NATIONAL SOBRE GLOVES
TOURNAMENT.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN GIVING THIS
YOUNG CHAMPION A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT WILL SUCCEED TO
WEIGH THE FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE HERE A. B. TEN
SIXTY FIVE JONES SAWYER TODAY
UPON GERMANS OF SESSION IN ROOM.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION THT REQUEST IS
GRANTED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT ALL SIXTY TWO A
THE FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENTS. TO
ALLOW THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE TO ADD THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO THE HEARING TODAY UPON
A GERMAN OF SESSION IN ROOM.
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN AS WE SEVENTY
SIX BATES SCR ONE THIRTY THREE
BERRYHILL AND SCR WHEN FIFTY
NINE BATES.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
REQUEST IS GRANTED [inaudible]
I MS WALDRON OBJECT TO THAT
MOTION.
MISS WALDRON IS WITHHOLDING.
ON THAT SECOND MOTION MISS
WALDRON IS WITHHOLDING.
WE ASSURE CALDERON MOVES THE
ROLL SUSPENSION MISTER GIBSON
SECONDS MEMBERS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE.
MARC LEVINE ROLL-ON.
MISTER CALDERON SASSY FOR NIVEAU
MISS WALDRON NO MISS CALLED
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
AND MISS WALDRON OR NO THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE ON THE RULE
SUSPENSION TAKES [inaudible]
FORTY ONE WORK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
I SWEAR TO HEAVEN KNOWS.
EIGHTEEN THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK.
TO FILE ITEM.
TO TEN FILE AN TO TEN S. B.
[inaudible]
TWELVE SEVENTY FOUR CORKERY.
SENATE BILL TWELVE SEVENTY FOUR
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE AND ACTUALLY
THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
[inaudible]
MS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
AM PRESENTING S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY FOUR BY MCGUIRE.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
DISCLOSE ELIGIBILITY AND
ENROLLMENT DATA. FOR THE CAL
WORKS AND CALPERS PROGRAMS TWO
DDS. TO ASSIST IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF EMPLOYMENT
FIRST POLICY.
THIS BILL HAD BEEN OUR A CONSENT
COUNT --
CANDIDATE THROUGHOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THAT'S I
STRONGLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS RUBIO SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CORD CLUB THE ROLL-ON MEMBERSHIP
OF HERE'S OUR VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE [inaudible]
SUSANVILLE.
BURKE WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ON I SIXTY SEVEN
NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WHO ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE OUT.
FILE ITEM. TO FOURTEEN VIOLENT
TO FOURTEEN IS S. B.. TEN
SEVENTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS.
MS RIVER US [inaudible]
YOU MISTER CURRENT MEMBERS SP
TEN SEVENTY SIX BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO EVALUATE THE RISK OF
ELECTROMAGNETIC.
PULSE ATTACKS AND YOU'LL
MAGNETIC STORM EVENTS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PREPARE FOR
SUCH HAZARDS.
THE SOLAR PULSE EVENTS WOULD
RENDER CALIFORNIA UNABLE TO
PROVIDE ELECTRICITYFOR MILLIONS
OF RESIDENTS AT AN UNPRECEDENTED
ECONOMIC AND HUMAN COST.
PREPARATION FOR THESE SOLAR
PULSE EVENTS IS CRUCIAL TO
SAFEGUARDING OUR CITIZENS FROM
SUCH A CATASTROPHE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
NAME IS RIVEN SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CORPORAL OF NARAL.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY THREE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS A RETAIN.
ON FILE ITEMS.
TO SEVENTEEN AND TO EIGHTEEN
WE'VE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
TO NINETEEN PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEMS.
TO TWENTY THROUGH TWO TWENTY
FOUR WE'VE DISPENSED A FILE I'M.
TO TWENTY FIVE WE ARE FILE ITEM.
TWO TWENTY SIX S. B. TWELVE
FIFTY ONE CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL TWELVE FIFTY ONE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND ACTUALLY TO
UNEMPLOYMENT MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE.
MISTER DALY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE.
REPEALS THE SUNSET DATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TRAINING BENEFITS
PROGRAM MAKING THE PROGRAM
PERMANENT.
THE BILL ALSO REPEALS IN
EXISTING PROHIBITION ON
PARTICIPANTS RECEIVING
DISCRETIONARY USE PAYMENTS.
IF THE TRAINING BENEFITS PROGRAM
WHERE TO SUNSET CALIFORNIA WOULD
BE AT RISK OF LOSING MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
ADMINISTRATIVE GRANTS.
AND FEDERAL EMPLOYER TAX CREDIT.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
DANISH DAILY.
SAME NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
COR CLUB THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
WORK WELL CLOSER ROLE.
CALVET EYES FORTY EIGHT KNOWS
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS. TWO
TWENTY SEVEN THROUGH TO THIRTY
ONE TO PASS A RETAIN.
A FILE AND TWO THIRTY TWO THAT
BRINGS US [inaudible]
TO FILE ITEM. TWO THIRTY THREE
S. B..
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR HERNANDEZ AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE MEDI CAL.
MISTER KANSEN HU YOU MAY OPEN
SICKER MISTER SPEAKER IS THEIR
MEMBERS SP FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE
IS A CLEAN UP BILL.
OF FOOD LAST YEAR'S ESPY TWO TO
THREE BY SENATOR ACTIONS DAD DO
ALIGNED CALIFORNIA LAW WAS A
FEDERAL REQUIREMENT.
OWN INTERPRETER SERVICES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A
NICE [inaudible]
FIFTY THREE KNOWS.
FOR THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS A RETAIN.
ON FILE ITEMS TO THIRTY FOUR AND
TWO THIRTY FIVE ROSS GOING TO
PASS A RETAIN A FILE ITEMS.
TO THIRTY EIGHT THROUGH.
TWO FORTY THREE PAST RETAIN OUT
FILE ITEM [inaudible]
TO FORTY FIVE THROUGH. TO FIFTY
SIX WE DISPENSE OF VIOLENT TO
FIFTY SEVEN PASS RETAIN A FILE
IN.
TWO FIFTY EIGHT MOVING TO TAKE
UP PART MAY PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEMS.
TO SIXTY THROUGH.
TWO SIXTY FOUR WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM.
TO SIXTY FIVE IS FILE ITEM.
TO SIXTY FIVE S. B. [inaudible]
THREE NINETY EIGHT CORKERY.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY EIGHT
BY SENATOR MINING AND ACTUALLY
THERE ACQUIRED BRAIN TRAUMA
[inaudible]
MR THURMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT.
S. B. THREE NINETY EIGHT A BILL
TO SUPPORT THOSE WHO BEEN
IMPACTED BY TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY.
THIS BILL EXTENDS A SUNSET DATE
FOR THE TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY
PROGRAM. TWENTY NINETEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THE PROGRAM
WAS ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE AND PROVIDES GRANTS
TO COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
CORE NAY SERVICES. TO ASSIST
ADULTS WITH AN ACQUIRED.
DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURY THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
ADMINISTERS A PROGRAM AND
THEY'RE CURRENTLY SEVEN SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
THIS PROGRAM SERVICE HAS SERVED
THOUSANDS OF SURVIVORS AND
ASSIST WITH THE REHABILITATION
AND INDEPENDENT LIVING AND HAS
BEEN EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE WITH
VERY LIMITED RESOURCES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THINGS THURMOND.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE.
TELL YOU BUT I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
KEY
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO JUMP
AHEAD.
IN THE FILE. TO FILE ITEM.
THREE TWENTY IS FILE ITEM THREE
TWENTY MEMBERS [inaudible]
S. BE. THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
THE CLERK READ WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME AMBER
FRAZIER.
MISTER FRAZIER ON THE MINUTES
MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU THE
AMENDMENTS PRESIDENT.
PRESENTED TODAY MAKE CLARIFYING
IN TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE BILL
ASK DR.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
MISS WALDRON FOR PURPOSE WE
OPPOSE THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A ROLL CALL ON
THESE AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WISH TO VOTE
THE TO THE AMENDMENTS TO SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX THESE ARE
THE AMENDMENTS.
MAJORITY PRESIDENT VOTING
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE THERE ARE. FORTY
EIGHT AYES TWENTY ONE KNOWS THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED TO BILL
IS OUT TO PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
IT MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO NOW
JUMPED TO FILE ITEM.
THREE FORTY THIS IS A JUMP TO
FILE ITEM.
THREE FOUR ZERO AGAIN
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM THREE
OF FORTY S. B. FOR SIXTY FIVE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
QUICK READ WITH IMMENSE.
SAMPLE FOR SIXTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY FAMILY MEMBER
LIMON.
MISS LAMAR ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU I SPEAKERS MEMBERS I
REYES TO OFFER FLOOR AMENDMENTS
FOR SP.
FOUR SIX FIVE OF FILE ITEM
THIRTY SP FOUR SIX FIVE MAKE
CERTAIN STATUTORY CHANGES TO THE
MISSION OF CALIFORNIA'S DIVISION
OF OIL GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
RESOURCES.
THE FLOOR MEN MEANT AT THE DESK
WOULD INSTEAD ENACT THE WILDFIRE
SAFETY FINANCE ACT WHICH
AUTHORIZES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
EXPAND THEIR PROPERTY.
ASSESSED CLEAN ENERGY OR PASTE
PROGRAMS TO ALLOW PROPERTY
OWNERS TO FINANCING INSTALLATION
OF WILDFIRE SAFETY.
IMPROVEMENTS THESE AMENDMENTS
WOULD ALLOW HOMEOWNERS IN HIGH
FIRE HAZARD AREAS AMONG OTHERS
TO MAKE THEIR HOMES MORE
RESILIENCE WHILE FIRED BY
CREATING AN FINANCING TOOL TO
GET RID OF STRUCTURAL HAZARD.
LIKE WOOD WERE SHINGLE ROOFS AND
WOOD SAT WITH CITING.
THEY MISS AMOUNT MISS WALDRON WE
OPPOSE THE AMENDMENT.
MEMBERS WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE
ON THE MERCED WHICH TO VOTE THIS.
ON THE AMENDMENTS.
MAJORITY PRESENT IN VOTING
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
I FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY THE
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL'S
HOW TO PRINT THEM BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE. TO
THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
TO FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY IS
A C. ARE. TWO SEVENTY SEVEN BY
MR MEDINA [inaudible]
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT LUCIEN TO
SEVENTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AND OTHERS PHILLIPS TO
EPILEPSY AWARENESS MONTH
[inaudible]
MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT ACR.
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN WHICH
PROCLAIMS NOVEMBER.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS
EPILEPSY AWARENESS MONTH
[inaudible]
MEMBERS ONE IN TEN PEOPLE THE
UNITED STATES HAS HAD A SINGLE.
UNPROVOKED SEIZURE.
OR HAS BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH
EPILEPSY [inaudible]
CURRENTLY. THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
[inaudible]
HAVE EPILEPSY.
AND OVER SIXTY FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE.
WORLDWIDE.
ARE LIVING WITH THE DISEASE.
AND MISTER CHAIR.
I ASK FOR ORDER IN THE HOUSE
PLEASE [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MANY PEOPLE LIVING WITH EPILEPSY.
FACE A SENSE OF DISCRIMINATION
AND ISOLATION FROM THEIR PEERS.
WE CAN HELP THOSE AFFECTED BY
BRINGING AWARENESS TO THE
CONDITION.
AND ALLEVIATING THAT FEAR.
SCREAMIN NATION AND BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT.
S. VARIANCE BY PEOPLE LIVING
WITH EPILEPSY.
I CALL UPON ALL CITIZENS
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS.
BUSINESSES AND SCHOOLS TO
RECOMMIT OUR COMMUNITY TO
INCREASE IN AWARENESS AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THOSE LIVING
WITH EPILEPSY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND ASKED THAT THE FIRST
ROLL THE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA.
SAME NO DISCRETION DEBATE ON THE
RESOLUTION THE AUTHORS ASSN OF
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
ON ACR TO SEVENTY SEVEN CARPOOL
OF ON THE RUN.
THIS IS COAUTHORS MEMBERS CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTE.
A CO AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SIXTY EIGHT
COAUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE.
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY ONE H. R. ONE TWENTY
ONE BY MISTER COOPER.
CORPOREAL HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE
TWENTY ONE BY SOME REMEMBER
COOPER BELT OF CHERRY MOUTH.
FOR MALFORMATION AWARENESS MONTH.
MISTER COOPER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS HR ONE TWENTY
ONE WILL CLEAR THE MONTH OF
SEPTEMBER.
IF CHIARI MALFORMATION AWARENESS
MONTH.
SERIOUS NEUROLOGICAL DISORDER
WAS BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION FROM
A CONSTITUENT Y. DISTRICT CITY
GILSTRAP WHOSE FAMILIESIN THE
GALLERY.
BRINGS A SESSION PLEASE STAND UP.
SONY'S DAUGHTER WROTE ME A VERY
NICE THANK YOU LETTER WITH
HEARTS ON IT --
CHIARI MALFORMATION AFFECTS OVER
THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
KERRY MALFORMATION THE DEFECT IN
THE CEREBRUM THE PART THE BRAIN
THAT CONTROLS BALANCE SYMPTOMS
USUALLY APPEAR DURING
ADOLESCENCE.
THANK INCLUDE SEVERE HEAD AND
NECK PAIN.
VERTIGO MUSCLE WEAKNESS DOUBLE
VISION.
COOLEY SWALLOWING AND SLEEP
APNEA [inaudible]
TYPICALLY SECOND. FOR THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO AREA WILL
JOIN THE THOUSANDS OF
PARTICIPANTS ACROSS THE NATION A
FROM RAISING WALKED SPONSORED BY.
CONQUER CHIARI WALK ACROSS
AMERICA.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING THE MONTH OF
SEPTEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS
CHIARI MALFORMATION AWARENESS
MONTH.
WHICH REFLECTS THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER.
THAT WAS MY SEAT MATE.
NO APPLAUSE DURING DEBATE DOCTOR
ARAMBULA BUT WE APPRECIATE YOUR
ENTHUSIASM.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE THE AUTHORS ASSN FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS FOR
CLUB THE ROLL-ON THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL THEIR
SIXTY FIVE CO AUTHORS ADDED AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE.
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND NOW WE MAY
WELCOME OUR GUESTS IN THE
CHAMBER [inaudible]
I MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE
CONCURRENCE FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO CONCURRENCE
[inaudible]
BEGINNING WITH.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE AB FOUR OH SIX BY MR
MCCARTY CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR OF SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
MR MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AFTER
SEVERAL YEARS OF DEBATE AND THE
LAST YEAR AND A HALF OF
NEGOTIATIONS WITH BOTH SIDES I
COME TODAY WITH A COMPROMISE ON
THE ISSUE RELATED TO FOR PROFIT.
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THIS WOULD ESSENTIALLY --
PROHIBIT THESE FOR PROFIT
CHARTER SCHOOLS FROM OPERATING --
AS A FOR PROFIT BUSINESS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AGAIN THIS
WAS WORKED OUT BETWEEN OUR
TEACHERS UNIONS AND THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION.
AND WHY DOES THIS MATTER BECAUSE
PUBLIC DOLLARS SHOULD BE FOCUSED
ON STUDENT SUCCESS AND NOT
CORPORATE PROFITS.
AND JUST KNOW LAST TWO YEARS WE
HAVE AN EXAMPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GOING AFTER.
K. TWELVE INK AND SETTLING FOR
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR I BILKING THE TAXPAYERS AND
NOT SERVING STUDENT SO WELL.
I IN A COUPLE IS EXAMPLES AYE K.
TWELVE BEING.
ENROLLED FOR EXAMPLE A STUDENT.
FOR I GOT A FULL DAY'S A EIGHTY
A FOR WEEKS AND MONTHS AT A TIME
SO THIS WILL ESSENTIALLY I PUT
TO REST THIS ISSUE OF FOR PROFIT
CHARTER SCHOOLS ALLOW US.
TO REALIZE THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE THE WAY THE LAND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA REALLY THIRTY YEARS.
BUT THE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE
NONPROFIT AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
SHOULD BE BASED UPON.
SERVING OUR STUDENTS SERVING OUR
OUR KIDS BUT NOT FOR CORPORATE
PROFITS FOR SHAREHOLDERS --
WALL STREET SO WITH THAT TASK
YOU'RE AYE VOTE ON THIS --
COMPROMISE WE HAVE HERE TODAY
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY JUSTICE.
A US MCCARTY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE START
MISTER THURMOND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AYE RISES JOINT AUTHOR --
OF AB FOR A SIX IN URGE AYE VOTE
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
SACRAMENTO FORCE LEADERSHIP IN.
FACILITATION THAT HE DESCRIBED
TO HELP REAP BRING THIS BILL A
TO COMPROMISE I JUST ECHO AT
WHAT WE'VE JUST HEARD --
THAT IN AN ERA WHERE OUR
STUDENTS STRUGGLE TO GET AN
EDUCATION.
THERE'S NO REASON WHY A FOR
PROFIT COMPANY.
PROFIT MORE THAN EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE YEAR --
SIMILAR COMPANY THAT HAD.
MORE THAN ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
JUST SIX EXECUTIVES WHAT THE
SAME TIME PAYING AN AVERAGE
TEACHER SALARY. THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS EACH.
SAME COMPANIES THAT HAVE BEEN
TRADED.
HAN WALL STREET --
AND HAVE HAD TO SETTLE LAWSUITS.
FOR FAILING TO SERVE STUDENTS
AND MANIPULATING ATTENDANCE
RECORDS.
OVERSTATED STUDENT SUCCESS WITH
THE GRADUATION RATE OF ONLY 36%.
OF ITS STUDENTS THANK YOU FOR
VOTING FOR THIS TODAY BECAUSE A
SENDS A MESSAGE.
THAT PUBLIC EDUCATION IS JUST
THAT PUBLIC EDUCATION IN THE
PUBLIC DOLLARS SHOULD NOT
SUBSIDIZE THE PROFITS OF
EXECUTIVES AND FOR PROFIT.
COMPANIES ON BEHALF OF OUR
STUDENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
NAMES THURMAN.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLL-ON THIS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. TO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TELL I VOTE EYES
WERE NINE KNOWS FIFTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
FOR HIS AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
EIGHT BY DR QUIRK.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE NINETY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK AND
ACTUALLY TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY EIGHT DEALS
WITH FINE CITIES AND COUNTIES
CAN LEVY.
AGAINST BUILDING PROPERTY OWNERS
FOR VIOLATION OF LOCAL BUILDING
AND SAFETY CODE VIOLATIONS.
OUR AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
SENATE WERE CLARIFYING AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY EIGHT IS SPONSORED
BY THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES.
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
QUIRK GLOBAL ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO WOULD WISH TO
VOTE [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ROLLTIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS FIFTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM OR FIVE
WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX A. B.
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY TWO CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMON AND
ACTUALLY CREDIT UNIONS MISS
LAMAR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
TWO IS A CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNIONIST ASSOCIATION BILL WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
THE BILL HAS NOT RECEIVED VOTES
IN OPPOSITION AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE WERE TECHNICAL AND NON
SUBSTANTIVE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
pARE CONCURRED AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
SEVEN IS A. B. TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY BY SOME A
MEMBER HARPER AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
SURE HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCY RECEIVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES.
THE AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
WERE MINOR AND TECHNICAL CHANGE
THE BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE FOR AB.
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY THANK YOU
MISTER HARPER SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
BUTTONS ARE VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRABLE.
ALL NUMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS AIRED ABOUT.
IT'S THE GREEN BUTTON MEMBERS
THAT'S THE GREEN BUTTON
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL.
TYPE BUT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT IS AC ARE
ONE OF THREE OR FOUR READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE OF THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO MATTHEW SLOW STRINGER FRANK
MEMORIAL HIGHWAY [inaudible]
MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ACR ONE OF THREE I NAMES OF
PORTION A HIGHWAY ONE I ONE
AFTER.
MATTHEW SLOW STRINGER FRANK --
MATTHEW FRANK ALSO KNOWS FLOWS
STRINGER WAS AN IMPORTANT PART
OF OUR CENTRAL BECAUSE COMMUNITY.
HE SPENT HIS OWN TIME HIS OWN
MONEY IN HIS OWN ENERGY.
REPORTING ON BREAKING EVENTS
SUCH AS FIRES.
AND OTHER THINGS HE HAD A
FUNERAL LAST YEAR AND OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE ATTENDED
INCLUDING OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
FIREFIGHTERS POLICE OFFICERS.
HE RAN OUT OF A WEBSITE A
FACEBOOK ACCOUNT A TWITTER
ACCOUNT.
TO INFORM THE PUBLIC OF BREAKING
NEWS AND I'M JUST VERY HONORED
TODAY TO HAVE THE CHANCE TO
PRESENT THIS RESOLUTION NAMING A
BEAUTIFUL STRETCH OF HIGHWAY.
ONE TO ONE AFTER A BELOVED
MEMBER OF OUR COMMUNITY THANK
YOU.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU MISS CUNNINGHAM.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL ON THIS
[inaudible]
ACR.
QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL.
TIDE VOTE I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT.
FILE ITEM NINE IS ACR
[inaudible]
TO FOURTEEN CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO FOURTEEN BY SELLING MEMBER
GIPSON AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPUTY DID YOUR M. HURDLE
MEMORIAL HIGHWAY [inaudible]
MISTER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SPEAKING
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT ACR TO
FOURTEEN WHICH WERE DESIGNATED
SPECIFIC PORTION OF THE ONE OF
FIVE FREEWAY.
AS THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY --
SHARE DEPUTY HURDLES MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY THIS RESOLUTION
COMMEMORATES --
THE DEPUTY WHO WAS KILLED IN THE
LINE OF DUTY THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADJUST THE LOCATION.
OF THE MEMORIAL HIGHWAY TO
INCLUDE LOCATIONS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO THE DEPUTIES FAMILY
AND TO THE SPEAKER.
AND AT THE SPEAKERS A CO AUTHOR
I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THANK YOU WHICH GIPSON.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
WE WILL AGAIN TAKE A ROLL CALL
ON THIS ACR CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
I'M VOTERS TO VOTE ON THE
RISOTTO WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
SIX NEWS ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
FILE AND NUMBER TEN IS AB.
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
BY SOME A MEMBER QUIRK AND
ACTUALLY TO ELECTRICALLY
CONDUCTIVE BALLOONS.
DOCTOR QUIRK YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AB.
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY WILL BRING
INCREASED CONSUMER AWARENESS TO
THE HAZARDS OF METALLIC FELL OR
MY LAWLER BELIEVES STRIKING
POWER LINES.
POWER LINES STRIKES BY BALLOONS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THOUSANDS OF
POWER OUTAGES TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF ACRES OF WILDFIRE
[inaudible]
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
HARMONIZED EXISTING MYLAR
BALLOON LAW WITH THE EFFORTS OF
THE SPELL.
THANK YOU.
THANK THAT QUIRK SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LOVE MARIAH I'M VOTERS OUT
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IS THERE TO VOTE [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE ITALIAN ICE FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS TEN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
ARE CONCURRENT PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM.
ELEVEN WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE AB NINETY THREE OR FOUR
RATE ASSEMBLY WILL NINETY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND
ACTING LIKE HEALING ARTS.
MACHINE MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB NINETY THREE IS BACK
FOR GOOD CURRENTS AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE MINOR AND
TECHNICAL IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY MISSED MEDINA SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT I'M.
TIRED VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTES EYES
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN IS AB
ONE NINETY THREE BY MISS
CERVANTES CLERK WILL READ.
SOMETHING A ONE NINETY THREE BY
FAMILY MEMBERS CERVANTES AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
VEHICULAR AIR POLLUTION.
MISTER MONTH S..
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
DAM PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
NINETY THREE FOR CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS AB ONE NINETY
THREE WILL ESTABLISH THE ZERO
MISSION ASSURANCE PROJECT OR ZAP.
THIS PROGRAM WILL MAKE
REPLACEMENT BATTERIES FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES ARE ZAPS MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR MIDDLE INCOME AND
WORKING CLASS CALIFORNIANS.
ACCORDING TO AN APRIL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN STUDY DONE BY UC DAVIS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CONCERNS FOR
CONSUMERS CONSIDERING WHETHER TO
BUY.
AS A VEHICLE IS BATTERY LIFE.
THIS CONCERN IS WELL FOUNDED AS
REPLACEMENTS ARE BATTERIES CAN
COST ANYWHERE FROM 550-021-5000
DOLLARS ZERO MISSION ASSURANCE
PROJECT WOULD PROVIDE LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS BUT THE REBATE IN
ORDER TO PURCHASE A REPLACEMENT
BATTERY OR FUEL CELL.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE NINETY THREE
REPRESENTS A CRITICAL STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION IN ACHIEVING
OUR GOAL OF PUTTING MORE HIS ABS
ON CALIFORNIA ROADS AND HIGH
RATE WHAT HIGHWAYS AND
RESPECTFULLY AUSTRIA AYE VOTE.
ON CONCURRENT AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THEY MISTER MONTESINOS
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
WORK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY FOUR KNOWS FIFTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEMS FOURTEEN THROUGH SEVENTEEN
PASS RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN
AB?
ELEVEN SIXTEEN OPERATE ASSEMBLY
BILL LEVIN SIXTEEN BY SOME A
MEMBER GRAYSON AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO EMERGENCY SERVICES
[inaudible]
MISTER GRAYSON.
THANK YOU SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN SIXTEEN IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
LIMIT THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
TO A PILOT PROGRAM FOR
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
CDC ARE AND SPECIFIED EMERGENCY
SERVICE PERSONNEL AND CREATE A
LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE TO
DEVELOP STANDARDS FOR PEER
SUPPORT PROGRAMS INCLUDING
DEFINING WHAT WILL BE COVERED
UNDER THE CONFIDENTIALITY
PROVISIONS.
LAST YEAR DURING THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE AND COSTLY FIRE
SEASON IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY
MORE FIREFIGHTERS DIED BY
SUICIDE THAN THOSE WHO DIED IN
THE LINE OF DUTY ONE HUNDRED AND
THREE COMPARED.
TO NINETY THREE BY PROVIDING
ACCESS TO QUALIFIED CONFIDENTIAL
PEER SUPPORT SERVICES WE CAN
ENSURE OUR FIRST RESPONDERS ARE
NOT AFRAID TO SEEK HELP AND
ULTIMATELY SAVE LIVES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I NAMES
GRAYSON SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE HOWEVER I SIXTY
THREE OVER THE ROLE --
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY VOTE I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOR BY
MISTER CALDERON QUACKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR FIGHTS IN THE NUMBER
CALDERON AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE FOOD FACILITIES [inaudible]
MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THIS IS AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOR WHICH IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE THIS IS MUCH DRAWS
UPON REQUEST BILL MY COLLEAGUES
FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH FAVORITE
BILL LEFT AUTHORED THIS YEAR --
ONE BE REALLY CLEAR ABOUT A
COUPLE POINTS THIS IS. FOR
DINING RESTAURANTS ONLY WHERE
YOU GO AND THERE'S A SERVER
THAT'S IN YOU --
YOUR FOOD IN YOUR STRAW --
IT'S I REQUEST IF NOT A BAN.
AND THIS IS TO HELP RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE ISSUE THE
POSSE POLLUTION HAVING THAT
REDUCTION OF SINGLE USE PLASTIC
STRAWS.
IN OUR RESTAURANTS IS A GOOD
THING -- AND
YOU KNOW THIS IS A LITTLE THIS
IS A SMALL STEP THAT IS IN A
BAND THAT CAN HELP US CURVE THE
ISSUE OF OF SINGLE USE CLASSICS
IN OUR ENVIRONMENT.
THE GETTING IN OUR OCEAN OUR
WATERWAYS AND OUR LANDFILLS
THESE ARE NOT EASILY RECYCLABLE
MATERIALS SO THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP --
I REALLY WANT TO THINK --
THERE FROM SANTA MONICA FOR THE
WORK THAT HE'S DONE ON THIS
ISSUE IT'S A BIG DEAL IT'S IT'S
GETTING A LOT OF ATTENTION I
THINK IT DOES A LOT OF GOOD AND
I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT FIRST
STEP.
IN THE RIGHT BALANCE WHEN IT
COMES TO HELPING US --
TRY TO TACKLE THE ISSUE OF
SINGLE USE PLASTICS IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT I THINK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON MS
MELENDEZ THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER --
SO.
I THINK EVERYONE IN HERE AGREES
THAT WE'D ALL LIKE TO REDUCE
WASTE IN OUR WATERWAYS INNER
OCEANS THERE'S NOTHING WORSE
THAN GOING TO THE BEACH AND
SEEING PEOPLE LEAVE THEIR TRASH
BEHIND AND IT'S JUST.
IF IT'S NOT A GOOD THING
PARTICULARLY BEAUTIFUL COASTLINE
OF CALIFORNIA SO WITH THAT.
WHERE WORDS WERE TOGETHER WERE
AYE AYE ON THAT OKAY HOWEVER --
YA BEEN LARGELY SILENT ON THIS
STRAW THING BUT I HAVE TO SAY
THAT I'M WONDERING WHY WE HAVE A
BILL AND I KNOW BABY STEPS BY.
IT IT ONLY APPLIES TO SIT DOWN
RESTAURANTS NOT.
TAKE OUT RESTAURANT IT'S WHICH
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
WHEN YEAR TO SIT DOWN RESTAURANT
YOU'RE NOT WHEN YOU LEAVE THE
RESTAURANT YOU'RE NOT TAKING
YOUR STRAW WITH YOU?
WHEN YOU'RE LEAVING A TAKE OUT
RESTAURANT YOU ARMY THAT'S
LARGELY YOU KNOW WHERE YOU
GETTING THEIR STAR SO I JUST
DON'T SEE HOW THIS IS GOING TO
MAKE?
THAT MUCH OF A DIFFERENCE.
AND REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF
STRIDES IN THE WATERWAYS --
I'M SURE THE AUTHOR PROBABLY
TRIED.
TO TIE IN FAST FOOD RESTAURANTS
IN THERE BUT PERHAPS CUTS IN
PUSH BACK ON THAT THANK YOU --
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY.
PUNISHING THE RESTAURANT --
FOR DEFYING THIS MANDATE I JUST
THINK SENDS THE WRONG MESSAGE OF
BIG EDUCATION CAMPAIGN MAKES
SENSE FOR SURE AND I THINK --
AN INCENTIVE BASED PROGRAM MAKES
EVEN MORE SENSE BUT THIS TYPE OF
PROGRAM WHERE THEY'RE BEING
PUNISHED WITH JUST IT DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE THE RIGHT FIT SO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE A NO VOTE.
MR MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE AUTHOR THE
BILL BUT WHEN I I TAKE MY WIFE
OUT TO EAT AND WE SIT DOWN AND
FINALLY HAVE A CHANCE TO GET
AWAY FROM THE KIDS I'M NOT
LOOKING FOR A LECTURE ON STRAWS
IN OCEAN HEALTH BY IN.
AN INTERRUPTION OF THE AMBIANCE --
LET US LOOK AT EDUCATION FOR
QUEEN OF THE OCEANS AND STOP
LET'S NOT DO IT WHEN WE FINALLY
GET A LITTLE PEACE AWAY FROM THE
KIDS.
A LOS ANGELES MILLS WITH OUR
LOVED ONES AND SET AGAIN
LECTURES ASK FOR NO VOTE
[inaudible]
SURE HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
JUST WANTED TOUCH ON ONE POINT
THAT I THINK THAT WAS
ACKNOWLEDGED OF PREVIOUSLY
DURING THE FLOOR DEBATE.
IN THIS IS A PRIME EXAMPLE OF
INCREMENTALISM I THINK THAT WAS
UP BROUGHT UP.
A BY THE MEMBER FOR RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
THAT THIS IS JUST THE FIRST STEP.
TOWARDS A COMPLETE BAN.
IF REPREHENSIBLE PENALTIES
TOWARD SMALL ABOUT BUSINESS.
AND THAT ENTRY IS AN INTRODUCED
IN THE US SUBSEQUENT LEGISLATIVE
CYCLE.
IT WILL BE INTRODUCED VERY SOON.
BECAUSE ALL THIS IS IS JUST
INCREMENTALISM TOWARDS NANNY
STATE GOVERNMENT CONTROL I ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE.
SAYING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM MISTER
CALDERON YOU MAY CLOSE I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL LITERALLY
HAS NO OPPOSITION THE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION.
DOES NOT OPPOSE THIS BILL THEY
DON'T SEE THESE FINES EYES BEING
REPREHENSIBLE WOULD WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THAT.
V. REPREHENSIBLE ASPECT OF THIS
BILL IT'S TWO WARNINGS AND THEN
A TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR FINE CAPPED
AT THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS I IT'S
JUST IT'S REASONABLE IT'S A
REASONABLE STEP THAT'S WHY THE
REST ONE ASSOCIATION IS NOT IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
THAT'S WHY THE PLASTICS INDUSTRY
ARE THE ONES MAKING THE STRAWS
ARE NOT IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL AND IT'S ALSO IF THERE'S
GOT TO BE A RECOGNITION THAT AS
WE STE.
AS WE CHANGE AND WE WE EVOLVE IN
OUR THINKING ABOUT OUR
CONVENIENCES VERSE IS WHAT'S
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY --
THAT WE TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
THE POTENTIAL IMPACT SECOND HAVE
THAT CAN HAPPEN WHEN WE MAKE
THESE CHANGES AND SO BY DOING AN
INCREMENTAL STEP THAT'S THE
RIGHT WAY TO DO IT.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHERE WE ARE
SIGNALING TO THE INDUSTRY TO THE
MANUFACTURERS THAT THIS IS WHERE
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE TODAY THIS
IS WHAT THE STATE IS TODAY IT
GIVES THEM THE OPPORTUNITY AND
THE TIME. TO FIND A DIFFERENT
SOLUTION.
ALLOW FOR IT.
TO AND I THINK THAT THAT'S HOW
WE SHOULD DO IT AND YOU KNOW
WHAT THE BEST CASE SCENARIO IS
THEY JUST ARE TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS ON THEIR OWN.
JUST LIKE STARBUCKS MADE THE
DECISION ON THEIR OWN THAT'S
JUST LIKE MCDONALDS IN THE UK
DID IT ON THEIR OWN AND THEY'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING AT DOING THAT
AND IN THE UNITED STATES.
JUST LIKE THE EUROPEAN UNION --
YOU KNOW THEY'RE NOW LOOKING AT
THIS SO OUT A LOT OF SMALL
RESTAURANTS THEY TALK TO ME THE
LIKE I LIKE THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
GIVES ME THE OPTION IT'S KINDA
HONESTLY GOING TO SAVE ME ON
COST BECAUSE WHEN I PUT THAT
STRAW DOWN THE TABLE EVEN IF
IT'S WRAPPED.
UP I STILL THROWN AWAY FOR
HEALTH PURPOSES SO THIS IS SMART
THIS IS COMMON SENSE IT'S IT'S
NOT OVER BURDEN SOME IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR AT IN
ORDER JUST. TO TO TO TO BE OUGHT
TO TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT --
YET BUT THEY'RE BEING COMPLYING
WITH THE LAW SO IT'S A FOR A
GREAT FIRST STEP AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROOM.
AND MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY VOTE EYES
[inaudible]
FORTY FIVE KNOWS.
TWENTY THAT MEASURE PARMI SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND WE
ARE FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINETY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN NINETY BY
SOME REMEMBER LEVINE ACTUALLY
THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES MISTER
LEVINE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RAW.
NUMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
WORK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY VOTE I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO IS AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN NINETY
ONE BY SOME A MEMBER LEVINE AND
ACCURATE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
MISTER LEVINE YOU MAKE AN OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS REMAINS SEEM NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
MARK WELL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
BETTER SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TALLY VOTE EYES SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE AB.
EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO BY MISTER
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
GREGORY.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND ATLANTA CAL FRESH
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY TWO FOR THE PURPOSES OF
CONCURRENCE.
AFTER RECEIVING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THIS BILL WAS
AMENDED IN THE SENATE TO DELETE
PORTIONS OF THE BILL THAT WOULD
MAKE.
WOULD HAVE MADE CHANGES TO THE
TRANSITIONAL CAL FRESH PROGRAM
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OUTSOURCING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
PURPLE OPEN ROLL-ON PARA VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TALBOT ICE FIFTY SIX
NO ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN [inaudible]
FILE ITEM. TWENTY FOUR IS AB
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHT BY SOME A MEMBER MCCARTY
AND OTHERS AND ACT UNDER
RESOURCES CONSERVATION.
MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU THIS IS A MEASURE TO
ALLOW THAT.
STATE CONSERVATION CORPS IN THE
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS TO
COORDINATE BETTER IN THEIR
PROGRAMMING.
HASN'T TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS BACK
FROM THE SENATE AND I ASK FOR
CONCURRENCE.
THEY RISK HURTING SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WELL
OPEN THE RIGHT.
ON MEMBERS.
THIS ARE THAT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TALLY I SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FOLLOWING TWENTY
FIVE IS A BE NINETEEN NINETY SIX
BY MISTER LACKEY CORKERY AT SOME
LEVEL NINETEEN NINETY SIX BY
SOME A MEMBER LACKEY AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY CANNABIS.
IF YOU'RE LUCKY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
NINETEEN NINETY SIX FOR
CONCURRENCE.
THIS BILL WILL GIVE
AUTHORIZATION TO THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS RESEARCH PROGRAM. TO
CONTINUE PERFORMING EFFECTIVE
RESEARCH AND UNDERTAKE
CULTIVATION METHODS.
APPROVED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THIS PROGRAM IS A PREMIER LEADER
IN THE FIELD OF CANNABIS STUDIES.
AND THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE
PROGRAM TO CONTINUE MAKING
STRIDES AND DISCOVERY INCLUDING
THE ABILITY TO TEST FOR DRUGS
DRIVING I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
NAMES LACKEY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CARP WILL OPEN
A UNDECIDED VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
THREE I SIXTY FOUR NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
WHILE I'M TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETEEN CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY PLANT TWENTY NINETEEN
BY SOME THE MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
AND I TRIED TO HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS.
MS AGUILAR CURRY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY NINETEEN IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS IS A
TRANSPARENCY.
AND ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS THE BILLS ON THE WORK
THAT WE STARTED LAST YEAR I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
CLUB LEVEL THE ROLE I'M TIRED OF
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY VOTE EYES.
FORTY FIVE KNOWS EIGHTEEN SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN IT'S AB TWENTY
TWENTY SIX BY MR LACKEY
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TWENTY SIX BY SOME A MEMBER
LACKEY AND ACTOR AND VEHICLE
SALES.
MISTER LACKEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY TWENTY SIX BACK ON CA
CURRENCY WAS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE TO PUSH OUT ITS OPERATIVE
DATE NOW RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
VOTE.
NAMES LACKEY SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
BUT LOCAL ROLL-ON THIS ARAB VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW I VOTE AYE
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT.
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY EIGHT AB TWENTY EIGHTY
SIX CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHTY SIX
BY SOME REMEMBER GALLAGHER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES [inaudible]
MISTER GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY EIGHTY SIX IS BACK
AFTER THE SENATE ON CONCURRENT
SAID IT WILL HELP PREVENT
FRAUDULENT PRESCRIPTIONS.
BYLINE PRESCRIBERS OF CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES TO REVIEW THEIR
PRESCRIBING HISTORY AND VERIFY
ACCURACY.
LAST YEAR I VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
QUIRK WELL OPEN THE ROLE.
OUR MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
WORK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE A. B..
TWENTY ONE FIFTEEN COOPERATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FIFTEEN
BY FAMILY MEMBERS SANTIAGO
ACTIVITY VEHICLES.
MISTER SANTIAGO THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS BILL --
IS BACK FROM SENATE AMENDMENTS
THE AMENDMENTS SIMPLY DELAYED
THE IMPLEMENTATION BY ONE YEAR.
EXPECT LAST NIGHT.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN RIGHT I'M
NERVOUS ARE VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE
[inaudible]
ERIC WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND FILE ITEM THIRTY
IS AB.
TWENTY ONE THIRTY TO CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE THIRTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO HOUSING.
MISS LEVINE.
THANK YOU MISTRESS TWO IT'S BACK
ON CURRENTS THIS BILL ALLOW
SENIORS WITH DISABILITIES TO GET
PERMITS TO MAKE YOUR HOME SAFER
FOR THEM --
TO HAVE THOSE FEES WAIVED BY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THE
AMENDMENTS ADDED MENTAL HEALTH
AS ONE OF THE DISABILITIES ALSO
ADDS A CO AUTHOR ASPIRIN AYE
VOTE.
THEY MISSED THE MAIN SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CORP WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON PARA VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE TALIBAN
AYE SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE IS AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FORTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER CABALLERO
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
MENTAL HEALTH.
CABALLERO THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY THREE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE BE AMENDMENTS WERE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON CONCURRENCE.
NAME IS COMEY ARSINOE DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
BURKE WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE WHAT I
SIXTY NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWOS AB TWENTY
ONE ANY.
FOR OPERATE AS SOME MIDDLE
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR BY SOME
THE MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND OTHERS
IN ATLANTA BUSINESS LICENSES.
MISTER CHIU EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FOUR TO CLARIFY INFORMATION
REQUIRED TO BE COLLECTED FOR
ISSUING BUSINESS LICENSES.
ARE CLARIFYING THAT FEDERAL TAX
ID NUMBERS CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S
LICENSES OR OTHER FORMS OF STATE
OR LOCAL ID'S CAN BE USED TO
APPLY FOR A BUSINESS LICENSE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS PROVIDED
PROTECTIONS TO KEEP RESIDENTIAL
ADDRESSES FROM DISCLOSURE WHICH
ALIGNS WITH CURRENT STATE LAW
THE BILL CONTINUES TO HAVE NO
OPPOSITION PASSED WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT HERE.
FAMOUS YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN.
AND MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE THOUGH
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE CALVET EYES FIFTY
TWO NO SEVEN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREES AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY FIVE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE NINETY
FIVE BY SOME A MEMBER CHAO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
GREENHOUSE GASES.
MR CHOW YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
FIVE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENT SIMPLY
RELOCATE THE BILL'S PROVISIONS
TO A MORE APPROPRIATE US CODE
SECTION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER SHALL SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORP WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
SARAH VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CULTURAL TIDE THAT ICE.
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS FIFTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
FILE ITEM.
THIRTY FOUR THIS AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY THREE CORPORATE.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY THREE FORTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND ACTUALLY THE REAL
PROPERTY.
MISTER CHAIR OF THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY THREE TO ADDRESS
IMBALANCES IN THE TENANT.
NOTICE IN EVICTION PROCESS BY
ENSURING --
THAT WE ARE NOT INCLUDING
WEEKENDS AND HOLIDAYS --
AS PART OF THE CALCULATION FOR
WHEN RESPONSES NEED TO BE MADE
DURING THE ELECTION PROCESS WE
MADE AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
THAT REMOVED OPPOSITION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
AS WELL AS A CALIFORNIA REALTORS
ARE AND WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THINGS YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CARP WELL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
PARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY OF A NICE
FORTY TWO KNOWS.
TWENTY TWO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IMPASSE RETAIN A FILE
ITEM.
THIRTY FIVE WHERE FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY SIX AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY NINE BY DR ARAMBULA QUIRK
WILL READ.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY FOUR NINETY
NINE BY SOME THE MEMBER ARAMBULA
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
DOCTOR REGULAR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS
TAKING IN THE SENATE.
ENSURE THAT THE BILL ONLY
CODIFIES OBAMA ERA REGULATIONS
ALONGSIDE OTHER AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TECHNICAL IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA SEEN
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM QUIRK WILL OPEN THE
RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF THE
CLERK WELL CLOSER ROLE TALLY
VOTE.
I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
[inaudible] SEVEN IS. FIVE OH
FOR CLERK WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY FIVE OH FOR BY
FAMILY MEMBER LOW AND ACTUALLY
TO PEACE OFFICER TRAINING.
MR LOW YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH PACIFIC REMEMBERS AB
TWENTY FIVE OH FORCED BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE.
AB MEMBERS TAKING THIS AND IT
WILL IMPROVE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE TRAININGS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE.
THINGS LOW SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON PARA
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I FIFTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT IS AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
FIVE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER O'DONNELL
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY NEED
ENGLISH LEARNERS.
MISTER O'DONNELL YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SENATE
AMENDMENTS TO AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY FIVE CLARIFY HOW THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS APPLY TO
NEWCOMER STUDENTS TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THEY MISTER DAHLE SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COURT WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY VOTE I SIXTY
FIVE KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE IS AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
BACK ON CONCURRENCE FROM THE
SENATE.
THE BILL REQUIRES HEALTHCARE
PRESCRIBERS TO OFFER A NET AND
THE LOCKS SOONER OTHER OPIOID
ANTAGONISE PRESCRIPTION TO A
PATIENT WHO WAS IDENTIFIED AT
RISK. FOR OVERDOSE ALSO REQUIRED
SUPERSPY YOUR PRESCRIBER TO
EDUCATE THE PATIENT AND OTHER
INDIVIDUALS DESIGNATED BY THE
PASTE ON THIS PURPOSE AND HOW TO
USE IT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULDSEEM NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE OUR MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE.
BOB WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN PASS RETAIN A
PILE AND FORTY ONE A PASS%
TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEM.
FORTY ONE PASS AND RETAIN.
OBSERVE MEMBERS WERE A JUMP TO
FILE ITEM.
FORTY THREE FILE ITEM.
FORTY THREE WE WILL TAKE UP THAT
IS AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY EIGHT
BY DOCTOR CHEN CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE TWENTY
EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBER CHEN AND
ACTUALLY TO HAZARDOUS WASTE.
DOCTOR CHEN EMAIL.
BUT YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY EIGHT IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE OF THE BILL TOOK
TECHNICAL CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
IN THE SENATE.
HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY NO VOTES
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT DON'T.
I THINK I CAN SEE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
QUIRK WELL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
OUR MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE.
TALLY THE HIGH SIXTY SEVEN OF
TWO SEVEN AMENDMENTS
[inaudible]
OUR CONCURRED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING AHEAD IN
FILE ORDER TO ITEM ONE FORTY
EIGHT HR ONE THIRTEEN MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE THIRTEEN BY
SOME A MEMBER RUBIO AND OTHERS
FELT IT IF HE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER RUBIO.
I NEED SOME QUIET.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
COLLEAGUE YOUR FULL ATTENTION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
[inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT HR.
ONE THIRTEEN KNOWN AS P. KEYS
RESOLUTION. FIVE YEAR OLD
PEEKING WAS A GIFTED AND LOVING
CHILD.
WITH A GREAT IMAGINATION.
HIS MOTHER.
I'M ESTEVEZ.
AND CHILD SAFETY ADVOCATES STAND
WITH US TODAY IN THE GALLERY
[inaudible]
PEEKING ENJOYED.
WALKING ALONG THE BEACH AT BOTH
AYE CHICA.
AND COLLECTING SEA TO SEA SHELLS.
HIS FAVORITE SONG.
WAS YOU ARE MY SUNSHINE.
HE LOVED WHEN.
WOULD READ TO HIM.
TOGETHER THEY WOULD ROLE PLAYING
THE CHARACTERS IN THE BOOKS.
IN HIS FEW YEARS.
HE LEFT BEHIND.
MEMORIES ARE OF OPENNESS AND
KINDNESS THAT WILL NEVER BE
FORGOTTEN.
IN APRIL OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN BIGGIE WAS MURDERED.
TODAY MY AUTHORS AND I JOIN ANA.
IN ASKING YOU. TO REMEMBER PEAKY.
NOT ONLY AND HOW HE LIVED.
BUT ON HOW HE DIED.
BECAUSE FELLOW MEMBERS THE
PERSON WHO COMMITTED THIS
HEINOUS ACT.
WAS SPEAKING FATHER FATHER.
YES HIS OWN FATHER.
DURING A LONG CUSTODIAL DISPUTE.
AFTER A DIVORCED TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
THE FAMILY COURT SYSTEM
REPEATEDLY REFUSED TO GIVE ANA
SOLE CUSTODY [inaudible]
DESPITE MOUNTING EVIDENCE THAT
PEAKY WAS IN DANGER.
I KNOW FOUGHT FOR HER SON.
BUT THE DOCUMENTED ABUSE WAS
IGNORED.
AND THEN DISMISSED.
THE SYSTEM FAILED THIS CHILD.
AND FRANKLY WE FAILED THIS CHILD.
AND HE'S NOT THE ONLY.
ONE SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
AT LEAST SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT CHILDREN IN THE U. S..
HAVE BEEN MURDERED.
BY A PARENT IN SIMILAR
CIRCUMSTANCES.
ACCORDING TO THE CENTER FOR
JUDICIAL EXCELLENCE.
ABUSIVE PARENTS ARE OFTEN
GRANTED CUSTODY.
OR I'M PROTECTING UNPROTECTED
PARENTING BY FAMILY COURTS.
AND MANY CORD RELATED CHILD
MURDERS OCCURRED AFTER
[inaudible]
FAMILY CHORDS GRANTED DANGEROUS
PARENTS ACCESS TO CHILDREN.
OVER THE OBJECTIONS OF A
PROTECTIVE PARENT.
EVEN OF CHILDREN SURVIVE A
CHILDHOOD FILLED WITH DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
WHETHER THEY ARE THE ONES
PHYSICALLY ABUSED OR NOT.
THEY CAN HAVE LONG LIFELONG
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS.
THIS INCLUDES ANXIETY.
AND DEPRESSION.
DIFFICULT IN RELATIONSHIPS
ACADEMIC EMPLOYMENT FAILURES AND
TROUBLE WITH THEIR OWN PARENTING.
THERE ARE ALSO MORE LIKELY TO
USE VIOLENCE THEMSELVES.
WITHOUT INTERVENTION AT AN EARLY
AGE THE CYCLE OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WILL CONTINUE
[inaudible]
TODAY.
MARKS THE ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY
THAT BEACUSE FATHER WAS
SENTENCED. TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO
LIFE [inaudible]
HE RECEIVED.
JUSTICE IN THIS LIFE.
AND HE WILL RECEIVE JUSTICE IN
THE NEXT [inaudible]
NOW.
WE ASK YOU TO STAND WITH US.
SO THAT OTHER CHILDREN RECEIVE
THE JUSTICE.
DEPT PEAKY NEVER DID.
LET'S PREVENT ANALYST TRAGEDY
FROM HAPPENING TO ANOTHER PARENT.
AS A MOTHER OF TWO OF TWO
WONDERFUL CHILDREN.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THE PAIN.
I WOULD GIVE MY LIFE. TO PROTECT
MY CHILDREN.
I KNOW THAT ALL MEMBERS IN THIS
CHAMBER WOULD DO THE SAME
[inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY WE CAN'T PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN FROM ALL HARM.
BUT TODAY WE CAN DO THIS.
I'M A HAS TURNED HER GRIEF.
INTO SEEKING JUSTICE. FOR
CHILDREN JUST LIKE PICKING.
LET US HONOR THIS POWERFUL
WOMAN'S.
COMMITMENT TO HER SON.
LET'S MAKE A CHILD SAFETY
[inaudible]
A PRIORITY.
OVER ALL.
OTHER CONSIDERATE CONSIDERATIONS
IN ANY CUSTODY OR VISITATION
DECISIONS.
LET'S REMEMBER PICKING.
AND THE CHILDREN WHO HAVE LOST
THEIR LIVES AT THE HANDS OF
UNFIT PARENTS.
AS THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
I THINK YOU.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
STRONG I VOTE FOR THIS
RESOLUTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE
THIRTEEN I THINK THE AUTHOR FROM
WEST COVINA FOR ONE HAVING THE
COURAGE TO BRING THIS RESOLUTION
BEFORE US.
I HAD THE DISTINCT HONOR.
OF MEETING THIS MOTHER WHO LOST
HER CHILD.
AND WHAT I THINK IS ONE OF THE
MOST HORRIFIC.
CASES I'VE HEARD.
AS A FORMER POLICE OFFICER.
AS A FATHER.
A FATHER WHO.
SON WAS KILLED AT THREE YEARS
OLD BY HIT AND RUN MOTORIST.
AND I HOPE THE LADY ROTS IN HELL.
I HAD HONORED TO MEET THIS
COURAGEOUS WOMAN WHO STANDS IN
THE ABOVE US.
WHO TOLD ME HER STORY
[inaudible]
VIEW [inaudible]
WEEKS AGO [inaudible]
IT'S HORRIFIC.
IT'S HORRIFIC. TO TO UNDERSTAND
OR TRIED TO ROB REMINDS AROUND
THE COURT SYSTEM PROFESSIONALS
[inaudible]
THAT.
HEARD HER PLEASE.
THAT THE FATHER WAS UNFIT TO
HAVE JOINT CUSTODY.
OF THEIR FIVE YEAR OLD SON.
BUT TO HAVE THIS MONTH
[inaudible]
THIS INDIVIDUAL.
TAKE THE SUN TO DISNEYLAND.
AND SPEND ENTIRE DAY.
AND THEN SUFFOCATE HIM IN THE
BACKSEAT.
OF THE CAR.
AND THEY DON'T HIS BODY.
I CANNOT FATHOM [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
HORRIFIC SITUATION.
IT PAINS ME.
THE COURT PROFESSIONALS
NEED BETTER TRAINING TO
RECOGNIZE THE SIGNS OF ABUSE.
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND HAD
THEY POSSIBLY.
HER SON WOULD NOT BE DEBT TODAY.
BUT I'M NOT WITH THE BLAME ON
THE PROFESSIONALS.
BECAUSE THIS BLAME [inaudible]
DIRECTLY.
FALLS ON HIS SHOULDERS
[inaudible]
FULLY.
AND AGAIN I HOPE HE ROTS NOW
IMPRISONED BUT ALSO INHALE.
AND WITH THAT.
I WOULD US STRONGLY*. FOR US
TO FINISH STRONG MESSAGE.
WITH AYE VOTE OR HOUSE
RESOLUTION.
ONE THIRTEEN THANK YOU SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE A
SOME NEVER RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE
AUTHORS [inaudible]
YES PLEASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
FOR THIS RULES FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THIS RULES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
BUT A PERKY MAY CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE SIXTY NINE CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED IS A MEMBER RUBIO
RETURNING TO YOU FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT VOTE AND I
WANT TO INTRODUCE YOU TO ON A AS
THAT AS THE MOTHER OF PEAKY.
THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR BEING HERE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING OUT OF
FILE ORDER TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
FOUR AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RATE
IS ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAISE
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THE MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT COUNTIES
OFFERING INTERNSHIP IN STUDENT
SYSTEM POSITIONS DEVELOP A
HIRING PATHWAY PROGRAM FOR
DISADVANTAGED GROUPS.
THIS IS CURRENTLY BEING DONE AT
THE STATE LEVEL WOULD MIRROR THE
EFFORTS THE COUNTY LEVEL.
SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THAT
NOTHING IN THIS BILL SHALL
CREATE A RIGHT THREE PERMANENT
CIVIL SERVICE POSITION.
EXPERIENCE PROVIDED BY
INTERNSHIPS AND STUDENT
ASSISTANT POSITIONS IS
INVALUABLE ESPECIALLY FOR
DISADVANTAGED YOUTH FACING.
MANY BARRIERS ARE RESPECTFULLY
ASK THREE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM QUICKIE MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELLING THE VOTES FORTY FOUR
EYES. TO KNOWS THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCORDANT.
WE ARE MOVING BACK AND FILE
ORDER.
ITEM FORTY FIVE PASS TEMPORARILY
MOVING TO ITEM FORTY SIX AB
THIRTY EIGHTY SIX MADAME QUICKLY
STREET ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
EIGHTY SIX BY SOME REMEMBER
KILEY TACKLING THE PEOPLE
ATTENDANCE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KILEY YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AB
THIRTY EIGHTS EIGHTY SIX IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE BECAUSE OF
CHAPTER RING OUT AMENDMENTS ARE
THE BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY NO
VOTES.
I ASK YOUR THANK YOU SEEING
THEIR REQUEST TO SPEAK METAPHOR
QUIZ OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
BUT A QUICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM FORTY SEVEN AB
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO AND
ACTUALLY THE SOLID WASTE.
THANK YOU A SUMMER RUBIO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT RELATED
TO WASTE DIVERSION REQUIREMENTS.
EARLIER THIS YEAR CHINA IMPOSED
NEW STRICT POLICIES LIMITING
RECYCLABLE IMPORTS AND PLACING
OUTRIGHT BANS ON MAKES PAPER AND
VARIOUS PLASTICS.
THIS HAS RAISED GREAT CONCERNS
BECAUSE CHINA HAD BEEN THE
LARGEST WORLD MARKET FOR MANY OF
OUR RECYCLABLE PRODUCTS.
SOMETHING THE CALIFORNIA LAW DID
NOT ANTICIPATE AND THAT
CURRENTLY DOES NOT ACCOUNT.
FOR THIS BILL MAKES FINDINGS AND
DECLARATIONS REGARDING CHINA'S
NATIONAL SOARED.
IT ALSO TAKES THE ABSENCE OF
AVAILABLE MARKETS INTO ACCOUNT
BY ESTABLISHING TEMPORARY
MEASURES TO ADDRESS
UNPREDICTABLE AN UNSTABLE WORLD
MARKETS FOR OUR MATERIALS.
AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE WITH
UNANIMOUS UNANIMOUS SUPPORT N
BOTH HOUSES.
ENJOYING SUPPORT FROM CITIES
COUNTIES AND BUSINESSES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THIS BILL WILL LET US CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION TO IDENTIFY NEW
RESILIENT RECYCLING DOMESTIC
MARKETS.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU SING THEIR REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM PARK IS OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULE AND TELL YOU THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB
THIRTY TO ELEVEN MATTER HER
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
TO ELEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER
KALRA AND AFTER THE HEALTH CARE
DECISIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SENATE AMENDMENTS TO AB THIRTY
TO ELEVEN REVISED THE ADVANCE
HEALTH CARE DIRECTIVE MODEL FORM
AND REFLECT INPUT FROM PROBATE
AND ESTATE LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
TAX COM.
SPECIFICALLY THE AMENDMENT
RESTORE THE OPS TO SPECIFY THE
USE OF THE DONATION AND CROSS
REFERENCE THE SECTION.
FOR A PRINCIPAL TO PLACE
LIMITATIONS ON THEIR AUTHORIZED
AGENT.
ADDITIONALLY LANGUAGE IN THE
FORM BETTER ACCOUNTS FOR
SITUATIONS WHERE PRINCIPLE NOT
MAKING A CHOICE AT THIS TIME AND
MAKE A NUMBER.
OF TECHNICAL CHANGES WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THEM NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE METAPHOR
PLEASE OPEN AROUND.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM FORTY NINE AB
THIRTY TO FIFTY EIGHT MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TO FIFTY EIGHT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING ACT UNTIL
ELECTIONS.
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER BERMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB THIRTY TO FIFTY
EIGHT IS ONE OF THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEES ANNUAL OMNIBUS BILLS
CONTAINING A NUMBER OF MINOR AND
NON CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES TO THE
ELECTIONS CODE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS RESOLVE
DISCREPANCY IN STATE LAW
REGARDING THE TIME ONE FOR
CANDIDATES CANDIDATES AT A
SPECIAL VACANCY ELECTION TALK TO
COLLECT SIGNATURES ON PETITIONS
IN LIEU.
OF PAYING A FILING FEE AND A AND
ADDED LANGUAGE TO AVOID CHAPTER
AND PROBLEMS WITH OTHER BILLS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAME PARK WAS OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOW MEMBERS BOTH THE DESIRE TO
VOTE?
HOW MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE?
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES ICE FIFTY
TWO NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCRETE IN.
ITEM FIFTY AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIXTY ONE BY SOME
MEMBER FRAZIER AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO VEHICLES
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MEDSPEAK
REMEMBERS.
AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE IS BACK HOME
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ADDED.
INTENT LANGUAGE AND BRINGS THE
BILL IN LINE WITH CHANGES
CURRENTLY BEING.
CONSIDERED BY THE CONGRESS.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK
MATTER QUICKLY IS OPEN THE ROOM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
BUT A QUICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY TWO NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
ITEM FIFTY ONE PASS AND RETAIN
MOVING TO ITEM FIFTY TWO AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN MADAM
QUICKLY THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN BY
FAMILY MEMBER MCCARTY AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS IS
ONE OF THE BILLS WE HAVE THIS
YEAR DEALING WITH THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC.
IT'S TOO LATE TO POSITION
TRAINING AND HELPING ENSURE THAT
OUR DOCTORS AND PHYSICIANS HAVE --
AMPLE OPPORTUNITY TO DEAL WITH --
OPPORTUNITIES TO SERVE OPIOID
ADDICTS AND GET THEM IN
TREATMENT --
WHEN THIS BILL LEFT THE ASSEMBLY
WE HAD SOME CONCERNS FROM THE
OUR DOCTORS WEALTH CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION PLEASED TO
NOTE WITH THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE?
ITS WE ARE CONCURRING ON TODAY
WE HAVE REMOVED THE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITH SOME MEMBER
WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ARE RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL --
DESPITE INCREASING SUCCESS OF
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENTS
FOR OPIOID ABUSE LESS THAN 2% OF
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL PROVIDERS A
CERTIFIED. TO PRESCRIBE PROVEN
OFFER IN AN THE LOCKS ON
TREATMENT AND EVEN LESS TO
ADMINISTER NALTREXONE.
ESPECIALLY ITS PIVOTAL IN RURAL
AREAS THIS BILL WILL HELP --
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF PROVIDERS
WHO ARE TRAINED AYE URGENT AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY DO YOU WISH TO
CLOSE.
HE DOES NOT MADAM CLERK YOU MAY
OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED AND
ITEM FIFTY THREE IS AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY FOUR MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FORTY
FOUR BY SOME A MEMBER LACKEY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE VEHICLES
DECLARED THEIR AND SEE THEIR UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY THANK
YOU SO MEMBER LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY FOURS BACK ON
CA COURAGE.
ONCE AGAIN IT'S A CLEAN UP
MEASURE TO LAST YEAR'S AB FIVE
ALL THREE WHICH ESTABLISHED A
PAYMENT PROGRAM FOR LOW INCOME
DRIVERS TO ACQUIRE PARKING
TICKETS.
THE BIPARTISAN MEASURE THAT
RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES ON THE
FLOOR AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN THAT NO FOR THE
REQUEST TO SPEAK MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM QUIRKY MAKE CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY
EYES FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
ITEM FIFTY FIVE PASS TEMPORARILY
MOVING TO ITEM FIFTY SIX AB.
TWENTY NINE TWENTY MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ SOME LEGAL TWENTY
NINE TWENTY BY SOME A MEMBER
THURMOND ACTUALLY TO TAXATION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SIGH RICE PRESENT AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY FOR
CONCURRENCE.
THIS IS IN FACT ADDITION BUILT
UP THAT ALLOWS --
WHEN MY CITIES IN THE CITY OF MY
COLLEAGUE?
REPRESENTS PLASTER COUNTY --
TO PUT BEFORE THEIR VOTERS
WHETHER NOT THEY WISH TO
INCREASE LOCAL TAXES. TO PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR THE HOMELESS AND TO
IMPROVE TRANSPORTATION MEASURES
THIS BILL DOES THIS BILL DOES
NOT.
INCREASE TAXES IT SIMPLY GIVES.
THE RIGHT TO PUT THE QUESTION
BEFORE THEM WHETHER OR NOT TO
INCREASE I TAXES FOR SERVICES
THAT ARE DESPERATELY NEEDED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING FACT.
IN FILE ORDER TO ITEM FORTY FIVE
A. B. HIRTY FORTY SEVEN MADAM
QUICKLY THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY FORTY SEVEN BY SOME THE
MEMBER DALY AND OTHERS AND I
PLAN TO COURT FEES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAILY
OR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS THIS BILL PROVIDES A FEE
WAIVER FOR OUT OF STATE TRIBAL
ATTORNEYS.
DURING CHILD CUSTODY PROCEEDINGS
UNDER THE INDIAN CHILD WELFARE
ACT.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
AND NON SUBSTANTIVE.
THE BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK METAPHOR PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS NO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
I DON'T THINK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY THREE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCLUDED.
MOVING BACK IN FILE ORDER TO
ITEM FIFTY FIVE A. B. FOR FORTY
EIGHT MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FORTY EIGHT
BY SOME THE NUMBER DALY ACTUALLY
JOINT POWERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAILY ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL AUTHORIZES THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE IN THE THIRTY
FOUR CITIES WITHIN THE COUNTY.
A FORMER JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY.
THE SOLE PURPOSE OF THE NEW JPA
WHICH WOULD BE KNOWN AS THE
ORANGE COUNTY HOUSING FINANCE
TRUST.
WILL BE TO FUND THE PLANNING AND
CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING FOR THE
HOMELESS AND LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES THE TRUST
TO RECEIVE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
FINANCING.
AS WELL AS TO ISSUE BONDS
CERTIFICATES OF PARTICIPATION OR
OTHER DEBT INSTRUMENTS.
THE PRIMARY OBJECTIVE OF THE
TRUST WILL BE TO INCREASE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING UNITS.
WHICH PROVIDE HOUSING STABILITY
FOR THEIR RESIDENTS ALONG WITH
WRAPAROUND SERVICES INCLUDING
MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND ADDICTION
TREATMENT.
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES OF ORANGE COUNTY.
SPONSOR OF THE BILL HAS PRODUCED
A DETAILED PLAN FOR CREATING.
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING UNITS
[inaudible]
CROSS.
GEOGRAPHY OF ORANGE COUNTY.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU IT'S A MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AS A PROUD JOINT AUTHOR
OF AB FOUR FOUR EIGHT I ALSO
REGRET REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT ON
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE TALKED MANY MANY
TIMES ON THIS FLOOR AND IN
COMMITTEE ABOUT.
THOSE SUFFERING FROM
HOMELESSNESS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
NOT ONLY WHAT WE CAN DO ABOUT IT
BUT ACTIONS THAT NEED TO BE.
MADE AND THIS BILL WILL DO
EXACTLY THAT A. B. FOR FOR FOR A
IS A COLLABORATIVE APPROACH TO
COMBATING HOMELESSNESS.
WITH THIS APPROVAL AS IT MOVES A
FORWARD TO LOOK TOWARDS THE
FUTURE IN ORANGE COUNTY OF
BUILDING TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
UNITS TO FOR OF PERMANENT
HOUSING WILL PUT PEOPLE ON THE
TRACK.
NOT ONLY FOR HOUSING BUT TO TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO
RECEIVE JOBS AND TO CONTRIBUTE
BACK TO OUR SOCIETY SO I AM
PROUD TO STAND WITH THE MEMBER
FROM.
FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU SCENE NO FOR THE
REQUEST TO SPEAK MADAM CLERK YOU
MAY OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
NO MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES ICE FIFTY
TWO NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
ITEM FORTY ONE EIGHTY TWO EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY HALL TO EIGHT EIGHT
FOUR BY THREE MEMBER IRWIN AND
ACTUALLY DO REAL ESTATE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWO EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR UPDATES THE REALISTIC
COATED IS BACK ON CURRENTS AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS LAST FOR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY THREE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE FROM HEARD IN.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LOOK
FOR CALLING ITEM FIFTY SIX AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY MADAM CLERK
PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE HE DESIRED TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MADAM PARKING MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS
FORTY ONE AT NO TWENTY FIVE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN
. THREE SB.
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN MEDICARE
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR HILL AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE HEALTH.
THANK YOU A SUMMER MOWING YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN WILL
HELP STUDENTS WITH SEVERE
MEDICAL DISABILITIES ATTEND
SCHOOL.
THE ONLY MEDICATION THAT WORKS
FOR SOME OF THE STUDENTS AS
MEDICAL CANNABIS.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW PARENT OR
GUARDIAN TO COME ON CAMPUS TO
ADMINISTER MEDICAL CANNABIS TO
THEIR CHILD IN A NON SMOKING AND
NON IN NON VAPING FORMS.
MANY OF THE STUDENTS NEED TO
TAKE A DOSE OF MEDICAL CANNABIS
AT REGULAR INTERVALS WHICH OFTEN
INCLUDES DURING SCHOOL HOURS
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT ALLOW ANY
FORM OF CANNABIS ON SCHOOL
GROUNDS.
THE STUDENTS MUST BE PICKED UP
BY THE PARENTS AND TAKING OFF
CAMPUS IN ORDER TO TAKE THEIR
MEDICINE IS A VERY DISRUPTIVE TO
THEIR LEARNING.
SP ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN WILL
ALLOW THE GOVERNING BOARD OF THE
K. TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICT COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION OR CHARTER
SCHOOL.
CHOOSE WHETHER TO ADOPT THIS
POLICY IS NOT A STATE MANDATE.
DISTRICTS AND COUNTIES THAT
OFTEN CAN OPT OUT FOR ANY REASON
INCLUDING A FEDERAL FUNDING IS
PUT AT RISK AS A RESULT OF THE
POLICY. ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
REQUIRES THESTUDENT TO BE A
QUALIFIED MEDICAL CANNABIS
PATIENT WITH A DOCTOR'S
RECOMMENDATION TYPICALLY THE
MEDICINE THAT IS ADMINISTERED AS
OIL.
CAPSULES TINCTURES LIQUIDS OR
TOPICAL CREAMS THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THAT A PARENT MUST GIVE
GIVE THE CHILD A COPY OF THEIR
CHILD'S MEDICAL CANNABIS
RECOMMENDATION TO KEEP ON FILE.
SIGN IN WHEN THEY COME ON CAMPUS
TO ADMINISTER THE MEDICINE NOT
DISRUPT THE EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT AND TAKE ALL
CANNABIS FROM SCHOOL GROUNDS
AFTER ADMINISTRATION A HOST OF
STATES.
HAVE THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK METAPHORICALLY SOAP
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
?
MISTER MULLIN MOVES THE CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM
ONE EIGHTY NINE SP SEVEN FIFTY
NINE MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND OTHERS IN
ATLANTA ELECTIONS DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
A STRONG DEMOCRACY DEPENDS ON A
VOTERS BELIEVE THAT HIS OR HER
BALLOT COUNTS HOWEVER IN
CALIFORNIA ACCORDING TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE.
OVER TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
BALLOTS WERE THROWN OUT IN THE
NOVEMBER GENERAL ELECTION
BECAUSE OF A MISMATCHING
SIGNATURE THAT WAS NOVEMBER.
TWENTY SIXTEEN IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
I AUTHORED AB FOR SEVENTY SEVEN
WHICH ALLOWS EIGHT DAYS TO
CORRECT THE BALLOT WITHOUT A
SIGNATURE.
HOWEVER THERE ARE STILL NO
GUARANTEE THAT A COUNTY GIVES
THE VOTER THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CORRECT A MISMATCHING SIGNATURE.
S. B. SEVEN FIFTY NINE CREATES A
PROCESS FOR LOCAL ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO NOTIFY VOTERS
WHETHER VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS
SIGNATURE MIS MATCHES THE ONE ON
FILE.
IT ALSO GUARANTEES THOSE VOTERS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT THE
MISMATCH SO THAT THEIR VOTES CAN
BE COUNTED.
THERE ARE MANY REASONS A BALLOT
MAY HAVE A MISMATCH SIGNATURE.
IT COULD BE BECAUSE OF OUR AS A
DISABILITY.
A PERSON SIGNATURE CHANGED OVER
TIME SOMEONE MISUNDERSTOOD AND
SIGNED IN NON ENGLISH CHARACTERS
OR DIFFERENT MEMBER OF THE
HOUSEHOLD SUCH AS A SPOUSE OR A
CARETAKER.
SIGN THE BALLOT.
AS THE USE OF VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS INCREASES IN CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY AS THE VOTERS CHOICE
ACT AS IMPLEMENTED IN MULTIPLE
COUNTIES WE CANNOT IGNORE THIS
ISSUE ANY LONGER.
TODAY OVER HALF OF CALIFORNIANS
WILL BY MAIL AND SOME COUNTIES
CONDUCTED TIRE ELECTIONS BY MAIL.
MEMBERS IT'S UP TO US TO KEEP
DEMOCRACY STRONG AND PASS SB
SEVEN FIFTY NINE I AS FOR NIGHT
THOUGH.
THANK YOU SEEN OF I'M SORRY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ELECTION EXPERTS
AGREED THAT VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS
ARE THE MOST SUSCEPTIBLE TO
FRAUD AND ELECTION.
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO TURN IN A
COPY OF A VOTER SIGNATURE UP TO
TWENTY EIGHT DAYS.
NOT SEVEN DAYS TWENTY EIGHT DAYS
AFTER AN ELECTION WILL
EXACERBATE THE PROBLEM.
SINCE A SIGNATURE CAN BE
RETURNED TO THE REGISTRAR VIA
FAX OR EMAIL THIS WOULD ALLOW
ANYONE TO WORK IN VARIOUS WAYS
AND EITHER PHOTOSHOP A SIGNATURE.
OR COPY THE SIGNATURE FROM SOME
OTHER SOURCE EVEN JUST
DOWNLOADING IT FROM THE INTERNET.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL HAS BEEN
AMENDED TO BEGIN THE PROCESS.
IN THIS YEAR'S ELECTION.
NOT THE NEXT SESSION BUT THIS
YEAR'S ELECTION.
CHANGING THE RULES MID PROCESS
LET ME UNDERSCORE.
VOTING FOR THIS BILL WOULD
CHANGE THE RULES OF MID PROCESS
DURING THIS ELECTION.
WE WILL NOT HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TEST THAT BEFORE THE OFFICIAL
ELECTION AND WITH AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR MORE VOTER FRAUD IN THIS
YEAR'S ELECTION WITH BALLOT
HARVESTING.
WE SHOULD WORK TO RESTORE
INTEGRITY IN OUR ELECTION SYSTEM
NOT DESTROY IT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT.
OF SB. SEVEN FIFTY NINE SEVEN
FIFTY NINE ALLOWS A VOTER WHO
SIGNATURE ON HIS OR HER VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT.
IDENTIFICATION ENVELOPE DOES NOT
MATCH THAT SIGNATURE ON FILE IN
THE VOTERS RECORD YOUR ATTORNEY
COMPLETED SIGNATURE VERIFICATION
STATEMENT IN ORDER TO HAVE HIS
OR HER BALLOT COUNTED.
SIGNATURE ISSUES SUCH AS MISSING
SIGNATURES AND MISMATCHING
SIGNATURES ARE ONE OF THE TOP
REASONS WHY VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS
DO NOT GET COUNTED.
WHILE MANY STATESHAVE TAKEN
STEPS TO DENY PEOPLE THE RIGHT
TO VOTE WERE FORTUNATE THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A LEADING
VOICE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
RESIDENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
AND HAVE THEIR VOTE COUNTED NOW
WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT ELECTION
FRAUD AND OTHERS CAN BE FRAUD IN
THIS KIND OF SYSTEM BUT LET'S BE
CLEAR WOULD HAVE TO HAPPEN
SOMEBODY WHO WANTED TO
FRAUDULENTLY INFLUENCE ELECTION.
WOULD HAVE TO YOU --
INTER INTERVIEW I INTERVENE
CAPTURE COMMUNICATION FROM A
REGISTRAR VOTER.
TAKE THAT BEFORE IT GETS THE
VOTER TELLING THEM THEIR
SIGNATURE IS INCORRECT.
USE THAT INFORMATION DON'T GET A
COPY OF THE PERSON SIGNATURE PDF
IT SCANNED IT BACK SEND IT BACK
TO THE REGISTER VOTER ALL FOR
ONE VOTE.
NOW WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT THIS RED
HEARING THE VOTER FRAUD BUT WE
KNOW THAT THE ONLY PEOPLE TO
INFLUENCE ELECTIONS LATELY.
I HAVE BEEN FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS
LIKE RUSSIA AND VLADIMIR PUTIN
AND THEY FOUND WAY SMARTER WAYS
INTERFERE ELECTIONS EARNED IT TO
INTERVENE IN ELECTIONS THAN THIS
DON'T GET DISTRACTED BY RED
HEARINGS.
WELL THIS IS A GOOD BILL THAT
WILL SIMPLY ENSURE THAT ALL
VOTERS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CURE A MISMATCH SIGNATURE IN
ORDER TO HAVE THEIR VOTES
COUNTED I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ALL DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE HAVING CEASED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM.
SPEAKER I'M INCLINED TO TAKE THE
ELECTIONS SHARES COMMENTS OFF
FROM MY CLOTHES LET ME JUST ADD
THAT THIS PROCESS THAT WE ARE
ESTABLISHING SIMPLY SYNCS UP THE
EXISTING PROCESS FOR MISSING
SIGNATURES THERE'S CONSISTENCY.
ARE IN THIS POLICY THIS IS ABOUT
INCLUSION THESE ARE VOTES THAT
THE VOTER ABSOLUTELY ARE
INTENDED TO CAST WE JUST HAVE TO
DEAL WE HAVE TO DIG IT ON THIS
ISSUE OF THIS BASS MET
MISMATCHING SIGNATURES HAS A
SEAT MOVED TO VOTE BY MAIL.
AND I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM COURT PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEMBERS THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR
VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MISTER MULLIN REQUEST THAT WE
MOVE THE CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY SIX S. B..
TWO FIFTEEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE MULTI THIRTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDING SP.
TWO ONE FIVE S. B. TWO ONE FIVE
ADDS VISION VICTIM RESTITUTION
TO THE MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION
PROGRAM THAT WAS CREATED BY A.
B.. EIGHTEEN TEN THESE
AMENDMENTS MODIFIED THE EXISTING
DIVERSION PROGRAM AND TO
ADDITIONAL WAYS THEY RESTRICT
THE ELIGIBLE OFFENSES SO THAT IT
THAT DIVERGENT CANNOT BE
CONSIDERED IN CASES.
INVOLVING MURDER VOLUNTARY
MANSLAUGHTER RAPE AND OR SEX
CRIMES THE MEMBERS ALSO
AUTHORIZED TO QUIRK TO REQUIRE A
PRIME APHASIA SHOWING THAT THE
DEFENDANT WILL MEET.
THE MINIMUM ELIGIBLE
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT THE
DEFENDANT AND THE OFFENSE OF
SUITABLE FOR DIVERSION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
NUMBER CLOSE THE ROLE MAY CLOSE
THE ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY ONE
EYES NO ZERO THE SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN
. FOR TWENTY ONE TEN
FIFTY FOUR MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SEVERAL TEN FIFTY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA.
THANK YOU SOME NEVER BONTA
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY AS A JOINT AUTHOR OF
SP TEN FIFTY FOR A FOLLOW UP
BILL. TO OUR MOMENTOUS VOTE ON
MONDAY THIS WEEK TO REFORM
CALIFORNIA'S PRE TRIAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
THIS BILL AMENDS SP TEN SO THAT
ANY OFFENSE LISTED UNDER SECTION
TWO NINETY WOULD NOW REQUIRE A
DEFENDANT TO GO BEFORE A JUDGE
EVEN IF IT IS A NON SERIOUS ARE
NON VIOLENT SEX OFFENSE.
AND ONLY AT ARRAIGNMENT WITH
THIS GROUP OF DEFENDANTS BE
ASSESSED FOR THE PUBLIC SAFETY
AND FIGHT RISKS AND FOR RELEASE
CONDITIONS. TO BE CONSIDERED.
THIS BILL ALSO PERMITS THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO TO
PHASE IN THE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS OF S. B. TEN WITHIN A
FIVE YEAR WINDOW OR LESS.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THINK
.
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE EYES PASS THE AYES HAVE IT
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
THAT THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT IN BACK
ON FILE.
MEMBERS THERE ARE BILLS ON CALL
I AM LIFTING THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY THREE SB ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE SB
SEVEN FIFTY NINE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
?
BUT A QUICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE.
EYES FORTY FOUR KNOWS TWENTY ONE
THE MEASURE FAILS MISTER MULLIN.
REQUEST RECONSIDERATION.
I AM LIFTING THE CALL ON ITEM
ONE SEVENTY THREE ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
NOT A QUICKIE MAKE CLOTHES THE
ROLL EYES THIRTY THREE NO TWENTY
THE MEASURE FAILS.
MISTER MULLIN NOTICES
RECONSIDERATION
.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I
AM RE REFERRING THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
ITEM SEVENTY SIX A. B. FIFTEEN
TWENTY NINE BY THURMAN TO
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS.
ITEM NINETY SEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY TWO BY A YEAR CURRY TO
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION ITEM
ONE HUNDRED AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY THREE GRAYSON TO HELP.
ITEM ONE OH FOR AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY SIX BY RODRIGUEZ TO
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT AND
SOCIAL SECURITY.
ITEM ONE THIRTEEN A. B. THIRTY
TO THIRTY ONE BY GREAT TO LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT.
ITEM ONE FIFTEEN A. B. EIGHT
EIGHTY FIVE GREATER GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION.
ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE A. B. TWO
THOUSAND BY KARL ROVE TO
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO M.
RE REFERRING THE FOLLOWING BILLS
TO COMMITTEE.
ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE S. B. FIVE
NINETEEN BY BILL TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE ITEM TO
SIXTY SEVEN S. B. FIVE OH TO
PORTANTINO TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE.
ITEM THREE QUARTER THREE FORTY
S. B. FOR SIXTY FIVE JACKSON TO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
WE ARE NOW MOVING TO THE CONSENT
FILE DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL NINE NINETY TWO BY
SENATOR HERNANDEZ AND OTHERS AND
I THINK THE ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN
THE ROLE.
AND FOUNDER ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS WHO.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY FIVE KNOWS.
ZERO THE REMAINDER OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WILL BE
DEFERRED TO TO THE END OF
SESSION.
MEMBERSTHE FOLLOWING COMMITTEES
WILL BE MEETING UPON A GERMAN IN
SESSION PRIVACY IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY SIX PUBLIC SAFETY IN ROOM
ONE TWENTY SEVEN TRANSPORTATION
AND ROOM.
FOR THIRTY SEVEN THE SESSION
SCHEDULED FEDERAL IS AS FOLLOWS.
FRIDAY AUGUST TWENTY FOURTH
FLOOR SESSION AT NINE AM MONDAY
AUGUST TWENTY SEVENTH.
FLOOR SESSION FROM ONE PM TO SIX
PM
.
THEIR MAJOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THE CLERK WILL READ.
CYNICAL.
TEN THIRTY FOUR I FIFTY FIVE
KNOWS NINE CYNICAL TEN FORTY SIX
I. FIFTY FIVE KNOWS.
NINE CYNICAL TWELVE FORTY EIGHT
I CITY FIVE KNOWS NINE CYNICAL
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR I CITY FIVE
KNOWS NONE SENATE BILLS WELL
SIXTY ONE I CITY FIVE KNOWS NINE
CYNICAL TWELVE SIXTY TWO I SIXTY
FIVE KNOWS NONE SIMPLE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SIX I CITY FIVE NO NINE
SIMPLE.
FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE I CITY FIVE
KNOWS NO SIMPLE FOURTEEN NINETY
FOUR I CITY FIVE KNOWS XENICAL
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE I CITY FIVE
KNOWS NO SENATE CONCURRENT
VERSION.
EIGHTY SEVEN I FIFTY FIVE KNOWS
NINE SENATE COMPARISON ONE FIFTY
SIX ISAAC DIED KNOWS NONE SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY
ONE HIGHS FIFTY FIVE KNOWS NINE
SENATE CONCURRENT WISHING EIGHTY
THREE I CITY FIVE KNOWS IT NOW
SENATE CONCURRENT WISHING NINETY
NINE I CITY FIVE KNOWS. NINE
SENATE THINKER RESOLUTION WHEN I
WON I STEEP DIVE KNOWS.
NINE IT COULD TAKE COUNTER IS
COMPLETED.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THAT
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY I DOUBTS
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENT AND MEMORY.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST MEMBERS TO
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR OR TAKE YOUR SEATS.
WILL MOVE TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
MISTER CASA YOUR RECOGNIZE AT
YOUR DESK FOR YOUR FIRST
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY.
OF MAJOR STEPHEN DEL BONIOR WHO
PASSED AWAY EARLIER THIS YEAR AT
THE YOUNG AGE OF THIRTY FOUR
MAJOR DOT BAGNO IS PRACTICING
ROUTINE TRAINING MANEUVERS IN
HIS F. IF F. SIXTEEN FIGHTING
FALCON WHEN IT CRASHED.
IN THE NEVADA TEST AND TRAINING
RANGE.
MAJOR STEVEN UP ON YOUR WAS A
SLOT PILOT FOR THE U. S. AIR
FORCE AIR DEMONSTRATION SQUADRON
FLYING THE NUMBER FOUR JET.
ALSO KNOWN AS THE THUNDERBIRDS.
HE GREW UP IN SANTA CLARITA
CALIFORNIA ATTENDED CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE FOR TWO
YEAR STUDY POLITICAL SCIENCE HE
GRADUATED FROM UTAH STATE
UNIVERSITY.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE TWO
YEARS LATER HE WAS COMMISSION
FROM OFFICER TRAINING SCHOOL
MAXWELL AIRFORCE BASE IN ALABAMA.
BEFORE JOINING THE AIRFORCE.
MAJOR DOT BOMB YOU WAS A
CIVILIAN FLIGHT STRUCTURE
INSTRUCTOR CORPORATE PILOT
SKYRIDER AND A BANNER TOW PILOT.
PRIOR TO JOINING THE
THUNDERBIRDS DABABNEH SERVED AS
IT F. THIRTY FIVE A. EVALUATE
APART PILOT [inaudible]
AND CHIEF.
OF STANDARDIZATION EVALUATION
FIFTY EIGHTH FIGHTER SQUADRON
ELK ELGIN AIR FORCE BASE FLORIDA.
HIS FORMER EMPLOYER WAYNE
MANSFIELD ONCE SAID THAT --
HE WAS AN OFFICER GENTLEMAN AND
FANTASTIC PILOT.
STEVEN HEARD EVERYTHING HE'S
GOTTEN THROUGH HARD WORK
DISCIPLINE AND FOCUS A GREAT
EXAMPLE FOR OTHERS TO FOLLOW.
IN AN INTERVIEW WITH ALABAMA TV
STATION W. E. A. R. MAJOR THE
BOND YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW MUCH
HE ENJOYED IN YOUR SHOWS AND
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE ESPECIALLY
KIDS.
WHO HOPE TO BECOME A PILOT
SOMEDAY?
HE WENT ON TO SAY QUOTE THE
BIGGEST THING I LEARNED
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER AND WHAT I
TELL ALL OF THE KIDS WHEN I
START TALKING TO THEM IS IN LIFE
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR A LOT OF
KNOWS.
AND SOMETIMES IT'S JUST A TEST
OF YOUR RESOLVE AND QUOTE.
I NEVER GOT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET --
MAJOR DAHLE BAGNO --
BUT HE'S TWO DOORS AWAY FROM
ANOTHER GOLD STAR FAMILY IN
SANTA CLARITA HE'S ACROSS THE
STREET FROM A HIGH SCHOOL FRIEND
OF MINE.
AND WHEN I WENT TO THE VIGIL ON
IN HIS NEIGHBORHOOD.
BOB I WAS ABSOLUTELY MOVED BY
ALL OF THE OUTPOURING BUT THE
STORIES ABOUT THIS YOUNG MAN AND
HOW.
HERE HE WAS AN ACCOMPLISHED
THUNDERBIRD PILOT AND OVER THE
EASTER REAK HE CAME HOME AND
SAT IN THE LIVING ROOMS OF HIS
NEIGHBORS HE CHECKED IN ON ALL
OF THIS NEIGHBORHOOD --
IS NEIGHBORHOOD AND NEIGHBORS AS
HE GREW UP --
AND AND SEE TO SEE HOW THEY WERE
AND IT JUST GOES TO TO SHOW YOU
THAT THAT THIS YOUNG MAN'S
CAREER WAS IT WAS IT WAS ANOTHER
STEPPING STONE IN HIS LIFE IN
TERMS OF HIS PUBLIC SERVICE HE
NEVER QUITE GET GIVING BACK AND
IT WAS ALWAYS AN ENCOURAGEMENT.
TO THOSE AROUND THEM.
AND I'VE GOT THE NOSE PARENTS
THEY'RE WONDERFUL PEOPLE AS HIS
SISTERS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN TODAY'S SESSION IN
MEMORY OF MAJOR STEPHEN DEL
BAGNO THANK YOU.
THEY GIVE US R. COSTA YOU MAY
PERCEIVE YOUR SECOND GERMAN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER HON
MEMBER SOME [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
I WASN'T SURE WHERE TO PUT THIS
PEACE BUT FOR THIS NEXT
ADJOURNMENT FOR MY GERMAN MEMORY --
BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE FAMILY
RIGHT THAT WE ARE ARE BORN INTO
IN THAT COME INTO OUR LIVES
THEIR MARRIAGE.
BUT I AM GOING TO ADJOURN AND
MEMORY OF JOAN M. HAVILAND.
WHO WAS LIKE I CALL HER MY AUNT
MY AUNT JOAN I'M I I HAVE
REFERRED TO HER AS THAT FOR MANY
MANY YEARS OR SIMPLY IS JONES?
JOAN WAS ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
THAT COMES INTO YOUR FAMILY'S
LIVES.
AND A CHANGES IT PROFOUNDLY AND
THEN JONES CASE FOR THE BETTER --
JOHN MARGARET MURPHY WAS BORN ON
MAY SECOND.
THE SAME DAY AS OUR SON RUDY WAS
BORN SHE ALWAYS CALLED THEM.
HER BIRTHDAY BOY.
IS BORN NINETEEN THIRTY TWO IN
VANCOUVER BRITISH COLUMBIA TO
WILLIAM CAMERON MURPHY AND
ESTHER KING.
DURING WORLD WAR TWO WHEN ONLY
TWELVE YEARS OLD HER MOTHER
PASSED AWAY WELL HER FATHER
SERVED AS A BRIGADIER GENERAL IN
THE CANADIAN ARMED FORCES.
HER DREAM HAD ALWAYS BEEN TO
BECOME A NURSE AND IN SPITE OF
BEING DIAGNOSED WITH SEVERE
RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS IS.
SEVENTEEN SHE WENT ON TO
COMPLETE A NURSING DEGREE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF BRITISH COLUMBIA.
SHORTLY AFTERWARD SHE IMMIGRATED
TO THE UNITED STATES SETTLING IN
WORKING IN THE WASHINGTON DC
AREA.
HERE SHE MET HER FIRST HUSBAND
MARRIED AND HAVE THREE WONDERFUL
DAUGHTERS.
WITHIN FIVE YEARS THAT MOVED TO
THE WEST COAST AND LIVE FIRST IN
SEATTLE WASHINGTON THAN
HOLLYWOOD CALIFORNIA.
WHERE HER HUSBAND WORKED AS A
SET DESIGNER FOR PLENTY OF
PICTURES?
AND THIS IS WHERE SHE ENTERED
INTO OUR FAMILIES LIVES MY
FATHER WAS AN ACTOR AND AND I
HAD MET.
HER -- HER
HUSBAND --
JONES HAS BEEN A WALT AND I OR
FAMILIES GOT TO BE GOOD FRIENDS
[inaudible]
AND EVENTUALLY JONAH DAUGHTERS
PUT DOWN ROOTS IN CHATSWORTH
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S WHERE MY
MEMORIES REALLY BEGAN UP GOING
TO JONES HOUSE.
OUT FOR SWIMMING AND HORSEBACK
RIDING SHE PURCHASED THAT
PROPERTY AND LOUDER DO INDULGE
IN HER.
LOVE OF ANIMALS ESPECIALLY DOGS
AND HORSES AND WE'RE CHILDREN
ARE OLDER --
CONTINUED HER NURSING CAREER IN
THE HOME HEALTH FIELD.
UPON RETIRING SHE WENT ON TO
JOIN MANY ADVENTURES TRAVELING
WITH A CLOSE FRIEND MY MOTHER
[inaudible]
CLAUDINE.
MORE RECENTLY SHE RESIDED IN SAN
ANSELMO CALIFORNIA.
IN SIMI VALLEY CALIFORNIA WHERE
SHE PASSED AWAY ON APRIL TWENTY
EIGHTH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN JOAN IS
REMEMBERED AS A WONDERFUL MOTHER
AND NANA TOURIST SIX
GRANDCHILDREN A SPUNKY LOVING
FRIEND WHO PERSEVERED THROUGH
MANY HEALTH CHALLENGES.
AND A WOMAN WHO ALWAYS SAID SHE
WAS GRATEFUL TO KNOW OUR LORD
JESUS CHRIST.
JOAN HAVEL IN THE SURVIVED BY
HER SISTER JOAN WERE A PATRICIA
MURPHY HER DAUGHTERS VICTORIA
SUSAN AND KIMBERLY.
AND HER GRANDCHILDREN TAVIA
LYNSEY SAMUEL.
KEIRA KAYLA AND RYLAN.
AND ONE FINAL NOTE IT WAS JOAN
WHO -- MANY
WAY SAVED OUR FAMILY --
SHE HOW MY MOM OPENED OUR FIRST
BUSINESS.
USE THAT PERSON IS THAT I
BELIEVE IN YOU.
THOUGHT TO BE OKAY.
SHE ALSO TOLD ME MY WHOLE LIFE.
YOU CAN DO IT.
YOU'RE SMART YOU'RE CAPABLE
[inaudible]
AND THE PROBABLY THE MOST.
MOVING THING DEMI WAS WHEN SHE
FINALLY BECAME A U. S. CITIZEN
APPEARS AGO IN SOME OF THE FIRST
PERSON.
YOU GOT TO VOTE FOR WITH ME.
AND THAT'S NOT THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE START WITH THE PARTS OF THE
STORY IS THE FACT THAT.
I DON'T KNOW.
YOU KNOW MY MOM WAS VERY --
DILIGENT AND PERSEVERING TYPE
PERSON.
BUT IT ALWAYS TAKES FRIENDS AND
AND FAMILY AND JOAN WAS LIKE
FAMILY TO US AND HER DAUGHTERS
ARE LIKE SISTERS TO ME.
AND IT'S IT WAS HARD LOSING
JONES JUST LIKE IT'S HARD AS MY
MOM TWO YEARS AGO --
BECAUSE SHE WAS ALWAYS THERE FOR
A FOUGHT FOR FOR OUR FAMILY IN
FACT SHE WAS THE ONE THAT TOLD
ME THAT MY FATHER HAD PASSED
AWAY THAT'S HOW CLOSE SHE IS TO
OUR SO.
I JUST THINK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE AND AND I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO HER FAMILY FOR
SHARING HER WITH MY FAMILY.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN TODAY SESSION A MEMORY
OF JOAN M. HAVILAND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MR ACOSTA.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELENDEZ YOUR
RECOGNIZED HERE GERMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN I'D LIKE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY TODAY --
MISTER BILL HARRISON WHO'S A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE THAT --
I GOT TO KNOW HIM A FEW YEARS
AGO HIS WORLD WAR TWO VETERAN.
HOW MANY HAS QUITE A UNIQUE
STORY -- HE
WROTE A BOOK CALLED SIX DAYS ON
A RAFT BECAUSE HE AND EIGHT
OTHER SAILORS --
SEPTEMBER SIXTEENTH NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE BERNIE WOULDN'T HOLD
MINE SWEEPER OFF BECAUSE TO
JAPAN IN A TYPHOON CAME THROUGH.
AND CAPSIZED THE SHIP SO DURING
ALL OF THAT THEY SOMEHOW MANAGED
TO WRESTLE FROM THIS MINESWEEPER
A RAFT FOR THEM TO GET IN BUT
THE ORDERS WERE GONE ALL OF THE
YOU KNOW SURVIVAL SUPPLIES WERE
GONE.
SO THEY HAD NOTHING THEIR WORST
SHARKS CIRCLING CONSTANTLY
AROUND THIS RAFT --
AND HE MANAGED TO SURVIVE SIX
DAYS OUT THERE WITH NO FOOD NO
WATER NO ONE TO HELP THEM.
AND HE WHEN HE WAS.
I GUESS STARTING TO THINK YOU
KNOW MAYBE NO ONE WAS EVER GOING
TO FIND THEM --
HE SAID BATS [inaudible]
I MEAN.
IF YOU HE RECALLED THE THE THE
PASSAGE IN THE BIBLE THAT SAID
IF YOU HAVE THE FAITH OF A GRAIN
OF MUSTARD SEED GOD CAN MOVE A
MOUNTAIN.
AND ABOUT AN HOUR LATER HE HEARD
PLANES OVERHEAD AND WAVED HIS
ARMS AND MADE NOISE AND HE ENDED
UP BEING RESCUED --
SO HE ALWAYS.
HE HELPED EVERYONE IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT HE COULD USE THIS
WEAKEST MAN YOU COULD POSSIBLY
IMAGINE TALKED ABOUT HIS WIFE
LIKE THEY WERE SIXTEEN YEAR OLDS
IN LOVE --
IN JUST DELIGHTFUL HAD A GREAT
FAITH IN HIS GOD AND LOVED HIS
COUNTRY IN HIS COMMUNITY.
AND WERE DEATHLY GOING TO MISS
HIM SO THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
JOINING IN AND IN BILL
HARRISON'S MEMORY.
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER MELENDEZ
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER COOPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR THE
GERMAN IN ME.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY ARISE THE HEAVY HEART. TO
JOIN THE MEMORY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS IN MONTANA COWBOY
WHO CAME TO THE CHEMICAL FREE
CPA.
A PROUD MARINE WERE THE CLOSE OF
OUR COUNTRY ON A FIELD OF WAR
AND ALL ROUND MEN IN FULL WHOSE
NAME BE FAMILIAR TO MANY.
IN THE CAPITOL COMMUNITY.
JAMES FRANCIS THE BLUE.
THE FATHER CHEN TO BOOT.
MANY OF US KNOW AS A FIXED IN
ASSEMBLY.
A FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE OF MEMBER
SERVICES.
STAFF TO THREE DIFFERENT MEMBERS
NOT SUCCESSFUL CAMPAIGN MANAGER.
JAMES PASSED AWAY WEDNESDAY THE
AGE OF EIGHTY SEVEN NEARLY
TWENTY SIX YEARS AFTER HE
SUFFERED HIS FIRST MAJOR STROKE.
AND DOCTORS FIRST PREDICTED THEY
WOULD HAVE LONG TO LIVE.
WELL THOSE DOCTORS DID
UNDERSTAND AND WHAT ANYONE WHO
CHIU NEW JAMES TO BOOT DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND.
THAT HE WAS BORN A TOUGH
[inaudible]
TOUGHER STUFF.
IN FACT JAMES BILL LIFETIME
FACING OVERWHELMING OBSTACLES IN
OVERCOMING THEM.
BORN INTO POVERTY HE LISTED THE
MARINES IN THE AGE OF SEVENTEEN
WAS DECORATED FOR HIS COURAGE IN
THE KOREAN WAR.
FIGHTING ON FREEDOM'S FRONTIER.
YOU CAN THE FIRST MEMBERS THE
FAMILY TO ATTEND COLLEGE AND THE
GRADUATE SCHOOL.
THE BILL IS SUCCESSFUL
ACCOUNTING PRACTICE THEY
MAINTAIN THAT PRACTICE EVEN
AFTER A SERIES OF LIFE ALTERING
HEALTH SETBACKS.
PERHAPS MOST AMAZINGLY THIS
LIFELONG FAN OF REAGAN AND BUSH
AND CARD CARRYING IN ARE A
MEMBER SOMEHOW RAISED A SON.
WHO HAS BEEN HIS LIFE ELECTING
DEMOCRATS [inaudible]
THAT'S IMPRESSIVE.
WELL ACCOUNTS JAMES TO BE WITH
POSSESSED OF A HEART OF GOLD AND
A WILL OF IRON.
IN THE LAST.
YOU STUBBORNLY REFUSE TO STOP
LIVING IS BEST LIFE.
TODAY WE CELEBRATE A MAN WHO
SERVED HIS COUNTRY.
RAISE A FAMILY AND INJURED A
TOUGH WITH NO EXAMPLE OF
REMARKABLE HUMAN RESILIENCE.
OUR THOUGHTS ARE WITH HIS SON
AND EVERYONE WHO LOVED HIM.
ON BEHALF OF A GRATEFUL
CALIFORNIA REST IN PEACE JAMES
TO BOO.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN THEM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO JOIN IN THE MEMORY.
OF MY FORMER PROFESSOR DOCTOR
STERLING STARTING.
DOCTOR STERLING STUCKY WAS
DISTINGUISHED PROFESSOR EMERITUS.
OF HISTORY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE.
AND A PROMINENT SCHOLAR OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN HISTORY.
A CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZER IN
CHICAGO DURING THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES.
DOCTOR STARKEY WROTE NUMEROUS
BOOKS ABOUT THE HISTORY OF
AMERICAN SLAVERY.
AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
INTELLECTUAL AND CULTURAL
HISTORY.
DOCTOR STARKEY WAS A CELEBRATED
MEMBER OF THE UC RIVERSIDE
COMMUNITY.
AND INFLUENCED THE LIVES OF MANY
STUDENTS AND SCHOLARS BUYER
SPIRE INSPIRING THEIR GROWTH IN
KNOWLEDGE THE BLACKOUTS FOLKLORE
SLAVE RESISTANCE.
AND BLACK INTELLECTUAL HISTORY.
DOCTOR STARKEY WAS KNOWN FOR HIS
GENEROSITY WIT AND COMPELLING
INSIGHT.
HIS LEGACY AND DEDICATION WILL
CONTINUE TO MOLD COUNTLESS
SCHOLARS THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
FOR YEARS TO COME.
AND INSPIRED GENERATIONS TO
PROVOKE THOUGHT.
DOCTOR STUART STUDY WAS A MENTOR
AND A FRIEND TO ME AND
INSPIRATION.
YOU WILL SURELY BE MESS AND I
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR THE FIRST
APPEAR TO ADJOURNMENTS MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SPEAKER DOCTOR EDWARD SAVAGE
JUNIOR PASSED AWAY.
A JULY OF THIS YEAR AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTY FIVE A GYNECOLOGIC.
ONCOLOGISTS DOT TO SAVAGE WANTED
A FEW BOARD CERTIFIED SPECIALIST
PROVIDING MEDICAL TREATMENT FOR
WOMEN IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AREA.
DOC SAVAGE A PROUD GRADUATE OF
DELEGATED TALLADEGA COLLEGE AND
A MEMBER OF KAPPA ALPHA SITE
FRATERNITY.
AND MAY VARY MEDICAL COLLEGES
WHERE HE GRADUATED.
HE MADE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT IN
THE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION AND
WAS ON THE NATIONAL LEVEL WITHIN
THE FIELD.
OF GHANA COULD ANNIKA LOGIC
ONCOLOGY.
STARTING IS PRACTICE OF MEDICINE
AT KING DREW HOSPITAL NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE DOCTOR SAVAGE WAS
A FIGHTER FOR QUALITY HEALTHCARE
ESPECIALLY FOR RESIDENTS OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SOUTH LOS ANGELES DR SAVAGE
SERVED AT THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR
OF KING DREW MEDICAL CENTER FROM.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX TWO THOUSAND
TWO KING HOSPITAL RECEIVED AN
OUTSTANDING RATING DURING HIS
TENURE HE BELIEVED COMMUNITY
SHOULD HAVE INPUT IN THE
GOVERNANCE OF HEALTH CARE
INSTITUTION.
HE WAS A MEMBER OF MANY
ORGANIZATIONS USED ATTEMPT
PRESIDENT OF THE WESTERN
ASSOCIATION A GANIC CHO LOGIC
ONCOLOGIST --
THE NATIONAL MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND SEVEN PRESIDENT OF THE
HUNDRED BLACK MEN LOS ANGELES.
DOCTOR SAVAGE HAS WAS HONORED IN
WITH IN AT CITY HALL ARM AND SEE
ALL HALL OF FAME AWARD AT A LOSS
IN THE CITY HALL DURING THE
AFTERNOON MERRICK IN HERITAGE
MONTH.
OB DOCTOR SAVAGE AND HIS SISTER
TOTAL LIKE IT IS WHAT DO YOU
LIKE WHAT THEY SAID OR NOT THEY
ALWAYS TOLD THE TRUTH.
DOCTOR SAVAGE LEAVES TO CHERISH
AND HIS MEMORY HIS WIFE CAROL
CHILDREN CHERYL RACHEL AND
EDWARD THE THIRD.
GOV SAVAGE PINCKNEY AND A HOST
OF GRANDCHILDREN RELATIVES AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY NEVER JONES
SAWYER YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
SECOND IN GERMANY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN MEMORY OF A VERY GOOD FRIEND
OF MINE AND A CONSTITUENT OF
OURS --
PERRY ANDRE AMOS WHO PASSED AWAY
ON JUNE TWELFTH.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN PERRY WAS
BORN ON SEPTEMBER SEVENTEENTH
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE HE WAS THE
SICK CHILD BORN TO HIS PARENTS
LULA MAE JOHNSON.
AND JAMES THOMAS AMOS SENIOR HE
GREW UP WITH HIS FAMILY AND AT
LEAST SO VILLAGE HOUSING
PROJECTS UNTIL HIS MOM PURCHASE
A HOME.
AT FIVE ZERO ZERO EIGHT SOUTH
GRAMMA SEE PLACE.
PERRY ATTENDED CRENSHAW HIGH
SCHOOL WHERE HIS LOVE FOR
EDUCATION AND SERVICE TO OTHERS
FLORA.
HE GRADUATED IN THE CLASS OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WITH
HONORS AND A SCHOLARSHIP TO
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SANTA
BARBARA.
AT U. S. YET YOU SEE S. B.
CONTINUE TO BUILD UPON WHAT WILL
BECOME A LEGACY OF LEADERSHIP
AND SERVICE.
PERRY WAS NICK INITIATED INTO
CAP PROPHESY FRATERNITY INC BETO
MAKE A CHAPTER BY CHAPTER WHOM I
PLEDGE --
WHERE WHERE I PLACED HIM WE USED
TO CHAPTER POLL MARK?
WHICH MEANS PRESIDENT.
ON JUNE NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
PERRY WAS AWARDED A BACHELOR OF
ARTS DEGREE IN HISTORY UPON
GRADUATION AREN'T BURIED
RECONNECTED WITH.
CYNTHIA WARNER A GIRL FROM THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
VARIOUS INDIA WERE MARRIED ON
AUGUST SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE AND IT APRIL.
NINETEEN NINETY JOHN PERRY AMOS
WAS BORN FOUR YEARS FOUR YEARS
LATER PERRY'S BABY GIRL JESSICA
DANIELLE AMOS WAS BORN.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE PERRY
JOINED A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENT AS A
DETENTION SERVICE OFFICER AT THE
SILMAR JUVENILE.
HALL.
PERRY LOVE WORKING PROBATION IS
HARD PROMOTED TO SUPERVISING
DEPUTY PROBATION OFFICER ONE FOR
DISSENT NO LAW BEACH AREA
OFFICES INTENSIVE GAME
SURVEILLANCE UNIT.
WITH PRESIDENT WITH A BLACK
PROBATION OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
SEVERAL TERMS WAS ALSO PROUD AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE FORTY
EIGHTH NOW THE FIFTY NINE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT STEERING
COMMITTEE.
SUPERVISING DEPUTY PROBATION
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION LOCAL SEVEN
TWO ONE AND THE LOS ANGELES
PROBATION OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
LOCAL.
SIX EIGHT FIVE PERRY MENTORED
MANY YOUNG MEN MODELING AND
SHOWING THEM THE VALUE OF
EDUCATION HARD WORK AND FAMILY.
PERRY HAD A GREAT HEART.
THE FAMILY MAN ANY MADE THE
WORLD A BETTER PLACE HE WILL BE
MISSED PERRY LEAVES TO CHERISH
HIS MEMORY HIS CHILDREN HIS WIFE.
FIVE BROTHERS INCLUDING HIS TWIN
THREE THREE SISTERS AND A HOST
OF LOVING RELATIVE.
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS AND
FRIENDS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER MEMBER PLEASE BRING THE
NAMES OF TO THE DESK TO BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL REQUESTS TO GERMAN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED AND RETAINED ALL
MOTIONS SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY WILL MOVE
A SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER --
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL FRIDAY AUGUST TWENTY
FOURTH AT NINE A. M..
WE STAND ADJOURNED
.
SOME REMEMBER RODRIGUEZ VOTE
CHANGE AB.
TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE FROM I
TO NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ S. LABEL TWENTY THREE
FORTY THREE FIGHTS NOT VOTING
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RANDY VOEPEL.
AB.
TWENTY NINE TWENTY EIGHT NO TWO
I VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
TWENTY EIGHT NOTES I O'DONNELL
SP TWO FIFTEEN FROM NO TO AYE.
FELT CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL SENATE BILL TWO
FIFTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS NOTES I